MORNING. GOOD MORNING I AM
CALLING ON THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEES
IMPORTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT
HEARING TO ORDER- TODAY'S TOPIC
IS THE PERFECT STORM
CALIFORNIA'S FOR CONGESTION AND
GOODS MOVEMENT CRISIS I SHOULD
SAY IT'S NOT REALLY
CALIFORNIA'S IT'S THE WORLD'S
CRISIS- WHICH WE ARE HERE TO
RESPOND TO TODAY- I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TODAY'S HEARING. I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA OUR NEWEST
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE. SO WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA SHE
REPRESENTS THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
AND ANY TIME I CAN GET A MEMBER
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE ENGAGE
IN THE PORTS I'M HAPPY. HEY
THERE'S ELEVEN PORTS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED MORE
MEMBERS ENGAGE WITH THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE TODAY ARE
CERTAINLY ENGAGED FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS. AND THEY MAY EVEN
BE WELL OVER A HUNDRED MILES
FROM REPORT BUT I ALWAYS SAY
THERE'S A PORT. AND EVERY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND EVERY
SENATE-DISTRICT- THEY MIGHT NOT
KNOW IT RIGHT THEY NEED A PORT.
LARA I KNOW THAT VOICE ALL
RIGHT- BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY I
HAVE A STATEMENT TO READ
REGARDING OUR PROCESS TODAY WE
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HEARING THE HEARING-
HEARING ROOM SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MUST BE
WORN OF PHYSICAL DISTANCE TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU WE HAVE SEVERAL OPTIONS
FOR TESTIMONY TO DATE IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WHEN WE CALL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING AT THE END OF THE
HEARING YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE IN THIS ROOM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO PROVIDE
COMMENT. IN OUR WITNESS
TESTIFYING VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS OR USING ARE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. 1-315-401-3154 TWO
ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON YOUR SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS IT'LL BE ON YOUR
SCREEN AS WELL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
LIMITED TO ONE. MINUTE PERSON
AGAIN THAT WILL HAPPEN. TOWARDS
THE BACK END OF THE HEARING. IF
YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS-
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL MY OFFICE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO SEVEN
ZERO WE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY VIA EMAIL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOT O'DONNELL AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G. O. V.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS
WE IMPLEMENT THESE PRACTICES TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE. THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA IN A SAFE MANNER.
NOW FOR MY OPENING REMARKS AND
I'LL TURN OVER TO SENATOR-
GONZALEZ- SHARING THIS HEARING
WITH ME AND ACTUALLY WE SHARE
DISTRICTS TO. AND PORTS ON. I
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS ARE MAJOR
ECONOMIC ENGINE AND A
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF GOOD
PAYING JOBS AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE AND NATIONAL LEVEL. I
REPRESENT THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH AND THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES I HAVE BOTH PORTS IN MY
DISTRICT THOSE ARE THE TWO
LARGEST. IN THE NATION.
COLLECTIVELY KNOWN AS THE SAN
PEDRO BAY PORTS THESE TWO PORTS
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR FORTY
PERCENT. OF THE NATION'S
IMPORTS AND 25% OF ITS EXPORTS
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TODAY
WE'LL HEAR A LOT ABOUT IMPORTS.
BUT WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
EXPORTS I KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. HAS BEEN BEATING
ON ME ABOUT THIS TOPIC BECAUSE
WHEN WE THINK EXPORTS- WE THINK
AGRICULTURAL. AND SHE
REPRESENTS A LOT OF
AGRICULTURAL LOOKS INTEREST
THAT CANNOT GET THEIR GOODS OUT
IN A TIMELY FASHION. IT'S ALSO
THE BUSINESS SIDE MANUFACTURES
ACCENTURE ECCENTRIC THAT
EXPORTERS WILL. WHEN OUR PORTS
AND SUPPLY CHAIN ARE WORKING AS
INTENDED THE EFFORT OFTEN GOES
UNNOTICED PEOPLE DON'T THINK
MUCH ABOUT IT. HOWEVER WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE MIDST OF THE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION TO THE
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN. IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FOR TO SEE A
MAJOR INCREASE IN CARGO VOLUMES
WHICH HAS LED TO SIGNIFICANT
JUST CONGESTION AND STRAIN.
EVERY LEVELS OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN I MEAN THE SIMPLE ANSWER
TO THIS CRISIS. IS THAT PEOPLE
STOP BUYING STUFF. BUT THAT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN A SO WE NEED
TO RESPOND AND WHEN IT IS FRAUD
QUICKLY. THE SHIPS ARE FULL.
THE DOCKS ARE FULL AND THE
WAREHOUSES ARE FULL. THIS HAS
TURNED PUBLIC ATTENTION TOWARDS
THE PORTS AND WITH SO MUCH OF
OUR NATION'S CARGO FLOWING
THROUGH THEM EVERY DAY. THIS
HAS BECOME A NATIONAL IF NOT
WORLDWIDE ISSUE. IF YOU LIKE MY
CONSTITUENTS LIVE AND WORK NEAR
PORTS YOU CAN SEE IT FOR
YOURSELF. DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
SHIPS IDOLING OFF THE COAST
WAITING FOR THEIR TURN TO
UNLOAD CARGO. TRUCKS WITH
CONTAINERS PARKED ALONG THE
ROAD OR IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS
WHERE THEY SHOULD NOT BE. UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES SHIPS
DON'T NEED TO WAIT LONG AT
ANCHOR HOWEVER AS OF MONDAY
THEY WERE SEVENTY THREE
CONTAINER SHIPS AT ANCHOR OR
LOITERING. DOWN FROM A HIGH OF
SEVENTY NINE IN LATE OCTOBER.
WITH SO MANY SHIPS AISLING OFF
OUR COAST PORT CONGESTIONHAS
BECOME AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEM. LEADING TO A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
EMISSIONS WHICH IS A DETRIMENT
IN DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON OUR
AIR QUALITY. JUST DRIVE DOWN
OCEAN BOULEVARD IN LONG BEACH
YOU'LL SEE THE SHIPS OUT THERE
CAMPUS ACROSS HIGHWAY GO SOUTH
ON THE NEWPORT YOU'LL SEE SHIPS
GO OUT TO CATALINA ISLAND.
YOU'LL SEE I'M JUST SHARING
YOU'LL SEE- SHIPS JUST A COUPLE
MILES OFF CATALINA ISLAND SO
THE LINE IS LONG. AND IT IS
WIDE. IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR THE
SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS OFF 50%
INCREASE IN CARGO COMPARED TO
THE SAME PERIOD IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WHICH RESULTED IN AN
INCREASE OF FOURTEEN POINT FIVE
TIMES PER DAY OF OXIDES OF
NITROGEN. AND POINT TO SEVEN
TONS PER DAY OF PARTICULATE
MATTER ABOVE PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS IN THE SOUTH COAST AIR
BASIN. NOT GOOD. THAT'S
EQUIVALENT TO THE AMOUNT OF
PARTICULATE MATTER FROM THE
EXHAUST OF NEARLY FIFTY
THOUSAND CLASS EIGHT. DIESEL
TRUCKS. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT HAS ONLY INCREASED AS
THE NUMBER OF SHIPS IDLING HAS
DOUBLED. SINCE MARCH. ON TOP OF
THESE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES THIS IS ALSO
BECOMING AN ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
PROBLEMS. AS CONSUMERS FACE
SIGNIFICANT DELIVERY DELAYS AND
BEGIN TO SEE EMPTY SHELVES AT
STORES. IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
THE BACKUP IMPACTS EXPORTERS AS
WELL AS SOME AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS AND THEY'RE NOT MAKING
IT OUT BEFORE THEY GO BAD WHICH
I HAD MENTIONED WHICH I KNOW
I'M GONNA LET YOU SPEAK UP
BECAUSE YOU'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS TOPIC. IF YOU'RE DISTRICT-
BUT AGAIN THIS- IT CONGESTION-
THE PERSISTENCE BY THE HARD
WORK OUR GOODS MOVEMENT
INDUSTRY WORKERS BUSH SHOWING
GREAT RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
AN UNPRECEDENTED. WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC AND THE SUBSEQUENT
SHOCKS TO OUR SUPPLY CHAIN. OUR
WORKERS ON THE DOCKS ON THE
SHIPS IN THE WAREHOUSES ARE
WORKING HARDER AND LONGER HOURS
THAN THEY EVER HAVE BEFORE. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO THESE WORKERS
EVERYONE FROM DOCKWORKERS.
DEPORT EMPLOYEES TO TRUCK
DRIVERS TO WAREHOUSE WORKERS
EVERYONE IN BETWEEN WHO AGAIN
I'M WORKING HARDER THAN THEY
EVER HAVE. WE ARE HOLDING THIS
HEARING SO WE CAN HEAR STRAIGHT
FROM THE SOURCE WHERE THE
BOTTLENECKS ARE HAPPENING N
THE GROUND AT OUR PORTS AND
ACROSS OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
EXPLORE THE CAUSES DRIVING
CONGESTION AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
ELEVATE BOTH SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TODAY WE
REALLY DON'T NEED TO REDEFINE
THE PROBLEM WE WILL HEAR ABOUT
THE PROBLEM WE WILL HEAR
EXPLAINED OF COURSE. BUT WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOLUTIONS
BOTH SHORT TERM. AND LONG TERM.
FURTHER WE NEED YOUR DIET DIED
IN A FIRE WHAT SPECIFICALLY THE
STATE CAN DO TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES WHAT IS OUR ROLE AND HOW
DO WE WORK WITH OTHER LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS. THIS
CRISIS IN A VERY RAPID MANNER.
SOLUTIONS BASED ON MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ON THE GROUND. IT HAS BECOME
CLEAR THAT THIS IS A MULTI
FACETED PROBLEM AND IT WILL
REQUIRE MULTI FACETED ACTION
THERE IS NOT ONE SWITCH YOU CAN
FLIP. OUR CURRENT CONGESTION
CRISIS WAS CAUSED BY A PERFECT
STORM OF FACTORS FROM INCREASED
CONSUMER DEMAND TO COVERT
NINETEEN SHUT DOWNS TO A LACK
OF SUFFICIENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
LIKE ON DOCK RAIL AND STORAGE
SPACE TO ASSURE SHORTAGE OF
AVAILABLE MATERIALS LIKE
CHASSIS AND CONTAINERS THIS
PROBLEM WILL NOT BE GOING AWAY
ON ITS OWN. WITH CONSTRUCTION
CONGESTION EXPECTED TO CONTINUE
INTO NEXT YEAR. SOLVING THIS
CRISIS AND PREVENTING FUTURE
DISRUPTIONS WILL TAKE A
RESPONSE FROM ALL LEVELS OF OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN. AND GOVERNMENT. I
KNOW I HAVE MY OWN IDEAS BUT
REALLY THIS IS TO HEAR FROM
OTHER FOLKS I'VE RECEIVED CALLS
FROM THE PRESS A WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING OTHER WEATHER
SOLUTIONS I HAVEN'T JOHNSON
SAID THESE ARE THE SOLUTIONS
NOW WHAT I'M HEARING AS I'M
HEARING WHEN HIS SWEEPER SHIPS
TO GET THE EMPTIES OUT OF THE
PORTS. ON HEARING THAT THE
PORTS ARE GONNA NEED MORE LAND
WEATHER'S INSIDE PORT FOUNDERS
ARE OUTSIDE COUNTERPART ANDREAS
THAT'LL BE UP A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION AND THE CHASSIS SO
MOST PEOPLE DON'T GET IT THIS
CHASSIS IS A THAT'S THE
CARRIAGE AND THE WHEELS THAT
CARRIES A CONTAINER THERE IS A
MASSIVE SHORTAGE OF THOSE. SO
IN THE SHORT TERM THAT'S LIKELY
WHAT WE'LL HEAR ABOUT TODAY SO
I ROOM REALLY INTERESTED HERE
ABOUT THOSE THREE AREAS AND
OTHERS THAT THEY EXPERTS WILL
BRING UP MAKE US EXPERTS TODAY
THAT'S WHAT I ASK OF YOU. TODAY
WE WILL HEAR FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND FROM THE
FEDERAL STATE IS FEDERAL STATE
AND FEDERAL STATE GOVERNMENT
SUPPORTS AND THE GOODS MOVEMENT
INDUSTRY. AND AGAIN. OUR
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. OUR ROLE
TODAY AS LEGISLATORS IS TO
LISTEN TO THESE INDUSTRY
EXPERTS. AND HEAR THEIR
PERSPECTIVE. ON WHAT WE CAN DO
TO ASSIST IN EASING. CONGESTION
AND STRENGTHENING. OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN. THIS WILL BE A JOINT
HEARING AND IS A JOINT HEARING.
WITH US STATE SENATE SELECT THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
PORTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT.
CHAIRED BY SENATOR LENA
GONZALEZ- TO MY LEFT. AND I
KNOW SHE WANTED TO SAY A FEW
WORDS SENATOR. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I'M ALSO
PROUD TO JOIN EVERYBODY TODAY
AS THE CHAIR OF THE PORT SELECT
COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION IN THE SENATE-
AS WELL AS MY- BICAMERAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REALLY
APPRECIATE. OF THIS. INCREDIBLE
FORM AN A PLUS AT A TIME WHEN
WE ARE. SURPLUS OF YEARLY
DEALING WITH A CRISIS NOT ONLY
TO COVER NINETEEN. AS MENTIONED
BUT OF COURSE THROUGH THIS-
LOGISTICS CRISIS IS BECOME
NATIONAL WE'RE SEEING THIS ON
THE TV EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS MY FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS- MENTIONED BEFORE
BY MY ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE AND CO
CHAIR- I WANT TO FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE A FRONT LINE
WORKERS WHO HAVE WORKED. DAY
AND NIGHT AND DAY OUT OUR
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES FOR
BEING HERE AS WELL. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES AND OF
COURSE MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE-
GOING TO PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
QUESTIONS THAT WILL NEED TO
STREAMLINE AND OPERATIONS
IMPACTFUL INVESTMENTS STRONG
BUSINESS AND WORKFORCE
ENVIRONMENTS. AND I WILL
ULTIMATELY AND WE HOPE TO KEEP
CONSUMERS HAPPY LOWER EMISSIONS
AT OUR PORTS AND ULTIMATELY
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA PORTS.
ARE GLOBALLY COMPETITIVE- I
KNOW THAT ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHETHER YOU. REPRESENT A PORT
OR NOTS YOU ALL HAVE SOME.
PLACE IN THIS DISCUSSION AND I
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU AS WELL.
EVERY REGION OF CALIFORNIA IS
DEALING WITH THIS- OF COURSE AS
WE TALKED ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
CONSUMER DEMANDS LABOR
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. A COMPLEX GLOBAL
TRADE AND COVER NINETEEN
CONSTRAINTS. RECORD BREAKING
CARGO VOLUMES WAREHOUSE VACANCY
RATES THAT ARE VERY LOW. AND
POOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
FRUSTRATED- WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM THEM AS WELL. AND AGAIN
REGIONAL PERSPECTIVE SO I LOOK
FOR TO THIS CONVERSATION I
THINK MY CULTURE AND COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL. AND
I THINK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE
AS WELL. GREAT THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. MEMBERS JUST
WHICH IS IF YOU WERE UP. MR
FONG KAMALA. A THIS IS YOUR- MR
ONE OF YOU'VE GOT. WE'RE GONNA
ARM WRESTLE FOR THIS IN THE
SECOND- GOOD MORNING- EVERYONE
I WANT TO THANK FIRST OF ALL
CHAU DAHLE INSURE GONZALEZ FOR
PUTTING THIS INTO IMPORTANT.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TOGETHER
I'M AS WE ALL KNOW THE PANDEMIC
HAS CAUSED MANY ISSUES THAT THE
PORTS. FROM BACKLOGS TO
CHANGING PROTOCOLS AND
DISRUPTION IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
YOU KNOW AS WE CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS I HEARD EVERYONE
HERE TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
AGRICULTURE IN MINE. AND AT THE
TABLE BECAUSE THEY ARE VITAL TO
OUR ECONOMY. JUST IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR
GENERATED OVER FORTY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE STATE
ECONOMY WHICH COME COMPRISES
TWELVE POINT 5% OF THE TOTAL-AGRICULTURE. PRODUCTION AMONG
ALL FIFTY STATES. A GREAT DEAL
OF ATTENTION ON IT IS ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES CONFRONTING
THESE ENTITIES BRING IN GOODS
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DEPENDSHEAVILY ON THE EXPORTING OF ITS
GOODS AND I CANNOT OVERSTATE
THIS ENOUGH WE ARE IN AN URGENT
POSITION. I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
HEARING TODAY FROM THE
PANELISTS TODAY TO HEAR ABOUT
THE WORK THAT IS BEING DONE AND
WHAT POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND I AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
TODAY. PREFIGURE SOME REGULAR
KERR AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHTED YOU EARLY ON
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP I'D BEEN
ON MY MIND BEING FROM LONG
BEACH IS THE ONLY AREA I KEPT
THINKING IMPORTS IMPORTS AND I
DIDN'T WITHOUT YOUR EDUCATION
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. A SIMILAR FONG
YOU'RE JUST DOWN THE PORT
DURING THE OTHER DAY SO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING INTEREST IN THE
TIME TO DRIVE ALL THE WAY OVER
THOSE HILLS AND COME TO THE
PORT AND SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH MR FONG. HELLO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR AND BOTH RESPECTIVE
CHAIRS- THIS ACTIVITIES AND
THERE'S AFTER THIS HEARING I DO
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE TOUR
THAT YOU PROVIDED ME- THERE ARE
REAL WORLD CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
CRISIS AND I GOT TO SEE THAT
FIRSTHAND- WITH OVER FOUR
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS OF.
CARGO MOVING TO THE PORTS OF
LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH
EVERY YEAR NOW WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AND THERE
NEED TO BE A SENSE OF URGENCY-
CONSUMER DEMAND HAS INCREASED-
AND WE HAVE LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES AND STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS- THAT HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED BUT THIS CRISIS AS
MUCH BEFORE STRETCHES BEYOND
REPORTS- THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FARMERS ARE SUFFERING. ARE
STATES RENT RENOWNED AG
PRODUCTS ARE NOT BEING EXPORTED
AS THEY WOULD IN A NORMAL YEAR
IN FACT FARMERS ARE SEEING A
20% REDUCTION IN THEIR EXPORT
OPPORTUNITIES. AND AN ESTIMATED
SIXTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
CARGO IS IDLING ON THE COAST
WAITING TO UNLOAD WITH THE
HOLIDAYS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER CHRISTMAS IN THE MONTHS
BEYOND MAY BE DIFFERENT FOR
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND AS WE SEE WITH ALL WITH AS
WE CAN SEE WITH ALL THOSE ON
THE AGENDA AND THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE FROM RETAILERS TO
PORTS TRANSPORTATION LABOR
THERE'S SO MANY COMPONENTS IN
INDUSTRIES INVOLVED AND WE NEED
URGENT ACTION AND COLLABORATION
NOT JUST IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS BUT TO FIND LONG
TERM STRUCTURAL SOLUTIONS. TO
ADAPT TO A CHANGING ECONOMY.
AND WORKFORCE WE MUST ALSO-
REEVA. THE POLICY- AND RULES.
IN PLACE. SOME OF THEM PUT IN
PLACE TO BUY- SACRAMENTO. THAT
HAS MADE THIS CRISIS WORSE. AND
WILL MAKE THINGS WORSE IN THE
FUTURE. CALIFORNIA HEARING FROM
ALL THE PANELISTS HERE TODAY
AND WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES
TO CLEAR THIS SUPPLY CHAIN
CLOG. THERE HAS TO BE A SENSE
OF URGENCY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR FONG- ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
RESPOND THANK YOU TEARS- DONALD
ENDS GONZALEZ FOR CONVENING
THIS HEARING AND INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING WITH IMPACTS ON
CONSUMERS WORKERS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR COMMUNITIES
MY NAME IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ME
UP ONTO A REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHTEEN TH
DISTRICT AND THE COMMUNITIES OF
OAKLAND ALAMEDA AND SAN LEANDRO
AND THIS IS MY FIRST HEARING ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE OF THE
PORTS OF GOODS AND MOVEMENT
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE. AT CALIFORNIA IS
THE PRIMARY DESTINATION FOR
TRANSPACIFIC TRADE SERVING AS A
GATEWAY FOR GOODS TO TRAVEL
ACROSS THE US AND SO IT IS NO
SURPRISE THAT THE PORTS CRISIS
HAS HIT US THE HARDEST AND SO
WHILE WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO THE NATION TO ALLEVIATE THE
CRISIS WE ALSO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CALIFORNIA
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THAT
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CURE IS NOT WORSE THAN
THE ILLNESS AND FOR TOO LONG
COMMUNITIES LIKE OAKLAND AND
LONG BEACH HAVE BEEN POLLUTED
AND NEGLECTED IN THE NAME OF
PROGRESS. AND EVERY DAY SHIPS
ARE ANCHORED WAITED TO UNLOAD
AT WE CONTINUE TO POLLUTE OUR
AIR STYMIE OUR ECONOMY AND
HIBBETT OUR WORKERS FROM
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE A GOOD
DAY OF WORK A LOT MORE TRUCKS
AND MORE TRAINS TO UNLOAD ON
THE SHIPS AND ALSO THAT MEANS
MORE DIESEL BURNED AND
EMISSIONS WHICH HAVE A COST TO
THEM. THAT'S WHY I'M HOPING
DEARLY THAT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
WHICH IS EXPERIENCING A 50%
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW HAS THE
ABILITY TO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION WHICH HAS THE CAPACITY
AND THE WORK FORCE TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THE SUPPLY CHAIN
BACKLOG LIMITING THE IDOLING
AND ADDITIONAL EMISSIONS THAT
COME COMMUNITIES AND THE LA AND
LONG BEACH ARE EXPERIENCING
RIGHT NOW SO TODAY WHILE I
OBSERVE THE CHALLENGE AND
LISTEN FOR ANSWERS I DO SO WITH
AN EYE TOWARDS OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ENSURING THAT OAKLAND AND
THE PORT OF OAKLAND ARE A PART
OF THAT SOLUTION AND ENSURING
WE DON'T COMPOUND ECONOMIC
INJUSTICES WITH FURTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ONES. THANK YOU
ALL AND I LOOK FOR TODAY'S
DISCUSSION NAME IS BONTA ANY
OTHER MEMBERS PUSH TO COMMENT
AS WE OPEN UP MISTER GIBSON. TO
HAVE REPRESENTED WILMINGTON
VERY VERY POOR TO PAY. IS JUST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
DONALD TO. THAT'S YOUR MEMBER
GONZALEZ THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR- LED ME TO HAVE A FEW
OPPORTUNITIES IS GIVE. A FEW
OPENING COMMENTS- I'M CERTAINLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO IS VERY
ROBUST AGENDA AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO- DIALOGUE THAT LEADS
TO REAL SOLUTIONS- I HAVE A
DISTRICT AND I'M HONORED TO
REPRESENT THE SIXTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT INCLUDES
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES. ON THE
WILMINGTON AREA- MY DISTRICT IS
IT IS IT IS VERY KEY TO THE
MOVEMENT. OF THE GOODS MOVEMENT
IN THE CORRIDOR- AND HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
ECONOMY AND JOBS IN THE STATE.
OF THE DELAYS AND CONGESTIONS
OF THE GOODS MOVEMENT CAN IN
FACT AND WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. ON OUR
ECONOMY IF WE DON'T GET A
RIGHT- RIGHT NOW. OF THE
DISTRICT IS ALSO HOME TO
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES WHICH
I REPRESENT. AREAS OF COMPTON
CARS A WOMAN TO NORTH LONG
BEACH LYNWOOD GUARDIANAND ALSO
TOWARDS- THE PUBLIC SAFETY THIS
IS THREATENED- AND A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS WE HAVE
CONTAINERS- THAT OUR POWER
HIGH- IN IN VERY DANGEROUS.
AREAS AS WELL AS WE'VE HAD A- A
CONTAINER- TURN OVER ON A CAR
THANK GOD THERE WAS. NO ONE IN
THE CAR. AND IT IS JUST A JUST
A HIGHLIGHT JUST SOME OF THE
ISSUES- THAT I'VE BEEN
BOMBARDED WITH WITH CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND- THINGS OF
THAT NATURE IN TERMS OF TRUCKS.
ON STREETS BLOWING AT STOP
SIGNS. I LINK JUST IN THE
STREET INTERSECTION THINGS OF
THAT NATURE. AND SO I THINK
THIS CONVERSATIONS ABSOLUTELY
TIMELY- TO US TRYING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO THIS PARTICULAR
DILEMMA WE ARE GRATEFUL- THAT
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE THE
PORT ARE WORKING SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK AROUND THE CLOCK. BUT IT
IS CERTAINLY COMING AT A PAY A
HEAVY COSTLY HEAVY PRICE- THAT
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING. AND
REACHING SOME KIND OF
SOLUTIONS- THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BECAUSE I WE HAVE ALL
STYLE IN OUR TO BE ABLE HEAR
FROM- THOSE WHO ARE ON AGENDA
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR- TO GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON ANY
OTHERS- MISTER MISTER BRADFORD
SENATOR BRADFORD WHO REPRESENTS
SUPPORT OF LOS ANGELES. FOR
OKAY. WHAT DO YOU GO. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE HERE I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THAT EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID
HERE ALL THE ABOVE IS TRUE CHAU
I ALSO WANT TO THINK THAT THE
PRESENTERS- FOR BEING
AVAILABLE- FOR SHARING THEIR
THEIR CURRENT CHALLENGES. AS
THE STATE THAT WERE FACING
SUPPLY CHAIN- MANY OF OUR LOCAL
OF ALL MY COLLEAGUES ARE ARE
SHARING SIMILAR CONCERNS THANK
THAT IS BEING EXPRESSED HERE I
WANT TO THANK- FOLKS ARE
TALKING ABOUT OUR AG. PRODUCERS
AND PROCESSORS HAVE POINTED
OUT- THE BOTTLENECK CONTINUES
TO HURT ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES
SO. WE'RE NOT HERE TO BLAME
ANYONE FOR TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN DO IN A FIGURE OUT
THIS FIX. I DO WANT TO OFFER
THAT- YOU KNOW THAT HOPEFULLY
WE CAN LOOK AT EVEN- A SMALLER
EVEN SMALLER PORTS LIKE THE
PORT OF STOCKTON I THAT I
REPRESENT. WE'RE NOT IN
COMPETITION YOU KNOW WE
SHOULDN'T BE IN COMPETITION
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW AND FIX. SO I
JUST AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE VICE CHAIR FOR BRING
THESE ISSUES UP. THANK YOU
MISTER RIVERA AND ACTUALLY I
WAS ON THE PHONE SOME YOUR
CONSTITUENTS JUST LAST WEEK-
AGAIN BROUGHT ME FURTHER
EDUCATION. IT'S NOT JUST
ADDRESS FORTY OF COURSE BUT
IT'S ALSO YOU HAVE SOME SOME
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT
MANUFACTURE. PIECES OF LARGE
EQUIPMENT THAT THE SHIP AROUND
THE WORLD THAT ARE. FUNNY
CHALLENGES THEMSELVES RIGHT NOW
SO THANK YOU FELT AFTER WITH
THAT AS SENATOR BRADFORD
REPRESENTS THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I TO JUST GET OUT GO
MUCH OF WHAT IS ALREADY BEEN
SAID- AS REPRESENTING THE
LARGEST PORT IN THE NATION WE
SEE THE IMPACT ON THE DAILY
BASIS WE FILL IT ON A DAILY
BASIS. AND THIS IS NOT JUST A
CALIFORNIA ISSUE THIS IS A
NATIONAL ISSUE THIS IS A WORLD
ISSUE SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY AS- YOU MY
COLLEAGUE STATED- SPECIALLY THE
IMPACTS THAT. RESIDENTS OR
EXPERIENCE IN OUTSIDE OF THE
WORK FORCE BUT THE RESIDENTS IN
THE SPIKE IN PRICES SO JUST
WORKING COLLABORATIVE COME UP
WITH ANSWERS TO MAKE SURE. THAT
WE COME UP WITH A FIX THAT'S
RESPONSIVE TO BOTH- THE
INDUSTRY THE STATE AND THOSE
CONSUMERS. WHO NEED THESE
PRODUCTS TODAY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE OR HEAR AGAIN- WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON IS- I. IS ONE
OF THE SOLUTIONS. BOTH SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM AND REALLY
WHAT IS THE STATE'S ROLE. IN IN
IN GETTING US. GOING THOSE
MOVING US TO THOSE SOLUTIONS
AND HOW WE WORK WITH OTHER
LEVELS. TO ACHIEVE THOSE
SOLUTIONS WITH THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR ON- CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPORT CONGESTION AND GOODS
MOVEMENT CRISIS. AS DANNY ONE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PORT AUTHORITIES
HE WILL SHARE AN OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT. PORT
CONGESTION. AND GOODS MOVEMENT
CRISIS. AGAIN HE IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION.
HEADS UP PORT OF OAKLAND. AND
THEIR ELEVEN PORTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH THAT LET'S
HEAR FROM A PRESIDENT ONE. YOU
MAY PERCEIVE IN REDDING. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY AND NOT WITH
DONALD AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS STANDARD
GONZALEZ ON THIS ISSUE AND I
LIKE TO WHILE COMMA MY ASSEMBLY
PERSON THAT SOMEBODY BONTA TO
THIS COMMITTEE VERY HAPPY THAT-
WE HAVE A CHAT WITH YOU AS WELL
TODAY- AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
THE CALL COMMITTEE FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING TO
DISCUSS THIS ISSUE- I ALSO AND
THESE ARE GOOD DRUGS OVER THE
PORT OF OAKLAND. WHICH HAS-
SERVICE MANY OF THE EXPORT
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES WE ARE
FIFTY FIFTY PERCENT- EXPORT
IMPORT PORT. SO THE EXPORTERS.
AMY IS FELT ACUTELY SO I JUST
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE THAT
KNOWLEDGE THE ONLY ISSUES THAT
SOME OF THE MEMBERS APPOINTED
OUT. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE SYSTEM APPOINT
THE NATION INCLUDING THREE OF
OUR COUNTRY'S LARGEST CONTAINER
PORTS AND A DIVERSE ASSEMBLY
SPECIALTY PORTS. ELEVEN PORT
AUTHORITIES ARE COMPRISED THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION PORT
AUTHORITIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
HANDLING 40% OF THE
CONTAINERIZED. IMPORTS AND 30%
OF ALL EXPORTS IN THE NATION.
US CONSUMER DEMAND START ROCKET
THE CONTAINER AND CARGO PORTS
COMBINED AT FACILITATING THE
MOVEMENT OF HISTORIC VOLUMES
WE'RE DOING THE JOB. BUT WE
NEED TO SOLVE THESE ISSUES OF
RESILIENCY IN THE TIMES OF
EXTRAORDINARY. CIRCUMSTANCES IN
THE MEANTIME OUR CREWS A
VISITOR ORIENTED PORTS AS WELL
AS OTHER ACTIVITIES CONTINUE TO
RECOVER WHEN I DROP POPPING
DEMAND. THE PROLEM IS THAT THE
WALL STATED BY ASSEMBLY
PERSONAL DONALD MEMBERS TO
COMMITTEES I WON'T REHASH THOSE
DISCHARGING CARGO MATE THE PAST
TWO YEARS OVERALL AMONG THE
BUSIEST HIS EIGHT YEARS IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA POINTS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY AGAIN ACUTE
AMOUNT THE WITH THOSE WORKING
THE STATE'S AGRICULTURAL EXPORT
COMMUNITIES. THE SITUATION GET
RIGHTFULLY DEMANDS INCREASED
COLLABORATION COOPERATION A
SOLUTIONS FOR ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. ALL PRIVATE SECTOR
SAKEHOLDERS. ALL OF THE BLANKS
IN ITS SUPPLY CHAIN. IT ALSO
OFFERS LESSONS ABOUT OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN RESILIENCY IN
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES. AND AS YOU
KNOW THESE EXTRAORDINARY TIMES
INVENSYS SEEM TO BECOME THE
ORDINARY. RECENTLY CATHOLIC
GOING TO SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS
SUMMIT ADVISING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE BUSINESS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK- DIRECTOR- CANAL FOR
HAVING CONVENE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS
TO WORK ON SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES.
OPERATIONALLY HAPPEN MEMBER
PORTS HAVE PRO PRO ACTIVELY
TAKEN STEPS TO ALLEVIATE SUPPLY
CHAIN CONGESTION. IT IS STEPS
UP INCLUDED CREATING POLICIES
THAT INCENTIVIZE TURN TIMES TO
MAKE SURE IT TOO MANY TIMES A
QUICK AND YOUR TRANSACTIONS SO
WHEN A TRUCK IT'S FULL IN WITH-
TO TWO WITH A CAGR LOW THE GLOW
CARGO FOR EXPORT AS WELL AS GO
OUT. WITH THE IMPORT CARGO TO
ELECT. IMPLEMENTED BEST
PRACTICES IN SHORT IT IS A
BETTER USE OF CAR HELLO
CAPACITY USE. OF EXISTING TRUCK
GATES APPOINTMENTS. WELL CARGO-
OWNERS BY. GATE AT. PROVIDING
GREATER TRANSPARENCY
INFORMATION. SO THAT WE INCLUDE
WE IMPROVE CARGO VELOCITY AND
EFFICIENCY. EXTENDING ATE
HOURS AT CERTAIN PORT TERMINALS
WHERE NEEDED TO EVALUATE ITS
IMPACT ON RELIEVING CONGESTION.
SO WE ARE TAKING A SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS NONETHELESS THE
CHALLENGES FACING OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
COORDINATION EFFORTS AMONG
PRIVATE FINANCING PARTNERS.
THANK YOU STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. HELLO
CALIFORNIA PORTS ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA BOARDS DPC ACCESS
THE FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE
FUNDS IN THE STATE BUDGET CYCLE
THE GUIDELINES BUT IT TO A
SMALL GROUP OF PORTS BUT DIRECT
pWHICH MIGHT ADDRESS GREAT
CONGESTION. AND IN WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT LONG TERM SOLUTIONS ONE
OF THOSE HAS TO BE ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. THE
CURRENT CONGESTION THAT WE SEE
IS PARTLY A RESULT OF DECADES
OF UNDER INVESTMENT IN ALL
PORTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT SUPPLY
CHAIN. THIS IS A BIGGER NOTABLY
THERE ISN'T NEARLY ELEVEN TO
ONE. I DON'T TRANSPORTATION A
WATERSIDE SPENDING A POOR
COMPLEXES AROUND THE COUNTRY
VERSUS BOTH MATING CURING
CALIFORNIA. IT IS A PATTERN IN
WHICH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND OTHER STATES INVESTMENTS
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA HAVE BIG ALL
SPENDING US IN CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY MANY STATES TO
CONTINUE TO COMPETE FOR CARGO
TRADITIONALLY HAS COME TO
CALIFORNIA PORTS ALONG WITH THE
JOBS AND ECONOMIC VITALITY THAT
COMES WITH. OUR CREW DEDICATED
EVERY CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THEIR
HOME PORTS THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT I WE WILL HOPE TO
HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSION. IS A-
ASSISTANT INVESTMENT IN OUR
PORTS IN CALIFORNIA. AS MANY OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES ARE
GLOBAL AND HAVE OVERLAPPING
AREAS OF FEDERAL JURISDICTION
WE APPLAUD THE RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENT BY A FEDERAL AND
STATE TRANSPORTATION PARTNERS
FOR ENHANCE COLLABORATION ON
DELPHINUS SUPPORTING KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
CAN HELP TO SPEED UP THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. THERE ARE ALSO SEVERAL
SHORT TERM MEDIUM TO LONG TERM
INITIATIVES AND PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WE BELIEVE CAN HELP TO
ADVANCE THE SOLUTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. FIRST ENCOURAGE AND
INCENTIVISE ALL THE SUPPLIES
YOU PARTNERS UTILIZED AND
MAXIMIZED CAPACITY IN ALL TRADE
GATEWAYS. I'M A AND- THE IDEA
AND- I THINK I JUST ON ONE
SLIDE TO SHOW YOU TO ILLUSTRATE
THIS POINT. AND IF I MAY. C.
OKAY. WELL AS EXPECTED I'M NOT
FINDING THIS SITE BUT I THINK
THE PROBLEM HERE IS I WAS
TALKING TO ONE OF THE- TERMINAL
OPERATORS IN OAKLAND LAST WEEK.
THIS IS AMAZING TO ME AS I SAID
AT THE TERMINAL CARE ACT
TERMINAL. YOU LOOK ON THE BAY
AND THE WHOLE TIME I WAS
ENERGY. ENERGY OF CONTAINERS
AND YOUR SHIPS AND THE OPERATOR
TELLS ME THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IN THEIR HISTORY OR THEIR
OPERATING OAKLAND THT THEY
HAVE NOT HAD ONE VESSEL CALL.
SO THIS IS AN EXAMPLE. OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN DICTATING IN THIS
KIND OF A MARKET DISTORTION.
ALL THE SUPPLY IN THE CARGO IS
NOW MOVING THROUGH OUR A LOT
I'M NOT ALL THAT A NOT LOT OF
THE- SHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
CALLING PORTABLE CONTENT NOW
SKIPPING THAT PORT. AND PUTTING
THAT CARGO IN NOW IN LONG
BEACH. THIS ASSEMBLY PERSONS-
POINTED OUT THIS IS NOT A
COMPETITION. ALL RIGHT ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS HEALTHY TO
ENCOURAGE OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
PARTNERS REALIZE A MAXIMUM
CAPACITY. IN ALL THE TRADE
GATEWAYS. NEXT ADVICE. STATION
PROPERTIES WHAT TEMPORARY.
STORAGE IN ADDITION TO LOSING
THE RESTRICTIONS OF HYPING. OFF
TEMPORARY STORAGE. WE HAVE THAT
THE STATE'S COOPER. IDENTIFY
PROPERTIES FOR THIS KIND OF
TALK A CRISIS FOR STORAGE. NEXT
SUPPORT EXEMPTIONS FOR PURCHASE
OF WARM HSCS INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF KEY EQUIPMENT USE THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. ONE OF THE ISSUES
OF SUPPLY CHASSIS SHORTAGE IS
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE LACK OF-
SUPPLY CURRENTLY PHONE FORM A
CHASSIS. EVEN THOUGH WE
UNDERSTAND THAT MADE AMERICA IS
AN OBJECTIVE AT THIS TIME WE
BOUGHT THAT CHASSIS IS TO BE
MADE AND SHIPPED OVER TO EUROPE
FOR SUPPLY. THANKS CONVENING A
SUPPLY CHAIN OF RG GROUP WITH
THIRD PARTY STAKEHOLDERS THAT
DEDICATED POINT PERSON. A
DEDICATED PERSON WITHIN A STATE
LEADERSHIP TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A CALIFORNIA FRENCH
POLICY THAT CAN IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL LEVERS TO EACH
CONTRACTIONS IN TIME OF CRISIS.
YES WE NEED TO CONTINUE EFFORTS
TO DEVELOP A ROLL OUT WORKFORCE
TRAINING INITIATIVES IN
INCREASING THE PIPELINE FOR
SKILLED LABOR THIS IS A SUPPLY
CHAIN WORKFORCE JOBS. ALSO WE
NEED TO DESIGNATE FUNDING FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT DATA SOLUTIONS
IMPLEMENTING A PILOT PROJECTS
TO CREATE MORE VISIBILITY. AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE SUPPL
CHAIN WHAT NEED MORE DATA
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHERE THE
CARGO IS AT ANY TIME. ADD OR
THAT CONNECTION IS MADE RIGHT
NOW ALL THE INFORMATION IS NOT
TRANSPARENT WE NEED SOME KIND
OF BEST MUCH INTO THAT DATA AND
ONE THAT'S UNIFORM ACROSS THE
PORTS. CREATE A SUPPLY CHAIN
INVESTMENT FUND THEY CAN ALSO
BE USED. QUICKLY LIKE CHASSIS
SOME CONTAINERS AND A SHORT
TERM. AND ADVANCE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN
LONG TERM. ONE OF THOSE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AS ON THE ASSEMBLY
PERSONS POINTED OUT IS
INTRODUCTION OF EMISSIONS WE
NEED ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURES
THE PORTS WE NEED- IT
INFRASTRUCTURE DATA WAREHOUSING
THE CLOSER TO THE SOURCE OF
THESE CARGO. AND THAT'S THE
KIND OF INVESTMENT WE NEED. IN
CLOSING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THESE
PRESSING ISSUES WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUES AS WE
DRESS OUR PART IN THE GLOBAL
CONGESTION CHALLENGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ONE OF PRESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MR ONE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PORT AUTHORITIES
OFFER THE KIND OF BIG PICTURE
THE OVERVIEW AND POTENTIALLY
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS DO WE
HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS FROM A
MEMBER CENTER. YES THANK YOU
PRESIDENT ONE FOR YOUR- YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR NEW- OF THAT ELECTION
TO THE PRESIDENCY OF KAPPA
KAPPA. I'M JUST A QUESTION IN
TERMS OF THE MAX CAPACITY
AVERAGE- FOR I KNOW PORT OF LA
LONG BEACH SEEMS TO BE HIRED-
POTENTIALLY THAN THE OTHER
NINE- PORTS BUT WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE AND HOW. CAN WE
ENSURE THAT- IF THERE ARE- IF
THERE IS A CARGO COMING IN TO
PORT OF LA AND LONG BEACH THAT
THEY CAN POTENTIALLY STAY IN
CALIFORNIA- PORTS. I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LOGISTICAL SORT OF ISSUES WITH
THAT- REGARDING RELATIONSHIPS
AND SIZE OF SHIPS BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING WHAT. COULD BE
DISCUSSED IN THAT IN THAT SPACE.
ABSOLUTELY THE GOAL IS TO- ONE
OF THE GOALS IS TO KEEP A CARGO
COMINGTO CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO
KEEP THE AVAILABILITY OF
CONTAINERS I ENTITIES FOR
EXPORTERS TO PUT THEIR CARGO
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE CARDINAL
INTO THOSE CONTENTIOUS TO ASIA.
SO THAT'S OUR GOAL YOU AND
CALIFORNIA PORTS. WHAT
CURRENTLY IS HAPPENING IS THAT
SOME OF THE CARGOES BEING
DIVERTED OF COURSE TO. OTHER
NON CALIFORNIA PORTS AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING EVEN BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC- SO THAT'S A
DISTURBING TREND. BUT SECONDLY
I DID CURRENTLY. SO I GUESS
SAID THE PRICE DISTORTION IS
SUCH THAT. THE CARGO A
COMMANDING SUCH PRICES THAT IS
IT IS- PROBABLY INCENTIVIZING.
THE FAST MOVEMENTS. OF FAST
MOVING THE CARGO TURN AROUND TO
GO BACK TO ASIA. SO WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS SOME OF THOSE SHIPS
IT SHIPPING LINES SO USED TO
CALL L. A. LONG BEACH FIRST.
THE DROP OF KAGEL DESIGNATED
FOR THAT POOR AND THEN GOLD IN
OAKLAND THE JUDGE DROPPED OFF A
CARD OVER THAT PORT AND
IMPORTANTLY PICK UP EXPORTS.
FROM THE AG EXPO- INDUSTRY WILL
GO BACK TO ASIA. NOW WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO NOW THEY'RE
DOING IS SIMPLY DROPPING OFF
THE CAR THE L. IN LONG BEACH.
ALL THE CLUB EVEN THOSE THAT
USED TO BE. SHIPPED TO OAKLAND
AND THEN GOING BACK TO ASIA
DIRECTLY BUT THAT'S CAUSING IS
OF COURSE ADDING TO THE
CONGESTION IS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PETER PORTS. AND
EVEN CAPACITY WANTING IN
OAKLAND AND AS WE HEARD FONG
STOPPED IN OTHER PORTS.
INDICATE ANY ASSOCIATION. HAS A
CAPACITY YOU. CURRENTLY OAKLAND
HOW. I THINK TWENTY BY PERCENT
BUT THEY CAPACITY WE COULD.
ACCOMMODATE TO HELP RELIEVE THE
CONGESTION AT THE ST PEDRO
COURTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHONE. I THINK
YOU ARE THE PRESENT ONE- I
WANTED TO DIVE INTO A PART OF
YOUR STATEMENT YOU SAID THAT
OTHER STATES HAVE INVESTED IN
THEIR PORTS- TO EXPAND THE
CAPACITY- I WONDER IF YOU CAN-
TO PROVIDE A BIT MORE SPECIFICS
WHAT HAVE OTHER STATES DONE- IN
THEIR INVESTMENTS AND I KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PORTS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED- THE
FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL. AND IF
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WERE PROVIDED
TO CALIFORNIA PORTS- WHAT
PROJECTS WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO-
INVEST IN TO ALLEVIATE THE
CONGESTION THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM. YES THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND I'M SURE THIS-
OTHER. FOLKS TESTIFYING AFTER
ME WILL BE GOING TO THIS ISSUE.
BUT IMPORTANTLY AS WE SAID IT
AS I STATED EVEN BEFORE THE
ADAMIC WHAT IS STOPPING THAT-
THERE ISN'T MUCH BETTER I
SHOULD I DON'T KNOW BETTER THE
WORD BUT CERTAINLY MUCH MORE
EMPHASIS. ON COORDINATED
BETWEEN STATE GOVERNMENTS AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TERMS
INVESTMENT IN THEIR PORTS
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN TERMS OF-
SORT OF AND MARKETING AND-
MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE A-
COORDINATED WAY OF HANDLING THE-
IN ADDITION GROWTH FOR THE
PORTS. AND YOU KNOW THAT IN-
THE PRAMANA BUT NOW I'M A GIRL
ALL POLL FOR EXAMPLE IN.
GEORGIA IN VIRGINIA ON THE
FLORIDA AS WELL AS TEXAS. SO
THAT INVESTMENT I GUESS I
STATED MY TESTIMONY THERE'S A
NEARLY ELEVEN TO ONE IMBALANCE
BETWEEN WHAT'S THE INVESTMENT
THAT'S MADE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
OTHER STATES THAT I MENTIONED
SO THAT IMBALANCE IT HAS TO BE
CORRECTED I THINK WE THAT'S WHY
I MENTIONED. THE ISSUE IS ARE
WE NEED TO HAVE A STATE LEVEL
COORDINATION. OF FOR FREIGHT
POLICY THAT GIVES INVESTMENT IN
PORTS. THAT'S IMPORTANT NOW
WHAT I NAME STANDS UP. I JUST
OPENED IT IS AMPLE AND SHOW THE
OTHER BOARD DIRECTORS WAS TO
SAY THEIR OWN- THAT IS WE ARE
TRYING TO EXACT FOR ELECTRIFY
PORTS. FIND TO MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT AND WE'RE TRYING TO
REDUCE THE EMISSIONS ONE OF
THOSE HAS TO BE INVESTMENT IN
OUR ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE
JUST SUPPLIED PARTS. AS WELL AS
WE STATED WE NEED MORE- SPACE.
AND WE ALSO NEED INVEST IN TURN
OF- INLAND PORT YOU KNOW WORDS
THAT HAVE. TWO MODELS AVAILABLE
ENGLAND OF THE SO THEY WE CAN
OUT. AND HAVE TO PRY IT AT THE
STORE. I DOLLARS BY SHIP BY RAY-
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE- WE CAN PROCESS SOME
OF THOSE CARGO INLAND UP ON THE
PORCH ITSELF SO AGAIN- THIS
KIND OF RESILIENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE- BADLY. SO
THE GOVERNMENT CAN ACT AS WANT
TO MAKE SURE I WROTE THIS DOWN
CORRECTLY SO YOU SAID THERE'S
ELEVEN AND ELEVEN TO ONE AND
BALLOTS SO FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE
INVEST OTHER STATES INVEST
ELEVEN DOLLARS- IN THERE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT AND STATE.
COMBINED NOT JUST EIGHT ZERO
ZERO ZERO YEAH THE SOAPS OF THE
TOTAL INVESTMENT SO OTHER
STATES SPEND ELEVEN TIMES MORE
THAN WE DO ON THE POOR
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT SAYS
SOMETHING I THINK WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. CAN YOU YOU'VE I KNOW
MY THAT MY LAST QUESTION I
GUESS IS- YOU MENTIONED
ADDITIONAL COORDINATION-
MULTIPLE TIMES. WHO WOULD BE
THE ONE COORDINATING WOULD BE
IT WOULD IT WOULD WHO WOULD YOU
HOW WOULD YOU ENVISION THIS
COORDINATION RIGHT NOW I THINK
EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
BUT WHEN WE GET TO BRASS TACKS
HOW DOES THIS FUNCTION HOW DOES
IT WORK WHO WHO DO YOU ENVISION
A WHAT YOU ENVISION. TO BE
COORDINATING. AND THIS IS A-
THIS IS. A QUESTION THESE DAYS.
IS THAT WE ARE DISCOVERING THIS
KIND OF CRISIS. THE WHO IS THE
COORDINATOR. IS THE BIG
QUESTION- WE TALK ABOUT A
SUPPLY CHAIN. IT IS A IT IS
EVEN CHANGING IMAGINE THE LINKS
INTO TALKING SOMETIMES DON'T
CONNECT EACH YEAR THE VERY
WELL. AND BY WHO IS ACTUALLY
MAKE SURE THESE THINGS ARE
ACTUALLY CONNECTED TO OTHER. I
THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO SOLVE AND
THAT'S WHY ONE OF OUR
SUGGESTIONS. IS THAT WE DO NEED
A STATE. LEADERSHIP WITHIN NEED
A POINT TO PERSON. OR VIæT
GROUP THAT WILL FIGURE TO HELP
US FIGURES OUT WHAT IS THE
COORDINATION SYSTEM. ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE HAVE MADE
IS THAT. NUMBER ONE WE NEED
MORE TRANSPARENCY IT BEFORE WE
CAN COORDINATE ANYTHING. WE
NEED A SYSTEM WHICH THERE'S-
CLARITY. AS TO IF I AM A CARGO
OWNER. WHERE IS MY COULD
CONTAIN A CARGO. IF I'M UP FOR
THOÁT HOW DO I KNOW WHEN. THE
CAR GOES COMING IN. AND WHEN
YOU SHIP SUPPORT OUT. AND IS A
REGULAR SCHEDULE THAT'S ABOUT
IT ALL THIS SO. OF THE
INFORMATION IS NUMBER ONE STEP.
IN TERMS OF I CHIANG BUT NOW
TWO WE DO NEED ACCORDING EFFORT.
TO ASK YOUR QUESTION. WHO IS
THE- OF ALL THE SYSTEM. SO I
WAS ONE LAST QUESTION BASED ON
THAT EACH. WEEK AS I SAID IN MY
OPENING STATEMENT AND I THINK
THAT THE CHAIR MENTIONED THIS
TO- AND MULTIPLE AT MULTIPLE
TIMES. THERE HAS TO BE A SENSE
OF URGENCY- SO WHO'S
COORDINATING NOW. AND WHAT GAPS
EXIST I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE SUPPLY
CHAIN. A LOT OF TIMES. RIGHT
NOW THE VISUAL IS ALL OF THE
BOATS IN THE CARGO SHIPS OFF
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
EVEN IF WE REMOVED ALL THE
CONTAINERS OFF THOSE BOATS
THERE ARE STILL MULTIPLE
CHECKPOINTS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN. SO WHO'S
COORDINATING NOW HOW IS IT
FUNCTIONING NOW SHOULD THERE BE
MORE ACTIVITY. FROM FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD THERE
BE MORE ACTIVITY FROM- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHO WHO WHAT
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW. YEAH
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS A GOOD
QUESTION AND I THINK IN THE
SHORT TERM- THE BY THE
MINISTRATION OUR PRESIDENT HAS
APPOINTED EIGHT POINT PERSON
WITHIN THE FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY.
TO COURT INDICTS A- I HOPE- I
JUMP THE CAR. MISTER JUMPING
EIGHT IS BEING POINT TO REALLY
HELP COORDINATE AMONG. THE VERY
PLAYERS AND USING HIS THE
PRESIDENT'S POINT HOPE IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
TALKING TO EACH OTHER ARE
COMING UP WITH SOLUTIONS. SOME
OTHER SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS I
MENTIONED. IN MY TESTIMONY IN
FACT HAS COME OUT OF THAT
DISCUSSION WITH MR PICARDO SO
THAT IS A FEDERAL EFFORT TO
COORDINATE THESE THINGS. BUT
YOU KNOW LONG TERM HOWEVER WE
DO NEED A SPECIAL IN CALIFORNIA
IS IN VIEWING OURSELVES AS A
COMPETITIVE. A PLAYER WITH
OTHER STATES WE DO NEED BETTER
COORDINATION AMONG JUST. ONE
IMPORTS IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
HERE. I THINK MY- THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND JUST JUST BACK TO
THE POINT ABOUT THE AMOUNTS THE
ELEVEN TO ONE RATIO. I THINK
WHAT HE WAS INCLUDING THERE AND
I CAN HIGHLIGHT AS ONE EXAMPLE
IS THE HARBOR MAINTENANCE FEE
RIGHT. PORT USERS PANDA THAT
AND THEN IT'S PUT OUT TO
IMPROVE PORTS ACROSS THE NATION
BUT CALIFORNIA DOES NOT AT ALL
GET ITS FAIR SHARE OF THE
HARBOR MAINTENANCE HE ACTUALLY
GOES. TO IMPROVE SOME MUCH
SMALLER PORTS TO AND WE DON'T
GET ENOUGH THERE'S A HUGE
BALANCER NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
THAT'S REALLY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WITH THAT SENATOR EGGMAN
HAS JOINED US THANK YOU SENATOR.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HERE'S A
NICE TO SEE EVERYBODY I'M
THINKING FOR THE PRESENTATION-
SO I REPRESENT MYSELF IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REPRESENT STOCK
IMPORT THE LARGEST AND
IMPORTANT WESTERN HEMISPHERE WE
LIKE TO SAY- AND OF COURSE THAT
WE'VE HAD A RECORD YEAR THIS
YEAR IN BEING ABLE TO HANDLE
SOME OF THE- THE SHIPS THAT ARE
COMING IN. BUT I GUESS SOME OF
MY QUESTIONS AROUND AND AT THAT
HEY LET ME JUST SAY I THINK I
CONCUR WITH A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I'M A LITTLE BIT
HORRIFIED THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
BETTER SYSTEMS ALREADY IN PLACE
LIKE YOU KIND OF VISUALIZE IS
AN AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLER
PERSON OUT THERE DOING
DIRECTING BUT I GUESS I GUESS
WERE I GUESS EVERYBODY'S KIND
OF DOING THE CONTRACTING ON
THEIR OWN WHICH WHICH I MEAN
AND THEN WE THEN WE UNDERSTAND
WHY WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW- BUT MY QUESTION MY POINT
IS WHILE IT CANNOT MAY PERHAPS
HELP WITH THE CONGESTION RIGHT
NOW. BEING ABLE TO DIRECT AS
MANY- CONTAINERS YOU CAN TO
SOME OF THE SMALLER PORTS LIKE
HOW ARE WE LOOKING AT THAT AND
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN IN AND
AROUND THE STOCK IMPORT THAT
DEBT THAT SHIPPING IS GOING TO
CHANGE RIGHT RIGHT NOW THEY
HAVE BIG TWENTY TWENTY. THIS
CONTAINER THAT ARE GOING TO GO
DOWN TO LIKE TWO THOUSAND WHICH
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THOSE ENOUGH THAT WE'RE
SEEING HAPPENING ALREADY- AND
THEN EVERY EVERY SMALLER
CONTAINER WE TAKE INTO STOCKTON
IS TWO THOUSAND TRUCKS THAT
WERE TAKEN OFF THE ROAD SO
WE'RE WE'RE MEETING A LOT OF
GOALS AT THE SAME TIME. AND WE
KNOW THAT WE I MEAN WE HAVE THE
SPACE WE HAVE THE CRANES WE
HAVE THE LABOR WE HAVE THAT
CAPACITY WHAT WE DON'T HAVE IS
A CUSTOM BORDERS TO BE ABLE TO-
CHECKPOINTS TO BE ABLE TO SCAN
THE MATERIAL THAT'S COMING IN
WE KNOW IS A BIG PART. SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
SOME OF THE MORE INLAND PORTS
WITH SOME OF THE SMALLER- SHIPS
THAT ARE THAT ARE ALREADY BEING
ON ORDER TO BE CREATED SO WE
KNOW THAT'S COMING SO IT'S EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT I THINK THAT WE
GET THIS COORDINATION PIECE
DOWN. I WHAT ARE WE DOING THEN
TO INCREASE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE NEED
THEM TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
GOODS- AND MAKE A MAKE SURE
THEY'VE THEY'VE MOVE.
SAMLESSLY AS- AND HOW IS THIS
A CONSIDER. IF IT IS. THIS IS A
QUESTION DIRECTED ME I SHOULD
WRITE JEFF. OKAY YES I SURE
AGAIN MY MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
WILL AND- I. I'D SHORT ANSWER
IS WE NEED THAT INVESTMENT BAD
FOR STOCK AND CERTAINLY HAS
WAGED A ROLE IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. AND IN TERMS OF FUTURE
PLANNING- YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
BOTH INLAND- WATER PORTS AND AS
WELL AS INLAND LAN PORTS ARE
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
COORDINATE INVESTED. AND DOT
RIGHT NOW FOR EXAMPLE- IT WE
HAVE EXPLORED IN THE PAST IT'S
SORT OF A- AND- STAY- IN- ROUTE
USED IN BUT AGAIN THE- HAS BEEN
INVESTMENT INCENTIVISING DOT
MAKING IT ECONOMICALLY VIABLE.
I ENJOY IS A LAN LAN PORTS WE
NEED THE RAILROADS TO PLAY A
ROLE IN THAT TO MAKE SURE THE
DATE BY INTO THE CONCEPT OF
RATHER THAN JUST CALLING LONG
TRIP LONG ROUTES ALSO SHORT
ROUTES. ALSO A CUSTOMS A
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS IN CUSTOMS.
FACILITIES IN BOTH- PUTS LIKE
STOCKTON I TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
FEASIBLE FOR- TOWARDS. SUCH A
STOCKTON TO OPERATE
INTERNATIONAL CARGO AS THOSE
ARE ALL KIND OF INFRASTRUCTURE
AND- SUPPLY AND LABOR AND COULD
THE JUST TO GO ISSUES THAT WE
NEED TO INVEST AND TO RETURN TO
GHANA CONCEPT YOU MENTION
ASSEMBLY. PERSON SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WOULD JUST THE
TO ALL OF US WHO HAVE POURED
ARE GOING LET'S NOT JUST TRY TO
SOLVE THIS CRISIS LET'S MAKE A
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE SO WE
DON'T. END UP HERE AGAIN I
THINK A GREAT POINT WELL TAKEN-
AGUIAR-CURRY. YEAH THANK YOU.
MR ONE- ARE YOU CURRENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH CARRIERS TO
INCREASE CALLS TO THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. AND HAVE EVEN
COMMITTED TO COME BACK YET. AND
HOW MUCH- VOLUME IS OAKLAND
DOWN IN EXPORT SHIPPING. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION YES
WERE ABSOLUTELY- WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONFERENCE BUT WE'VE
NOT ONLY PRIVATELY YOU HAVE
BEEN TALKING TO THIS AND THAT
THE SHIPPING LINES ABOUT-
COORDINATING THE SCHEDULE SO
THAT THEY CAN CALL ME AND THEY
HAVE A SEAMLESS. EXPERIENCE AT
THE PORT OF OAKLAND- AND WE
HAVE SEVERAL CARRIERS HAVE NOW
STARTING TO RESUME NOT ONLY THE
CALLS AT PORT BUT LSO STARTING
SOME WHAT WE CALL DIRECT
SERVICE IN OTHER WORDS TAKING
SMALLER SHIPS. AND CALLING
CALLING TO OAKLAND AND THEN
JUST GOING BACK. WITHOUT
SERVICING OTHER PORTS SO
DIRECTIONAL VERSUS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT WE ARE TALKING TO
THE SHIPPING LINES ABOUT- AND
ALL THAT IS THE DOT EFFORT. TO
RELIEVE THE ACOG GESTIONES IN
OTHER UP PORTS SO- SOME OF THAT
IS RETURNING. AND BUT- NOT ALL
OF THEM HAVE AND WE ALL
CONTINUE THE EFFORT- RIGHT NOW
LIKE I SAID WE ARE WE HAVE
PLAYED THE ENTIRETY IF WE SAY A
100% OF CAPACITY OR DOUBLE BED.
WHERE POPPI A. 75% RIGHT NOW WE
CAN'T. NOW JUST A- JUST THIS.
THE IS NOT IS. TO THE
CONGESTION THAT I OWN LONG
BEACH IN THE HOLD BECAUSE WE
SUPPORT THE SIZE OF PULGAS NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO BE THE ALL THE
CONGESTION THE PORT OF LA AND
LONG BEACH. AT LEAST THE CARGO
DESTINED FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA UTAH NEVADA SHOULD
COME TO THE PORTABLE CAN AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY. THE CARGO
THAT- THAT ANTI SHOULD BE
FILLED WITH EXPORTS BEFORE THE
EXIT- CALIFORNIA ABOUT TO
EXPIRE. SO WE ARE TALKING AND
AGAIN JUDICIAL COORDINATION
WE'RE TRYING TO PLAYED A ROLE
COORDINATOR TO MAKE SURE ALL
THE CHANGES. ARE LINED UP SO
THAT WHEN THEY DO CALL PORTABLE
CAN. THAT DOES NOT CAUSE
FURTHER CONGESTION. WELL AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE MY AGRICULTURAL
FRIENDS OR WONDER WHAT CAN BE
DONE IN THE NEXT THIRTY SIXTY
NINETY DAYS- YOU KNOW IF YOU
GET DOWN PERFECT LONGER OUT
BUT- TO HELP ERASE SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES IN GETTING THESE
EXPORTS UP- WE MISSED A- PRIME
TIME- A PRODUCT GOING TO. A
SOUTHEAST ASIA AND INDIA. AND
SO- THE HIT ON THE ECONOMY HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE. I'M SURE WE'LL
HEAR ABOUT THAT WHEN WE HAVE
ANOTHER SPEAKER LATER TODAY SO-
THE EXPORT PIECE I'M REALLY
GLAD WE'RE ADDRESSING TODAY.
AND I'M NOT I'M GOING TO DRILL
IT INTO EVERYBODY THE SENSE OF
URGENCY. AND THE SENSE OF NOT
FORGETTING AGRICULTURE MAKING
SURE WE GET OUR EXPORTS UP
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND I JUST. NOT TO DEFEND THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OR ANY COMPANY
OUT THERE BUT I THINK PEOPLE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT. IF
YOU'RE TARGETED CAP OR SOME
COMPANY- IF YOU IT'S NOT AS
SIMPLE AS JUST TAKING A SHIP.
TO OAKLAND RIGHT YOU'VE GOT TO
HAVE A SHIPPING COMPANY THAT'S
THE BOAT RIGHT. YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A TERMINAL OPERATOR THAT'S
WHERE YOU. THAT'S THE DOC.
RIGHT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A
TRUCKING COMPANY RELATIONSHIP A
WORKHOUSE RELATIONSHIP AND EVEN
SOME OTHER RELATIONSHIPS. TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN AT ALL
REQUIRES LEGAL CONTRACTS THAT
JUST TAKES TIME SO YOU JUST
CAN'T TURN ON A DIME SAY HEY.
TAKE A BOAT SOMEWHERE ELSE FOR
THE CONTAINERS. BECAUSE THERE
HAS TO BE A LOT OF.
RELATIONSHIPS ARE THERE- MANY
OF THEM LEGAL. WITH THAT ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO COMMENT-
AS BONTA. THANK YOU CHAIR IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU MISTER ON- AT
MY QUESTION IS I KNOW THAT AT
SOME POINT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
JUST BY WAY OF EXAMPLE DID HAVE
SOME OVERAGE IN TERMS OF THE
CONCERT CONGESTION BACK IN THE
SPRING AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH THAT WAS AN
INVESTMENT IN INCREASING
WORKFORCE AT THE DOCK TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO JUST FOR WAY
OF EXPLANATION TO BE ABLE TO.
OFFER UP ANOTHER POTENTIAL
SOLUTION IT INVESTMENT IN
WORKFORCE AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE KINDS OF BOTH TRUCKERS
AND DOCKWORKERS THAT ALLOW US
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT CAN YOU
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE SOME
OAKLAND ALREADY INSTITUTED AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO CONSIDER. IN TERMS OF
WORKFORCE. ASSEMBLY PERSON
THANK YOU. IT IS INDEED TRUE
JOY- WHEN- WENDY SHIPS- OR IN
THEIR NORMAL- CALLING ORDER
THEY CALL OAKLAND. WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED WAS THERE WAS A LONG
SHORT- LABOR SKILLED LABOR
SHORTAGE AT THE DOCK AND THERE
WAS A CONGESTION. AND THAT
SINCE THAT INTO SHORT TERM. THE
LONG SHORT AND IF YOU MAY HAVE-
A RAMPED UP THEIR TRAINING OF
SKILLED LABOR AT THE AGE. OF
THE DOCK AND DODD IS NOW-
SOMEWHAT DATA RESULT SO BUT I
THINK THE ASSEMBLY PERSON POINT
IS WELL TAKEN ONE OF THE LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS TO MEET ENTERS
THROUGH SINCE. GOT WE- WE MUST
FOCUS ON. IS THE SHORTAGE OF
TRUCKERS SHORTAGES LABOUR IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN NETWORK AND
THOSE ARE GOOD ABSOLUTELY GOOD
PAYING JOBS THAT WE NEED TO
INVEST IN WORKFORCE TRAINING-
WE NEED RECRUITMENT. AND UP AND
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DEALING WITH COURSES
TRUCKER SHORTAGE- AND YOU KNOW
LONG TERM WE ALSO NEED TO
ASSIST THESE TRUCKERS. IN
CONVERTING THEIR EQUIPMENT FROM
THE CURRENT DIESEL COULD MAKE
STOCK- TO- ELECTRIC SO- IS NOT
RESPECTED THE PORTABLE CAN
REALLY WANT TO GIVE THANKS TO
THE TO THE LONG STORE. AND THE
PMR FOR REALLY HAVING STEPPED
UP TO TRAINED. TO TRAIN MORE
SKILLED WORKERS AND INCREASE A
LABOR FORCE AT AT THE DOCK AND
SHOW THAT'S TRUE IN ALLEN LONG
BEACH AND ALL REPORTS. THAT OUR
LABOR FORCE IS STEPPED UP
DURING THE SPEND DOWN MAKE AND
WE THANK THEM. THANK YOU
FIGURES ANY OTHER STAR LAST
COMMENT BY A QUESTION BY MR ON.
A GIPSON THANK YOU HAVE ANOTHER
PANEL WAITING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INTEREST OF TIME
MS PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE KNOW YOU ONLY BEEN IN
YOUR POSITION FOR TWENTY ONE
DAYS- AND YOU YOU HAVE A BIG
TASK AHEAD OF YOU. I WOULD
SIMPLY ASK THAT IF YOUR GROUP
WE TALKED ABOUT COORDINATION-
AND YOU TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR
A GREAT FOR LEADERSHIP. I WOULD
HOPE THAT- UNDER YOUR
LEAERSHIP THAT YOU'RE
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY DRAFTED
SUCH SUGGESTIONS AND IF THE IF
YOU HAVE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
SUBMIT THAT AT YOUR EARLIEST
CONVENIENCE TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO THAT WE CAN- HAVE A COPY OF
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN THINKING ABUT
AROUND AROUND HOW TO ADDRESS
THIS GROWING. ISSUE IN CRISIS
IN THE PORT. ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE
OPPOSITE AND WE HAVE TO JUST
SOLUTION WILL PROVIDE TO THE-
AND I WANT TO THANK THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE CAP BUT YOU
STILL GOT. BY THE START OF THAT
PROCESS EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SO YES WE ABSOLUTELY
PROVIDE THAT YOU. THANK YOU AND
I BELIEVE THAT LETTER WILL BE
COMING OUT TOMORROW IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY THAT'S
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN KIND OF.
BEING THE DRUM ON A YOU ONE
PIECE OF PAPER ONE SIDE ONE
PIECE OF PAPER WHAT DO YOU
NEED. LONG TERM SHORT TERM WITH
THAT THANK YOU A PRESENT ONE
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY. AND FOR YOUR ROLE AND IF
WE WANT A PANEL NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER ONE. A PANEL OF
MARIJUANA SPIKING COSTS AND
SCARES CONTAINERS HOW THE
BACKUP IS IMPACTING. BUSINESSES
AND THE ECONOMY. OUR FIRST
PANEL WILL DISCUSS HOW THE
BACKUP IS IMPACTING BUSINESSES
AND THE ECONOMY EACH PANELIST
WILL HAVE UP TO FIVE MINUTES
WILL WRITE AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AFTER WE
HEAR FROM ALL PANELISTS. ARE
COMING FORWARD IS RACHEL
MICHELIN ICE HERE RIGHT THERE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION SHE'S IN
PERSON. AND THEN WRITER OUGHT
ROGER EYES I SOME. WRITER ISON
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND BEFORE YOU
PROCEED I JUST WANNA KNOW THE
PRESENCE OF CENTER DOLLY THERE.
WHO REPRESENTS UPPER NORTHERN
COSTA MESA PORT OR TWO IT IS
DISTRICT. DOWN OKAY I THOUGHT
YOU DID AFTER THERE'S A COUPLE
OUT THERE K. THERE'S UP THERE
SOME UP THERE. SO I WITH THAT
I'M O OUR FIRST ARE PRESENT
PRESENCE. BY RACHEL MICHELIN.
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN. RIKISHI
REGARDLESS. YEAH NOW. TRAVEL
YOU CAN. I'M THIRTY GAL ALL
RIGHT LET'S START OVER. THEY
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN
TODAY IN IMPORTANT FACING US
CHAIN GOOD MOVEMENT WE APPLAUD
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN FINDING
SOLUTIONS TO THE ONGOING SUPPLY
CHAIN CHALLENGES THAT IMPACT
EVERY SEGMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
AND U. S. ECONOMY. NO ONE
ENTITY CAN SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND THERE'S NOT ONE MAGIC
BULLET THAT WILL PUT AN END TO
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN CHALLENGES BUT
THIS DOES POSE AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
SECTOR TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
ON IDEAS AND SOLUTIONS TO AVOID
THE SITUATION FROM GETTING
WORSE. AND TO PUT IT ALL ON A
PATH THAT RESULTS IN A ROBUST
WELL RAINY GATES MOVEMENT FOR
THE FUTURE. SO WHAT DO
RETAILERS SEE AS CHALLENGES TO
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND WHAT OUR
SOLUTIONS TO DISCUSS TO ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES. NUMBER ONE WE
NEED AN HONEST EVALUATION OF
HOW THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS WORKING
AND IDENTIFY THE OBSTACLES THAT
PREVENT THE MOVEMENT OF CARGO.
THROUGH THE ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN
SYSTEM. ONE INVESTMENT IN THE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NEEDED OTHER INVESTMENTS SUCH
AS AUTOMATION AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS CAN HELP
IMPROVE DATA SHARING AMONG ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. NUMBER TWO THE
ONGOING SURGE OF IMPORTS HAS
LED TO LIMITED WAREHOUSE
CAPACITY AND AVAILABILITY WE
KNOW THERE IS LITTLE TO NO
AVAILABLE AVAILABILITY AND THEN
THE NUMBER HIGHER. AND THERE
CONTINUES TO BE REGULATORY AND
PERMITTING CHALLENGES THAT
CREATE BURDENS TO BUILDING AND
FACILITIES JUST THIS YEAR
REGULATIONS WERE ADOPTED THAT
WILL IMPACT THE ABILITY TO
BUILD NEW FACILITIES AT THE
CURRENT ONES. WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON IMPROVING THE PERMITTING
PROCESS TO BUILD NEW FACILITIES
AND A MORE EFFICIENT TIME FRAME.
NUMBER THREE WE NEED TO ENSURE
NEW INVESTMENT IN TECHNOLOGY
AND INFORMATION SYSTEMS THAT
WILL PROVIDE BETTER INSIGHTS
INTO THE MOVEMENTS OF THE
ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN. ON AVERAGE
OVER TWENTY DIFFERENT ENTITIES
TOUCH A CONTAINER WITHIN A
PORT. AND NO ONE ENTITY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERALL
MOVEMENT OF PRODUCT THIS
RESULTS IN A SYSTEM OF
STAKEHOLDERS WORKING IN A SILO.
COMPLETING THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PIECE OF CONTAMINANTS. AND NOT
CONSIDERING THE ENTIRE GOODS
MOVEMENT AS A WHOLE. NUMBER
FOUR. NATIONALLY WAREHOUSE AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTER JOBS HAVE
GROWN BY 56% IN THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. THERE ARE MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION JOBS IN THE
WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY WITH OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND JOB
OPENINGS NATIONWIDE. WITH AN
AVERAGE ENTRY LEVEL WAGE OF
OVER NINETEEN DOLLARS PR HOUR
IT IS CRITICAL OUR FUTURE
WAREHOUSE AND DISTRIBUTION
CENTER WORKFORCE. IS TRAINED TO
MEET THE NEEDSOF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY SUPPLY CHAIN. SO
NOW I WANT TO SHARE WHAT
SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ARE DOING TO LEAD ON
SOLUTIONS. NUMBER ONE TO
ADDRESS THE NEED OF GETTING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE SAME PAGE
PHERAE SPEARHEADING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
RESPONSIBLE GOODS MOVEMENT AND
WELCOME THE PARTICIPATION OF
THESE OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE THIS IS
A COOPERATIVE EFFORT OF
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS TO
PROVIDE AN INTELLIGENT INDUSTRY
LED RESPONSE TOWARDS IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA PORTS AND GOODS
MOVEMENT. WHILE WORKING
TOGETHER TO BUILD AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND GOODS
MOVEMENT SYSTEM FOR THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WE WELCOME THE
PARTICIPATION OF ALL GOOD
MOVEMENT STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR PUBLIC LEADERS AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LABOR.
SPECIFIC TO WHERE HOUSING. C.
R. A. IS PARTNERING WITH THE
NATIONAL RETAIL FEDERATION AND
THE RISE UP WAREHOUSE INVENTORY
LOGISTICS CERTIFICATE PROGRAM.
THIS CERTIFICATE WAS DEVELOPED
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
ASSOCIATION FOR SUPPLY CHAIN
MANAGEMENT FOUNDATION. WITH A
PROJECTED SIX SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS STATE SURPLUS NEXT YEAR
THIS PROGRAM IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF HOW THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR CAN COLLABORATE TO BRING
THIS PROGRAM TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND LEAD ON A LONG TERM
SOLUTION OF TRAINING. OUR
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY GOODS
MOVEMENT WORKFORCE. WE WELCOME
THE COLLABORATION OF THIS
COMMITTEE I'M MAKING THIS
PROGRAM A REALITY IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS OR ANY
UNIQUE UNIQUE POSITION. AT
TOUCHING EVERY PART OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. FROM PORTS TO
TRUCKING TO WAREHOUSING AND
FINALLY TO THE CONSUMERS RETAIL
HAS A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS IS
IMPACTING THE OODS MOVEMENT IN
THE STATE. THIS IS A SYSTEM OF
SYSTEMS AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT
ALL OPTIONS IF WE'RE GOING TO
SEE SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR BOLD
LEADERSHIP NOW IS THE TIME FOR
THE PUBLIC SECTOR TO LOOK AT
HOW REGULATIONS LEGISLATION
EXECUTIVE ORDERS. AND LOCAL
ORDINANCES ARE IMPACTING THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. NOW IS THE TIME
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO LOOK
AT HOW THE USE OR LACK THEREOF
OF TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION IS AND
IT'S IMPACTING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. NOW IS THE TIME FOR ALL
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS TO LOOK
AT WHAT WE CAN DO INDIVIDUALLY
AND COLLECTIVELY TO MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS NECESSARY TO HAVE
A GOOD STATEMENT THAT IS WORTHY
OF THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
STAND READY TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU AND WITH OTHER GOODS
MOVEMENT STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN AND GOODS
MOVEMENT. IS THE BEST AND MOST
EFFICIENT IN THE ENTIRE NATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
MITCHELL AND WILL HER NOW HER
FROM ROGER I SOME OF THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS. AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION. ROGER YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READING. GOOD
MORNING AND- THANK YOU. NOT
CHURN AND THIS GERMAN
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
I REALLY WANT TO THANK EVERY
SINGLE MEMBER YOU EITHER
REPRESENT ONE OF MY GROWERS OR
THE PORTS WERE PART GOES OUT
SO. I KNOW ITS- OFF TIME OF THE
YEAR BUT CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR HOLD ITS
HEARING. BUT AS WAS STATED I
REPRESENT THE COTTON TREE NOT
INDUSTRIES THE INDUSTRIES THAT
RELY HEAVILY ON EXPORTS. ALL
RIGHT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
THREE PORTS LONG BEACH LOS
ANGELES AND OAKLAND. ARE
INDUSTRIES THE ONES ARE
REPRESENT REPRESENT OVER EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN AG EXPORTS.
BUT TO PUT IT ON SPECIFIC
NUMBERS. ALMONDS ARE THE NUMBER
ONE AGRICULTURAL EXPORT AT FOUR
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
PISTACHIOS NUMBER TWO AT ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION. ONE THAT'S
NUMBER FIVE AT ONE POINT THREE
BILLION AND THEN COTTON COMES
IN AT NUMBER SEVENTEEN AT JUST
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. IMPORT THOMPSON.
THAT'S A TOTAL TYPICAL. VOLUME
OF OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND TO
USE. MORE SPECIFICALLY- TREE
NUTS REPRESENT OVER SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND T. USER. FIFTY
NINE. BEECH TREE NOTES ACCOUNT
FOR OVER TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
TO USE ABOUT 3% OF THE AG
EXPORT VOLUME. AND COTTON
REPRESENTS OVER A HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND TWO USER
ABOUT 9210% OF THE AG EXPORT
VOLUME THROUGH LA ONE BEACH.
BUT TO FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT THE SITUATION TOOK MY
COMMODITIES ARE REPRESENT AND
THANKFULLY I REPRESENT
COMMODITIES ARE NOT PERISHABLE
SO WE HAVE WE CAN SUFFER THIS A
LITTLE BIT. 65270% OF THE
PROFESSIONALS GOING CALIFORNIA
ARE EXPORTED 65% OF THE WALNUTS
ARE EXPORTED. 73% OF ALMONDS
ARE EXPORTED. AND 1100% OF THE
COTTON GOING TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXPORTED SO WE'RE DEFINITELY
IMPACTED BY THIS. IN TERMS OF
DIRECT IMPACTS- WE ARE
DEFINITELY SEEING A LACK OF
EQUIPMENT INCLUDING CONTAINERS
AND CHASSIS. UP MORE THAN 80%
OF OUR BOOKINGS ARE SCHEDULED-
EXPORTS ARE BEING ROLLED IN
OTHER WORDS CANCEL TRY TO
RESCHEDULE- IN MOST CASES IT'S
MULTIPLE TIMES. AS AN EXAMPLE
THIS LAST MONTH OF OCTOBER ONE
OF MY ONE OF OUR PROCESSORS.
HAD ALL TWENTY SEVEN BOOKINGS
ROLLED. AND AS OF YESTERDAY.
NONE OF THOSE HAVE BEEN RE
SCHEDULED TO GO OUT. BECAUSE
THE ROLE BOOKINGS ARE
CONTAINERS OF THERE AT THE PARK
THEY HAVE TO BE STORED WE START
PAYING DEMURRAGE AND STORAGE
FEES. SOMETIMES AS MUCH OF THE
LAST YEAR'S TEN TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH IN
ADDITIONAL FEES AND SURCHARGES-
IN TERMS OF SCHEDULING OUR
EARLIEST RECEIVING DATES AND
LAST RECEIVING DATES ARE
CHANGING ON A DAILY BASIS.
SOMETIMES BY THE HOUR. MAKING
IT POSSIBLE FOR SHIPPERS. IF
THEY PULLED UP THE CONTAINER
TOO SOON THE SHIP A LITTLE BE
CHARGE PER DIEM ON THE OCEAN BY
THE OCEAN CARRIER. AT A RATE OF
FORTY TWO HUNDRED FORTY DOLLARS
PER DAY PER CONTAINER. BOB MOST
OCEAN CARRIERS HAVE IMPLEMENTED
A GENERATE INCREASE OF TWO
HUNDRED TO FOUR DOLLARS PER
CONTAINER. THERE'S NOW A PEAK
SEASON SURCHARGE AND A WEST
COAST PORT CONGESTION
SURCHARGE. AND THESE CAN RANGE
FROM AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TO
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
CONTAINER. I AS HAS BEEN STATED
IS VERY OBVIOUS- MANY SHIPS OR
BY PASSING OR OF COUNSEL OPEN
ALL TOGETHER. THOSE SHIPS ARE
RETURNING EMPTIES TO ASIA
INSTEAD OF THE PAST PRACTICE OF
HOLDING IRAQ EXPORTS. AS A
RESULT WE LOST MARKETS-
ESPECIALLY FOR ONE ITS EUROPEAN
CHRISTMAS IS A BIG MARKET IS
NOW BEING FILLED BY OTHER
COUNTRIES. ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
LOST OVER SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE MONTH OF
SALES. BECAUSE OF THE INABILITY
TO FILL TIME THE COMMITMENTS.
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT- WHICH ARE
STRUCTURALLY EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS- WE ARE SHIPPING
PISTACHIOS ON RAIL CARS TO
HOUSTON GALVESTON- THAT'S NOT
MAKING MONEY THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TWELVE DOLLARS PER
CONTAINER BUT IT'S SIMPLE TO
KEEP OUR MARKET PLACE. WE'RE
ALSO PLACING LIMITS ON REAL
COURTS TO BALTIMORE. AT A LOSS
JUST TO KEEP OUR EUROPEAN
CUSTOMERS. ON THE CON SIDE
WE'VE ACTUALLY PHONE. VIA AIR
FREIGHT- BALES OF COTTON TO
PERU AGAIN JUST TO PRESERVE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS. AND THEN
WE'VE AS BEEN STATE ON SOME OF
THE SMALLER PORTS WERE ACTUALLY
SHIPPING SOME CONTAINERS
THROUGH PORT WHY NINI. AGAIN
THIS IS A THAT'S A BANDAID
SITUATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
REALLY HANDLE LARGE ONE THE
CONTAINERS OR LARGE SHIPS. BUT
IT IS SOME WAY TO TRY TO
SURVIVE THROUGH THIS- IN TERMS
OF CAUSES. AGAIN IT'S BEEN
STATED MANY TIMES IT'S REALLY
IT'S AN IMPERFECT AND OVER ONE
SITUATION. ALL RIGHT NOW AND NO
ONE CAN DISPUTE THERE'S A HUGE
INCREASE IN IMPORTS. COVERT
DEFINITELY PLAYED A ROLE
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF TRUCKERS.
BUT FRANKLY THE OPENING HOURS
THE PORTS DON'T MATCH THE
CURRENT DEMAND- BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE ARE AT THE MERCY
OF FOREIGN SHIPPING COMPANIES.
WE HAVE NO OVERSIGHT OR TEETH
IN TRYING TO GET THESE- FEES
CORRECTED OR THEM TO TAKE COME
TO- GOING TO TAKE OUR AG
EXPORTS- WE'RE GAME THAT-
SOMEBODY CHANGE THE RULES ON US
AND WE HAVE NO WAY TO CORRECT
IT. WE ARE PURELY AT THEIR
MERCY. OUR CULTURE AND OUR
INABILITY GET OUR EXPORTS OUT
HIS SIMPLY COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
WE NEED SOLUTIONS WE NEED THEM
YESTERDAY. SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS HAVE BEEN MADE IN
ADDITIONAL STORAGE FOR THE
CONTAINERS- TRUCKING- TRUCKERS
LONGSHOREMAN THERE'S ALL TAKE
TIME TO PUT IN PLACE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS FOR OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF. SO ANY
SOLUTION THAT CAN MOVE THIS
ALONG WOULD BE VERY APPRECIATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
WILL NOT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS. I GO YOUR- I'LL
GO I'M- TO THE RETAILER'S- YOU
HAD MENTIONED- ONGOING
REGULATORY AND PERMITTING
CHALLENGES- THAT YOU DIDN'T
MENTION ANY SPECIFICS COULD YOU
GIVE ME SOME EXAMPLES AND I
THINK ONE EXAMPLE I CAN USE IS
RECENTLY THIS YEAR THEY PASSED
THE INDIRECT SOURCE ROLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ON
WAREHOUSES AND YOU KNOW WHILE
WE WE'RE WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THE RETAIL INDUSTRY WERE
VERY CONSUMER DRIVEN. AND SO
WHEN CONSUMERS DEMAND
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY IN
THEIR IN THEIR RETAILERS WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO MEET
THAT SO WE WANT TO MEET AND WE
ARE VERY BROAD AND HIGH IN OUR
MENTAL STATE ABILITY GOALS BUT
WHEN SOME OF THESE REGULATIONS
ARE PASSED. AND THE TECHNOLOGY
IS NOT THERE THE TECHNOLOGY IS
NOT THERE TO IMPLEMENT WHAT
THEY WANT TO ACCOMPLISH THE
INDIRECT SOURCE FULL THEY'RE
GOOD IN THAT TAXING RETAILERS
ARE THE OPERATORS OF THE
WAREHOUSES BUT YET THEY CAN'T
DO ANYTHING TO IMPLEMENT THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE
SO I WILL SAY WHEN THAT WILL
PASSED NOW WITH MAY OF THIS
YEAR I HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH-
RETAILERS SOME NATIONAL
RETAILERS WHO WERE LOOKING AT
EXPANDING THEIR WAREHOUSE
CAPACITY IN CALIFORNIA. AND NOW
THAT THAT'S OFF THE TABLE AND
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THE
UNCERTAINTY IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
A CONSTANT YOU KNOW LEGISLATION
PASSING REGULATIONS PASSING AND
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE
I'VE. TALKED ABOUT WITH SOME OF
YOU IS. YOU KNOW ONCE THE- IS
THAT LET'S TAKE A STEP LOOK AT
ALL OF THE REGULATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PASSED IN PART OF THE
LAST TEN YEARS. THAT IMPACT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. LET'S MAKE SURE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY WORKING. IF
THEY'RE NOT WORKING LET'S TRY
TO IMPROVE THAT BUT WHEN YOU
HAVE LOCAL. APPOINTED BOARDS
MAKING REGULATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE PASSING BILLS THE
GOVERNOR DOING EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. IT'S VERY CHALLENGING
TO KEEP THAT. AND WHEN
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY
RETAILERS SEE THE UNCERTAINTY.
IT'S EASY TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD A
WAREHOUSE AND OF THAT ACT. OR
ARIZONA AND WE'RE GONNA TRACK
THAT ACROSS THE STATE. USE THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER THERE AND
BRING IT BACK TO CALIFORNIA. SO
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN NUMBER ONE
WE'RE NOT MEETING ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS. NUMBER TWO ALL OF THESE
JOBS THAT. YOU KNOW THAT THIS
THIS NOTION THAT THESE
WAREHOUSE JOBS ARE NOT THE JOBS
THEY ARE THERE THERE ARE SOME
OTHER ARE STARTING UPWARDS OF
TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS AN HOUR.
THOSE JOBS WILL BE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THOSE ARE
IT'S NOT JUST ONE I CAN'T POINT
TO JUST ONE THING SURE IT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE IT ALL TOGETHER.
AND WE WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN WITH
FOLKS AND SAY. LET'S HAVE A
FRANK CONVERSATION WE'RE NOT
SAYING REPEAL EVERYTHING BUT
WE'RE SAYING LET'S TALK ABOUT
IT AND HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT. ARE WE HINDERING THE
SUPPLY CHAIN IN THE GOODS
MOVEMENT BY THESE REGULATIONS
AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
STREAMLINE IT TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR BUSINESSES IN THE STATE. I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT. THAT WE
NEED A HOLISTIC APPROACH I
THINK YOU HAVE TO THE CORRECT
THAT WE NEED TO. RE EVALUATE AS
I SAID EARLIER EVERYTHING THAT
HAS HAPPENED IN THE OVER MAYBE
WE GO BACK TEN FIFTEEN YEARS-
TO SEE KIND OF. HOW A THEY
LATER. I THINK WE'VE- A LOT OF
THINGS RULES AND MANDATES AND
REGULATIONS OVER AN EXECUTIVE
ORDERS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
ON TOP OF EACH OTHER. AND THAT
I THINK HAS MADE THE PROBLEM
WORSE THAT NOW IT'S TOO
DIFFICULT- IT'S LIKE AN ANCHOR
ON SOMEONE THAT SWIMMING. WE
SAY UNFORTUNATELY THE SUMMER
DOESN'T SWIM FAST ENOUGH
ANYMORE BUT INSTEAD OF CUTTING
OFF THE ANCHORS AND LIVING THE
SUMMER'S CTUALLY- DO WHAT. I
HEAR SHE IS SUPPOSED TO DO- IN
TERMS OF M. AND MAYBE THAT'S
WHERE THE AYE YOU MENTIONED
THIS CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
RESPONSIBLE GOODS MOVING. AT
WOULD THEY BE ABLE TO DO AN
ANALYSIS. TO OR HELP US
DEVELOP- THAT TYPE OF DATA AND
INFORMATION OF WHERE WE KNOW
WHAT THE WHERE THE LEFT HAND
KNOWS WHAT THE RIGHT HAND IS
DOING. WITH THAT BEING. SAID
THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO BRING
EVERYONE TOGETHER I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS YOU'VE HEARD HIS
THAT. IT EVERYONE'S DOING THEIR
OWN THING AND THERE'S NO ONE
THAT'S REALLY LIKE BRINGING
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE AND
HAVING A CONVERSATION SPECIFIC
TO HOW IT'S IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA. SO ABSOLUTELY I'VE
HAD FOLKS REACH OUT TO ME AND
SAY HEY WE CAN PROVIDE WHITE
PAPERS ON THIS ISSUE OR WE CAN
PROVIDE WHITE PAPERS ON THIS ON
THAT ISSUE. I THINK IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY AND WE
WANT TO PARTNER WITH ALL OF YOU
WE WANT TO ENGAGE WITH ALL THE
I THINK IT'S A GREAT. WAY TO
SHOW THE PUBLIC SECTOR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR COMING TOGETHER
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS SO
YEAH ABSOLUTELY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD DO.
THIS HAVE TO BE DATA DRIVEN
SURE RIGHT WE CAN'T SAY. AND
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY TO YOU IS
AS- LEGISLATORS IN CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO GET RID OF ACTS
REGULATION AND LESS I CAN SHOW
YOU WHY THAT REGULATION IS NOT
WORKING. AND HOW WE CAN TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH THOSEGOALS THROUGH
ANOTHER AVENUE. BUT WHAT
HAPPENS IS A LOT OF TIMES AND
WE'RE NOT INCLUDED IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AND SO WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO BRING THAT PERSPECTIVE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THIS COALITION- WELL. I
THINK THAT THE OUT. YOUR
COLLEAGUES A EXCUSE WE NEED TO.
YESTERDAY IF YOU COULD PROVIDE
A TO AND FROM- I. TOMORROW IF
YOU HAVE IDEAS. IN MY- VIE IF
YOU OF IDEAS AND I THINK WE DO
NEED TO TAKE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO LOOK AT WHAT
OCCURRED OVER- THE DECADE OR
SO- AND WHAT AT THE SECT WHAT
SACRAMENTO IS DONE AND WHAT
WHAT WASHINGTON DC HAS DONE TO
IMPACT THE SUPPLY CHAIN- AND IF
WE CAN BEGIN TO REMOVE THOSE
ANCHORS OR REMOVE THOSE
BARRIERS. I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THOSE- SOLUTIONS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE- I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS FOR ROGER TO GET TO
SEE YOU- IN TERMS OF YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOUR LAST POINT-
THAT YOU'RE AT THE MERCY OF- OF
THE SHIPPING COMPANY'S- IT
WOULD DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS IN
TERMS OF. HOW TO CREATE SOME
BALANCE AT IN TERMS OF THAT
RELATIONSHIP. WE DON'T SEE IT-
THE ONLY WAY THAT THIS CAN BE
RESOLVED IS IF THAT. IF THE
CONGESTION EASES. AND THOSE
SHIPPING COMPANIES DON'T AREN'T
MAKING AS MUCH MONEY AS THEY
ARE RIGHT NOW. THEY'RE MAKING
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A CONTAINER FOR THOSE
IMPORTS SO. DEALING WITH US AND
EIGHT OR NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
WHICH IS TWICE WHAT WE USED TO
PAY FOR- AND EXPORT CONTAINER.
WORK WE'RE NOT EVEN ON THE
RADAR SCREEN ANYMORE SO. RIGHT
NOW AS LONG AS THAT THAT
IMPORTANT CRUSHES THERE. THAT'S
WHERE THE FOCUS IS GOING TO BE.
AND THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO
GET A PRODUCT OUT. IN IN TERMS
OF. YOUR MEMBERS AND OF COURSE
THIS IS THIS IS TRUE- OF
AGRICULTURE COMPLETELY IN MY
COLLEAGUE I THINK- AS MENTIONED
IS BEFORE YOU'RE YOU'RE HAVING
TO YOU'RE FORCED TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS TO JUST MAINTAIN
MARKET CHER- AND MAINTAIN
MARKETS AROUND THE WORLD- IN.
IN TERMS OF LIKE. OPERATING
HOURS YOU MENTIONED THAT- AS
WELL- DO YOU FEEL THAT THE-
THERE'S NOT AN ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN. BETWEEN THE PORTS AND-
THE INDISCRETION CENTERS AND-
AND THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN RIGHT
NOW. WHETHER PEOPLE ARE GONNA
BE OUT YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARD
FROM THE DAY THEY CAN SPEAK TO
IT BETTER THAN I CAN BUT YES
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT IT'S EVEN
A COUPLE MORE HOURS- OPEN FOR
TRUCKS TO COME INSPECTION ONLY
LONG BEACH WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF IT. IT'S NOT THE ENTIRE
PROBLEM BUT WOULD HELP WOULD
HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THAT
PRESSURE AND AGAIN HOPEFULLY
THAT'S ENOUGH WHERE I BECAUSE
THE SHIPS THEY WAITED TOO LONG
AS IT IS- TO THEN WANT TO COME
UP TO OPEN AND LOAD AND GO BACK
SO. IF WE CAN SHORTEN THAT TIME
THAT MAYBE MAKE IT MORE
TRACTION TO COME OPEN AND I
GUESS MY LAST QUESTION IS
CERTAINLY SOMEWHAT PROVIDING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AGRICULTURE
HIS HIS IS A SIGNIFICANT IF NOT
THE BIGGEST ECONOMIC DRIVER FOR
OUR REGION- HAVE YOU DONE AN
ASSESSMENT OR ANALYSIS OR
MAYBE- SURVEYED REMEMBERS WHAT
IT HAS BEEN THE FINANCIAL
FINANCIAL IMPACT OR THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT YOU'VE
SEEN SO FAR- OF AN AGGREGATE.
COULD GIVE YEAH I DON'T HAVE
THE I DON'T HAVE A TOTAL WE ARE
SERVING WE'RE DOING IT ON A ON
A MONTHLY BASIS BECAUSE WERE
PROVIDING THAT TO THE FEDERAL
MARITIME COMMISSION. IN
PARTICULAR COMMISSIONER DIED TO
TRY TO GET SOME. IDEA OF WHAT
THAT IMPACT IS I GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
ONE IS THAT THE LOSS OF SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE MONTH OF
SALES. LONG TERM WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT IMPACT IS- WE'RE
TRYING TO REGAIN THAT MARKET
SHARE- BUT IF WE DON'T THEN
THERE'S HUGE IMPACTS LONGER Y.
ONE ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES-
YOU KNOW SOMEONE BURKE
AGUIAR-CURRY SAID THERE'S NEED.
TO BE A SENSE OF URGENCY FOR
SURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
JUST A COMMENT- MISTER. IN UP.
WE YOU TALK ABOUT ONE SINGLE.
ESSENTIALLY INFORMATION SYSTEM
WITH REGARD TO THE PORTS AND I
ONE OF THE- I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THE PORT DIRECTORS
HAVE HAD I THINK THEY WOULD
ARGUE. OR SOME OTHERS THE
PORTER RENO HAD. IS WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN BECAUSE THE
CHALLENGES THOSE FOLKS ARE
GOING TO FACE IS NOT EVERY BCO
BENEFICIAL CARGO OWNER
RETAILERS GOING TO WANT TO
SHARE THEIR DATA RIGHT. IF I AM
TARGET I DON'T WANT. WALMART
KNOWING WHEN I'M SHIPPING ENTER
EVEN THE VOLUME OF WHAT I'M
SHIPPING AND- HOW DOES THAT
COMPORT WITH IT WITH THE GOAL
YOU MENTION OF CREATING AN
INFORMATION SYSTEM. YEAH THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION AND IN
HONESTLY I THINK THOSE ARE PART
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED
TO BE HAVE AND I WOULD SAY THIS
IS THAT. IF WE- WANT TO HAVE A
SUPPLY CHAIN AND A GOODS
MOVEMENT THAT'S WORKING. AND
THERE MIGHT BE OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY AROUND I THINK WITH. WITH
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
AND THERE'S WAYS TO DO THIS BUT
YOU CAN MAYBE. GET OUT NOT SURE
THAT PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
BUT AT LEAST GET THE DATA. YOU
KNOW AVAILABLE SO THAT WE CAN
GET THE GOODS MOVEMENT. WORKING
EFFICIENTLY. AND THAT'S WHERE
WE HAVE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND I THINK YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THOSE CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS AND- YOU KNOW AT
THIS POINT. I DON'T THINK WE
EVER WANT TO SEE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW WHICH IS YOU KNOW
THE PORTS JUST FULL OF CARGO
SHIPS BECAUSE THAT HELPS NO
ONE. WHEN ALL OF YOUR CARGO IS
SITTING OUT IN THE PORT WE NEED
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET
AND THEN. AND I THINK IN A IN A
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA. HOME TO
THE SILICON VALLEY THERE MUST
BE WAYS THAT WE CAN FIND A
SOLUTION TO THAT. AND I'M HAPPY
TO CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO FROM THE
RETAIL SIDE. TO TRY TO BE PART
OF THAT SOLUTION. GREAT THANK
YOU WILL TALK ABOUT EXPORTS.
FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. HAS EXPORT A LOT
OF ITS AUTHORITY. TO BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SUCH THAT- WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO THEM AND THEY
ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR US. AND
THAT CREATES A VERY FRUSTRATING
DYNAMIC AND HIGH AT TIMES. MANY
THINGS HAVE YOU KNOW WITH. A
LOT THE CHANGES GOOD. HAVE
BECAUSE THE BOARDS ARE. BUT THE
SAME AS A LARGE. OFTEN I'VE
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE I CAN'T
IMPACT. A TECHNICAL DECISION
THEY'RE MAKING. WITH REGARD TO
MATTERS OF MY DISTRICT. THAT
MIGHT. NEED TO BE MADE BUT
MAYBE MADE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT-
AND I WAS IT WAS GONNA GO GREEN
WE GOTTA MAKE GREAT WILL GO
GREAT- AND THEN THAT CAN BE
VERY FRUSTRATING. SO I SHARE
YOUR FRUSTRATION. THERE MR FONG.
WHAT THAT ANY COMMENTS OR ANY.
SEGAR CURRY. THANK YOU IN A
FIRST OFF THANK YOU ASSESSMENT
YOUR SOLUTIONS AND IDEAS THOSE
ARE VERY HELPFUL ANOTHER THING
WE CAN PUT IN OUR TOOL BOX
POTENTIALLY. I JUST WANNA MAKE
A COMMENT TWO MISTER ISAM- YOU
KNOW YOU. IF EVERYBODY'S EARS
DIDN'T PERK UP IS WHEN YOU SAID
WE ARE NOT GETTING OUR PRODUCTS
EXPORTED. THEY WERE SHIPPING
THEM TO TEXAS. MORRELL CARTING
TO THE EAST COAST. OR FLYING
COTTON TO PERU. ALL OF THIS IS
COSTING SOMEBODY A LOT OF MONEY
AND IT'S ALL OF US THAT ARE
SITTING IN THIS ROOM IN THE
LONG RUN. IT'S HURTING THE
PRODUCERS- OUR AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITIES SO ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK
ABOUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
AGRICULTURE CALIFORNIA WE TELL
OURSELF IS BEING THE NUMBER ONE
IN THE NATION FOR THE BEST
QUALITY PRODUCT IN THAT PEOPLE
WANT TO BUY OUR PRODUCTS. WE
DON'T OUR PRODUCTS IT'S ON ON
AT A WAREHOUSE RID SITTING ON
THE PORCH AND IT'S NOT FRESH
AND WONDERFUL ALL THE THINGS WE
COUNTED. IT'S A COST TO THE
CONSUMER IS COST TO OUR OUR
INDUSTRY SO- I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE THAT POINT IS THAT- WHEN
IT'S SITTING IN THE CHASIDIC
COST TO MOVE THIS PRODUCT FROM
POINT. WE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
OURSELVES THAT WE ARE NOT
EXPORTING IT FROM CALIFORNIA IN
A TIMELY FASHION AND SO- I JUST
WANTED TO BRING THAT TO HER AND
WAS ATTENTION IS LIKE WE WORRY
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT WELL BY
THE TIME YOU CURRENT THE STUFF
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES IS
THAT MAKES SENSE. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT TO
OUR ATTENTION AND- HOPEFULLY.
WE CAN WORK ON A SOLUTION FOR
THAT. THANK YOU GENERALLY
GONZALEZ S. THANK YOU ALL GREAT
COMMENTS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY AS WELL I
JUST WANTED TO ASK- EITHER OF
YOU BUT I KNOW- MYSTERY SOME
UNIT- MENTION THE CONTAINER
FEES IS SORT OF RANGE- I DON'T
KNOW AND ON THE BEEN THE PORTS
PERSPECTIVE FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN
INFERRING IN A LOT OF MEDIA
THAT IT SEEMS TO BE MOVING IN A
GOOD DIRECTION WITH CONTAINER
FEES OF COURSE IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE- YOU KNOW IT'S
JUST KIND OF RUNS THE GAMUT
BUT- WHAT CAN YOU SAY DO YOU
EXPECT THESE CONTAINER FEES TO.
BE JUST IN THIS EMERGENCY ONLY
DO EXPECT THEM TO BE LONG TERM
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE FOR
YOU AND YOUR PERSPECTIVE JUST
SO WE CAN GET ENOUGH ADDITIONAL
INSIGHT WELL WE HOPE IT'S IN
THE SHORT TERM YEAH AND RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF THE CRISIS- BUT
LIKE ANYTHING YET IT'LL START
TO THROTTLE GO UP IT'LL COME
DOWN BUT IT DOESN'T EVER COME
BACK TO WHAT IT WHAT IT WAS
BEFORE- BUT YES WE HOPE SO MANY
SURCHARGES LIKE THIS WEST COAST
PORT CONGESTION SURCHARGE WILL
GO AWAY. AND SOME OF THOSE AND
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE'RE THIS
IS OUR BUSINESS RIGHT I MEAN
LIKE I SAID ALL THESE
COMMODITIES MORE THAN 70% OR
PRODUCTS EXPORTED WE KNOW HOW
TO SCHEDULE AND THE SYSTEM
WORKS WHEN IT WHEN IT'S NOT IN
THE SITUATION SO WE'RE NOT
PAYING. ATTENTION TO MERGE FEES
MOST OF THE TIME- EVEN WHEN WE
DO WHEN THERE'S THAT ODD CASE
MOST THE TIME THE KERRS WILL
WAIVE THAT RIGHT NOW THAT
THEY'RE NOT AND SO- WE WOULD
HOPE IT WOULD GO AWAY AND
CERTAINLY- DIMINISH- ONCE WE
GET OUT OF THIS CRISIS RIGHT
NOW DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY AS WELL WITH
THE INDIRECT SOURCE REAL I KNOW
THAT THAT IS A THREE YEAR PHASE
IN PERIOD SO DEPENDING ON THE
WAREHOUSE- SQUARE FOOT SIZE.
232-023-2420 FIVE SO THERE IS
TIME- SO I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
OF COURSE THESE REGULATIONS ARE
ALWAYS TOUGH BUT- TO BEAR BUT I
KNOW A LOT OF THE POOR
COMMUNITIES ALSO ARE DEALING
WITH A LOT OF EMISSION SOURCES
SO- YOU KNOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT THAT OUTCOME THAT
TASK FORCE HASN'T. LOOKED FOR
TO BEING PART OF THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU. SAID ALI. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU GET INTO THIS BUT
YOU MATCH IN YOUR STATEMENT OF
FOREIGN SHIPS WHAT WHAT'S THE
RATIO FOR TO. CHIPSET- OUR
AMERICAN TOP. THERE NO LONGER
ANY AMERICAN SHIPPING LINES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WOULD
THAT WILK THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND
YOUR WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE WITH
THAT MOVIE WILL MOVE TO A PANEL
TO. WHICH OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS ROLE IN
EASING CONGESTION OUR SECOND
PANEL WILL DISCUSS THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS ROLE IN
EASING CONGESTION AS A REMINDER
WE WILL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
TO THE END OF THIS PANEL
UNFORTUNATELY. CONGRESSMAN ALAN
LOWENTHAL. IT IS STARTING TO
TALK RIGHT NOW. BOB BUT HE'S
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN PERSON
BUT HE SENT A RECORDED MESSAGE-
HE'S A GOOD GUY HE REPRESENTS
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH- HE'S
BEEN IN FULLY ENGAGED IN PORTS
MATTER SINCE ELECTED TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE PROBABLY
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I WAS A
GOOD GUY SO WE'LL GO TO A
CONGRESSMAN BONTA. HI RES AND.
ALSO HELLO WORLD LARGEST. AND
WE'RE SEEING OTHERS. STEP.
THE
BILL BACKED. THIS IS. FOR USING
WHICH WAS CAPACITY AND
CRITICALLY INJURED. GOOD SCHOOL.
PEOPLE SPIEGEL WHO DISAGREE
HAVE BEEN PATIENT BY. NO THIS
WE ARE STRUGGLING SOME OF THE
MOST CHALLENGING. CONGRESS AND
IF IT IS STEPPING UP AND DOING
EVERYTHING. TO THANK YOU WITH
YOU THIS MEANS THAT STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOU CONGRESSMAN
NOW. FOR SURE US YOUR THOUGHTS
TODAY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN AT THE
FED LEVEL ALL THERE'S A LETTER
IN YOUR PACKET FROM- JOHN COREY
HE'S THE PORT. FOR THE BYTON
HARRISON. AND OUTLINES FEDERAL.
TO ADDRESS THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS NOW MOVE TO OUR PAN
THERE ALREADY OUT HERE GREAT-
TODAY WE BEFORE- DAVID CAMPS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE. AGENCY
HERE THOSE ANDY MY SENIOR. GOV
GAVIN AND DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ALSO
IN PERSON WITH US TODAY MAY
PERCEIVE ALREADY. THE MORNING
CARE. THE WHOLE SET ON. WE'LL
START OVER YEAH WE GOT GOOD
MORNING CHERYL DONALD CHURCHES
ALSO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCHFOR CALLING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT AND TIMELY
HEARING IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE DEALING MYERS
DIRECTOR OF GOLD IS. JUST TO
PUT THINGS INTO PERSPECTIVE I
WANT TO MAKE TWO QUICK POINTS
AT THE OUTSET. FIRST WE ARE
EXPERIENCING GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAIN CHALLENGES THIS IS NOT.
JUST A CALIFORNIA SITUATION AS
CENTER BRADFORD POINTED OUT. NO
NO THAT'S GENERALLY UNDERSTOOD-
BUT IT IS WORTH UNDERSCORING.
WHAT THE SUMMER AND FALL KEY
PORTS ABROAD HAVE SHUT DOWN FOR
WEEKS DUE TO CODED AS WELL AS
OVERSEAS FACTORIES PRODUCING
GOODS FOR THE US. MAJOR PORTS
IN HONG KONG AND SHANGHAI HAVE
ALSO BEEN EXPERIENCING SIMILAR
CONGESTION TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN
AT THE SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS.
SECOND WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO ADDRESS ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN EVERY LINK IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN INCLUDING RETAILERS
BENEFICIAL CARGO OWNERS WITH
LOGISTICS WORKFORCE RETENTION
AND ELSEWHERE. ALL OF YOU HAVE
SEEN RECENT ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM
THE PORTS OF LA AND LONG BEACH
CALLING ON TERMINAL OPERATORS
TO PROVIDE EXPANDED TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN GATE OUT GATE HOURS. AND
THIS IS A GOOD THING FOR. IT'S
ALSO IMPERATIVE. THAT WE
CONTINUE TO COORDINATE WITH
RETAILERS. AND BENEFICIAL CARGO
OWNERS TO OFFICIALLY MOVE YOUR
CONTAINERS FROM OUR PORTS. WE
ALSO NEED TO WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHERS. TO
PROVIDE SPACE FOR CONTAINER
YARDS SO WE HAVE CONTAINER
CHALICES AND TRUCKING CAPACITY
SERVICES NOW TO REPORT. FOR
EXAMPLE THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT
BY LONG BEACH MAYOR ROBERT
GARCIA. TO TEMPORARILY WAIVE
THE PROHIBITION ON CONTAINER
STOCK MORE THAN TWO HIGH. THIS
IS ALL ABOUT HOLISTIC
COORDINATION ON SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
DIRECTOR MYERS FOR INVITING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY CAL STUCK TO PARTNER ON
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN TO
STEP SIX USSISHKIN. WITH THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH AND CAL
STATE LONG BEACH IS CENTER FOR
INTERNATIONAL TRADE. AND
TRANSPORTATION. AS PART OF THAT
INITIATIVE WE HOSTED A VERY
SUCCESSFUL STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENTS IN SEPTEMBER. AND
WE'RE NOW WAITING ON THE FINAL
REPORT AND RECOMMENDATIONS. IN
THE MEANTIME I WANT TO BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU ACTIONS WE
HAVE CAL STAR ARE ALREADY
TAKING TO ADDRESS SUPPLY CHAIN
CHALLENGES. FIRST THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC KILLS TO HAS BEEN
LASER FOCUSED ON THE SUPPLY
CHAIN THE MOVEMENT OF EMERGENCY
SUPPLIES. PP FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE FIRST FEW
MUCH THE PANDEMIC THE US
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
TEMPORARY TEMPORARILY ALLOWED
STATES TO RESTRICT WHAT LIMITS
ON THE INTERSTATE SYSTEM. FOR
THE DELIVERY OF EMERGENCY
RELIEF SUPPLIES. CALTRANS TOOK
IMMEDIATE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
TEMPORARY FLEXIBILITY. AND FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
CALTRANS HAS BEEN PERMITTING
OVERSIZE AGRICULTURAL TRUCK
OPERATIONS ON THE NON
INTERSTATE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
TO MITIGATE WORKER RETENTION
ISSUES IN THE AG TRUCKING
INDUSTRY. AND NOW PURSUANT TO
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE. CALTRANS WILL
IDENTIFY AND EVALUATE PRIORITY
THREE ROUTES TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR A TEMPORARY EXEMPTION OF
TRUCK WEIGHT LIMITS ON THE NON
INTERSTATE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
ALSO ENQUIRING WITH US DOT
WHETHER ANY ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR OVERSIZED TRUCK
OPERATIONS ON THE INTERSTATE
CAN BE APPLIED. NOW AS SOMEONE
WHO SPENT TIME IN WASHINGTON AS
A SENIOR LEVEL- APPOINTEE AT
THE US DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION I'VE ALSO TAKEN
A LEADERSHIP ROLE CORDONING
WITH U. S. DOT LEADERSHIP. AND
THE WHITE HOUSE SUPPLY CHAIN
TASK FORCE TO ADDRESS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CHALLENGES. IN
JULY ARE REPRESENTED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT CIRCUITRY
PEOPLE JUDGES ROUNDTABLE WITH
ST PETER OF A SUPPLY CHAIN
STAKEHOLDERS. AND AS A FOLLOW
UP TO SECRETARY PERDUE JUDGES
ROUNDTABLE I COORDINATED THE
PARTICIPATION OF WHITE HOUSE
PORT ENVOY JOHN PER CARI. AND
ACTING MARITIME ADMINISTRATOR
LUCINDA LESLIE IN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS
INITIATIVE. I AM IN REGULAR
CONVERSATION WITH ENVOY FOR
CARI TOMORROW VERY WELL FROM MY
TIME AT U. S. D. O. T. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH HIM.
AND SUPPORTING HIS EFFORTS WITH
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO SECURE
ACCESS TO LAND FOR CONTAINER
YARD. ALSO MAINTAINING
COMMUNICATION WITH FEDERAL
FEDERAL MARITIME COMMISSION
SURE DOWN BUFFET. AND
COMMISSIONER KARL BENTZEL. BOTH
OF WHOM HAVE RECENTLY TRAVELED
TO CALIFORNIA TO MEET FORTY
STAKEHOLDERS. IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS KELSO HAS PARTICIPATED
MEETINGS WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
GOBIZ LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO DISCUSS TRUCK
DRIVER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION. SEVERAL OF OUR
AGENCIES ARE ALSO DEVELOPING A
STUDY WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA TO EXAMINE AG
TRUCKING WORKFORCE ISSUES. AND
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
WORKFORCE ISSUES LOOM LARGE- IN
FACT JUST LAST WEEK WE MET WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE AND MEERA
JOSHI. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
NOMINEE TO HEAD UP THE FEDERAL
MOTOR CARRIER SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION. WITH A VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
APPLYING REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
TRUCKING WORKFORCE. NOW AS FAR
AS LONG TERM SOLUTIONS ARE
CONCERNED LESS THAN A WEEK AGO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ANNOUNCED A
HISTORIC STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP
WITH US DOT. TO JOINTLY
DEVELOP. WITH REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS A PROGRAM OF MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR FREIGHT RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THIS
PARTNERSHIP WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO EXPEDITE A
NETWORK OF RELATED PROJECTS
RATHER THAN USING A PIECEMEAL
APPROACH. THAT COLLECTIVELY
WILL HELP GROW THE ECONOMY.
IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT
FACILITATE THE MOVEMENT OF
GOODS AND STRUCK IN SUPPLY
CHAIN RESILIENCE THROUGHOUT THE
US AND CALIFORNIA'S CRITICAL
THREE QUARTERS. SO USDOT AND
CAL STAR WILL EXECUTE WHAT'S
CALLED AN EMERGING PROJECTS
AGREEMENT. WERE DOT WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
EXPERTISE AND STAFF TIME TO
DEVELOP PROJECTS FOR ENTRY INTO
INNOVATIVE FINANCING PROGRAMS
LIKE TO FREE UP. TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE AND
INNOVATION ACT AS WELL AS ROOF
WHICH STANDS FOR RAILROAD ROUTE
REAL RAILROAD REHABILITATION
AND IMPROVEMENT FINANCING
PROGRAM. AND JUST BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND TO FEEL AND ROOF ARE
AMONG THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
PRIMEROS LOAN PROGRAMS AND THEY
ARE HIGHLY SOUGHT AFTER. THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY OFFER VERY
FAVORABLE LOAN REPAYMENT TERMS
FOR PROJECT SPONSORS. ANYONE
WHO CAN GET A TWO IF YOU ARE
REFLECTS ON HIS MOST FORTUNATE
BECAUSE IT USUALLY PLAYS A
MAJOR ROLE IN A PROJECTS
OVERALL FUNDING AND FINANCING
PLAN IT WORKS ESPECIALLY WELL.
FOR MEGA PROJECTS. WHAT'S TRULY
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THE
DISAGREEMENT IS THAT IT WILL
GIVE CALIFORNIA ADDITIONAL
TOOLS TO TAKE A PROGRAMMATIC
APPROACH TO ADVANCE FREE
PROJECTS AND LEVERAGE LOCAL.
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT. AS WELL
AS TARGETING STATE INVESTMENT
THROUGH GRANTS THE BUDGET
PROCESS OR FINANCING
ARRANGEMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STRUCTURE BACK. BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY IN THE PAST IT WAS A
SERIES OF ONE OFF PROJECTS WITH
VERY LITTLE CONSIDERATION GIVEN
TO HELP PROJECTS FIT TOGETHER
IN A HOLISTIC MANNER. IN
ADVANCE COMMON GOALS. ALL OF
THAT WILL CHANGE THE
DISAGREEMENT. ON TOP OF THAT
THE AGREEMENT WILL SUDDEN SET
THE STAGE FOR LEVERAGING
FEDERAL SUPPORT IN CARRYING OUT
THE DIRECTION OF EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
TO DEVELOP PROPOSALS AND
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR PORT AND
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS. SO
BY DREDGING UP HOLISTIC PROGRAM
A PROJECT AIMED AT ELIMINATING
BOTTLENECKS AND IMPROVING THE
FLOW OF GOODS IN AND AROUND
CALIFORNIA PORTS. THESE
PROJECTS HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
REDUCE HARMFUL POLLUTION WITH
FEWER ODDLY TRUCKS AND SHIPS AT
SEA. SORE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT THE AGREEMENT WILL MEAN
FOR CALIFORNIA I THINK IT
REPRESENTS A STRONG FEDERAL
STATE COLLABORATION AND
FRANKLY. IT'S EXACTLY THE KIND
OF APPROACH WE NEED IN ORDER TO
TACKLE THIS VERY COMPLEX
CHALLENGE AS I'VE SAID ON MANY
OCCASIONS. EVEN A LARGE STAKE
WHITE CALIFORNIA CANNOT SOLVE
THIS ON OUR OWN WE THE
PARTNERSHIP OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OTHERS TO
IDENTIFY AND PURSUE THE RIGHT
SOLUTIONS. THAT'S WHAT THIS
AGREEMENT REPRESENTS AND I LOOK
FOR TO KEEP YOU UPDATED AS WE
MOVE AHEAD. FINALLY I SIMPLY
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE GET CALLS
TO HAVE LED THE STATE'S EFFORTS
IN COORDINATING ADVOCACY WITH
CONGRESS AND THE BIDEN HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION. ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN
AMERICAN JOBS ACT AND THE BILL
BACK BETTER BUDGET
RECONCILIATION BILL THAT'S NOW
PENDING IN CONGRESS AS
CONGRESSMAN LOWENTHAL ALLUDED
TO. THIS SUMMER I LEAD A MULTI
STATE COALITION URGING CONGRESS
TO PASS THE PRESIDENT'S
PROPOSAL. TO INVEST AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN BILLION.
IN COASTAL PORTS. INLAND
WATERWAYS LAND PORTS OF ENTRY.
AND FERRIES WHICH ARE ALL
ESSENTIAL TORN NATION THREE.
AND JUST LAST MONTH I WROTE TO
THE ENTIRE CONGRESSIONAL TO
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
DELEGATION TO URGE CONGRESS TO
PROVIDE TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
IN FEDERAL GRANTS TO SUPPORT
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL NOW PENDING
INCLUDES SEVENTEEN BILLION FOR
PORTS AND WATERWAYS AND THE
RECONCILIATION BILL THE HOUSE
AT SIX HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
MARITIME ADMINISTRATION TO
SUPPORT SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE
AND INCREASE PORT VISIT OUR
OFFICIAL C. SO THROW ADVOCACY
WITH CONGRESS IN A RECENT
AGREEMENT WITH US DOT. KELSO
HAS REALLY ELEVATED THE
DISCUSSION AROUND CALIFORNIA'S
NEED FOR FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING. I THINK WE ARE NOW
VERY WELL POSITIONED TO BENEFIT
FROM FEDERAL FUNDING. AT A TIME
WHEN CONGRESS WILL BE MAKING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AVAILABLE
TO ADDRESS THIS NEED. ONE LAST
NOTE AND I AM FOLLOWING THE
LEAD OF CHIRLA DONALD ENSURE
GONZALEZ ONE TAKE A MOMENT TO
COMMEND AND THANK ALL THE WOMEN
AND MEN- WORKING TO KEEP GOODS
MOVING IN AND OUT OF OUR PORTS.
THESE WORKERS HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO KEEP THE SUPPLY
CHAIN MOVING IN THE MIDST OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. I HOPE ALL OF
US CAN BE EXPLOITED INSPIRED BY
THEIR EXAMPLE. AS WE COLLECT WE
STEP UP TO TACKLE THE MANY
IMPORTANT CHALLENGES IN FRONT
OF US. AND SO WITH THAT SURE
O'DONNELL INSURE GONZALEZ THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME AND LOOK FOR
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU TO DIRECTOR MYERS. THANK
YOU SHERMAN O'DONNELL AND
CAROLINE'S ALL US- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANKS FOR
INVITING ME HERE DISCUSS- WHAT
IS CLEARLY A PRESSING ISSUE
ISSUE OF CONGESTION NOT ONLY IN
OUR- CALIFORNIA PORTS AROUND.
THANKS MY NAME IS DEE DEE MYERS
AND I'M A SENIOR ADVISER TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND DIRECTOR OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AS WE ALL KNOW WITH
GOBIZ- I KNOW A LOT IT'S BEEN
SAID AND WRITTEN INCLUDING HERE
TODAY ABOUT THE CAUSES OF
SUPPLY CHAIN CONGESTION AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE SECRETARY KIM
NOTED- IT'S A GLOBAL PROBLEM
MANY YEARS IN THE MAKING THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
OVER NIGHT GOOD TO MOVE AROUND
THE WORLD VIA AN EXCEEDINGLY
COMPLEX SYSTEM RIGHT TO SYSTEM
OF SYSTEMS- IT'S CONTROLLED
MOSTLY BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND PRIVATE CONTRACTS IS ALSO
BEEN DISCUSSED- CHANGING COST
STRUCTURES NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
AND EVOLVING TERRACE AMONG
OTHER THINGS WERE ALREADY
PUTTING PRESSURE ON THAT SYSTEM
AND WHEN CODE NINETEEN HIT MORE
CRACKS WERE REVEALED AND THE
PROBLEMS WERE EXACERBATED-
EARLY ON A LOT OF NATION'S
LIMITED OR SHUT DOWN GOOD TO
MOVEMENT TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH CREATING A BACKLOG THAT
TROUBLED AROUND THE WORLD- AND
A SHIPPING RESUMED CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR CHANGED- AND DEMAND
SURGE THAT BACKLOG GREW INTO
THE SEVERE CONGESTION THAT
WE'RE NOW EXPERIENCING- AND
THIS LED TO REAL AND SOMETIMES
PERCEIVED SHORTAGES EVERYTHING
FROM TOILET PAPER STATIONARY
BIKES TO IN THE EARLY DAYS
SUPPLIES NEEDED TO FIGHT THE
PANDEMIC. SO IN THOSE EARLY
DAYS WE'D GO BIZ WORK CLOSELY
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES APART
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES
FACING BOTH THE HEALTH HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IN OUR CENTRAL
WORKERS- AND TO GET THEM THE
CRITICAL SUPPLIES THAT THEY
NEEDED SO WE TAPPED EXISTING
STATE RESERVES OF GLOVES MASKS
AND OTHER PP AND FOUND
SUPPLIERS TO PROVIDE MILLIONS
MORE WE WORK WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AS WE HAVE THROUGHOUT
THIS AS MANUFACTURERS RETOOLED
FROM MAKING CLOSE TO MAKING A
NINETY FIVE MASKS OR FOR
MAKING- LIQUOR PRODUCTS TO MAKE
HAND SANITIZER AND THEN WE PUT
PRIORITIZE GETTING THAT P. P.
E. R. TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS
INCLUDING PORT WORKERS. ARE
WHEN VACCINES BECAME AVAILABLE
WE AGAIN PRIORITIZED OUR PORTS
UNDERSTANDING THAT PROTECTING
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
THOSE WORKERS. ACROSS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN WAS ACTUALLY AB.
SEND TO KEEP GOOD TO MOVE. HELP
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM OUTED. WE
ALSO LOOK FOR OTHER STEPS THAT
WE COULD TAKE BECAUSE WE KNEW
IT WAS CRITICAL. TO BRING
TOGETHER THE DIVERSE NETWORK OF
SUPPLY CHAIN STAKEHOLDERS TO
DISCUSS KEY CHALLENGES AND
FIND. CREATIVE SOLUTIONS SO
THAT'S IN SEPTEMBER SECRETARY
KIM NOTED WE PARTNERED WITH CAL
STUFF. THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY LONG
BEACH OUGHT TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS
INITIATIVE. AND KEY ELEMENTS OF
THAT INCLUDED A MEDIA A SOCIAL
MEDIA CAMPAIGN TO. ELEVATE SOME
OF THE ISSUES A VIRTUAL
WORKSHOP AND THEN IN PERSON
SENATE. I'M IN THE FORM FINAL
REPORT OF THAT WILL BE.
AVAILABLE SOMETIME IN THE NEXT
MONTH OR SO BUT THE CONVENING
MADE A COUPLE OF THINGS CLEAR.
ODDS THAT THERE WAS A QUITE A
BIT OF AGREEMENT AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHAT THE
SHORT TERM STEPS AND LONGER
TERM STEPS. WOULD BE NEEDED TO
GET THINGS MOVING AGAIN WE NEED
TO CREATE MORE STORAGE SPACE
FOR CONTAINERS WILL PREPARE A
LOT ABOUT. INCREASE ACCESS TO
CHASTITY'S. TRANSITION THE
SUPPLY CHAIN TO MORE HOURS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO BECOME THE
SHORTHAND FOR THAT. COLLECT AND
USE DATA MORE EFFICIENTLY GROW
AND PREPARE THE SUPPLY CHAIN
WORKFORCE FOR NOW IN THE
FUTURE. AND INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL NEED TO
CREATE CAPACITY AND RESILIENCE
AS WE GO FORWARD- BUT PERHAPS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT CAME OUT OF THAT OF
THAT CONVENING. WAS THAT THERE
IS TREMENDOUS AGREEMENT ACROSS
THE BOARD THAT IN ORDER TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS EVERY
SINGLE STAKEHOLDER IN SUPPLY
CHAIN IS GOING TO HAVE TO STEP
U AND MAKE DIFFICULT CHOICES.
AND BECOME PART OF THE SOLUTION
AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD A LOT.
OF THAT FROM EVERYBODY TODAY-
INCLUDING THE STATE. OUGHT SO
TO THAT END- WE IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT XCELERATED OUR WORK-
WHICH LED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH WAS ISSUED ON
SEPTEMBER. TWENTIETH THE EO-
DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO IDENTIFY
STATE ON PROPERTIES AS YOU KNOW
THAT CAN BE AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS SHORT TERM- CARGO
CONTAINER STORAGE NEEDS IN GOLD
IS ALSO WORKING WITH. FEDERAL
AND PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS TO-
IDENTIFY POSSIBLE OPTION-
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY IS DIRECTED- TO IDENTIFY
PRIORITY FREIGHT ROUTES TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION WOULD SECRETARY
MANAGE- AND- GROUP GROSS
VEHICLE WEIGHT LIMITS AND
ALLOW. TRUCKS TO CARRY
ADDITIONAL CARGO. THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AGENCIES
DIRECTED TO CREATE WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS EXPEDITE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIX THIRTY
NINE. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS DIRECTED TO WORK
WITH STATE AGENCIES DEVELOP TO
DEVELOP. LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
THAT SUPPORT PORT OPERATIONS
AND GOOD MOVEMENTS. FOR THE
GOVERNOR JANUARY. TENTH BUDGET-
IS SO THAT'S RELATIVELY SHORT
TERM- IDENTIFICATION IN THOSE
WILL INCLUDE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS
ELECTRIC PERFECT
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE GOODS
MOVEMENT. SYSTEM FROM PORT TO
DELIVERY. DATA DIGITIZATION
WILL PREPARE A LOT ABOUT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. SO IN
ADDITION TO THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER- YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING OTHER
STEPS. AGAIN THE SECRETARY SAID
COUNTS TO TEMPORARILY RELAX
WAIT REGULATIONS FOR TRUCKS.
BOTH HAULING ROOM. EMERGENCY
RELIEF SUPPLIES EARLY ON IN THE
AG PRODUCTS. WE'VE CREATED AN
INTERAGENCY SUPPLY CHAIN TASK
FORCE THAT DOESN'T GET TO THE
YOU KNOW THE BROADER
STAKEHOLDERS BUT INSIDE THE
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE- NOT ONLY IMPLEMENTING
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. BUT ALSO
IDENTIFYING POTENTIAL OTHER
SOLUTIONS AND THEN LAST WEEK
THE GOVERNOR CAST ON THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
SIGNED EPA THAT. THE SECRETARY
DISCUSSED. OUT WILL CONTINUE
OUR WORK WITH OTHER PARTNERS
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNERS AND OUR LABOR
PARTNERS AS WE GO FORWARD. I'M
SHOWING THE PRESIDENT- PRESENT
BIDEN WAS HERE IN OCTOBER
OCTOBER FOURTEENTH- AND
ANNOUNCED THE- LA LA WOULD JOIN
LONG BEACH AN OPENING THIS CASE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN WHICH- YOU
KNOW BIG. BIG BEGAN TO CREATE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS JOINING THAT
CONVERSATION FROM SOME OF OUR
LARGE RETAILERS LIKE WALMART
TARGET SAM SUNG AND HOLD HOME
DEPOT. FEDEX AND UPS ALSO
AGREED TO MOVE MORE CONTAINERS
DURING NIGHT TIME HOURS. WE'VE
ALL TALKED ABOUT HOW THE RAIL
RAIL. CARRIERS ARE CRITICAL TO
THIS. THEY'VE UNION PACIFIC IS
COMMITTED TO A SIXTY DAHLE
REBATE FOR CAN. THAT ENTER THE
PORTS ON WE AND BE. IS OFFERING
A FIFTY DOLLAR INCENTIVES AND
OF COURSE THE I. O. W. S.
PLEDGE TO MEET DEMANDS OF THE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SCHEDULE SO
THERE'S A LOT OF. INTEREST IN
EXPANDING HOURS- BUT IT'S IT
YOU KNOW ONE STEP AT A TIME-
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH ALSO
UNVEILED ITS PILOT PROJECT WITH
TTI TO EXPAND GATES. OCTOBER
TERMINAL HOURS AT ONE TERMINAL
SO- AND FINALLY WE HEARD- THE
L. A. PORTS THE- REPORT ADDED
UP A NEW FEE- WHICH WILL TAKE
AFFECTED MIDDLE OF THIS MONTH.
SO IT'S CLEAR THERE'S NO SINGLE
CAUSE AND THERE IS CERTAINLY NO
SINGLE SOURCE SIMPLE SOLUTION-
WE CAN ONLY SOLVE THIS CRISIS
IF EVERYONE WORKS TOGETHER.
STARTING WITH TRANSITIONING- TO
MORE ROBUST ROUND THE CLOCK
SUPPLY CHAIN OPERATION
IDENTIFYING THOSE ADDITIONAL
SITES- CLEARING EMPTY
CONTAINERS OFF THE PORT TO
ALLOW FOR MORE EFFICIENT- AND
MORE ACCESSIBLE MOVEMENT OF
GOODS- SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ALL OF US- AND- AND- WE
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AS WE
GO FORWARD. I'M ENCOURAGED BY
HOW EVERYBODY HAS STEPPED UP
THE PORCH THE RETAILER'S THE
RAILWAYS THE WAREHOUSES- YOU
KNOW TO REALLY TRY TO SOLVE
THESE COMPLEX AND VERY
INTERCONNECTED CHALLENGES- AND
WE ARE OF COURSE AS HAS BEEN
SAID FOREVER INDEBTED TO THE
LONGSHOREMEN STEVEDORES THE
CHECKERS THE WAREHOUSE
PERSONNEL THE CRANE OPERATORS
THE TRUCKERS. THE REAL
OPERATING SHIPBUILDERS AND
FERRYBOAT OPERATORS IN PORT
AUTHORITY PERSONNEL WHO HAVE.
STEPPED UP TO OUT OF THIS
CRISIS SOMETIMES PUTTING
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AT RISK TO DO SO I THINK WE'RE
ALL GRATEFUL FOR THAT. BUT BY
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY- WE CAN
MEET. OUR MUTUAL GOALS WE HAVE
THE ACCELERATOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN PROTECT THE ASSET
OF OUR PORTS WE HAVE TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT TRANSITION TO
CLEANER MORE RESILIENT SLOT
SUPPLY CHAIN FROM BEGINNING TO
END. AND WE HAVE TO SUPPORT THE
CREATION. OF HIGH QUALITY JOB
PROVIDE TRAINING FOR THOSE
JOBS- THAT WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
PORTS WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
ENGINES OF ECONOMIC GROWTH I'VE
BEEN SO ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND HAVE
MADE US A LEADER. IN THE WORLD
IN THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
ON. ON THE PLANET SO WITH THAT
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ROADS FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. I JUST QUICK
QUESTION FOR- DIRECTOR OF
MYERS- THE PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS- THAT AS
SOME OF THE EXECUTIVE AGENCIES
WHAT LOOK FOR MORE SPACE MORE
LAND. YEP OUR PROPERTY JUST
STORE CONTAINERS BECAUSE THE
DOCKS ARE FULL. WHAT WHAT IS
THE STATUS OF THAT EFFORT. THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER- REQUIRES THAT
THAT THAT THAT SURVEYED
COMPLETE BY JUST FIFTEENTH WE
MAY BE DONE SOONER SO. WE'VE
YOU KNOW WE'VE STARTED BY
WORKING WITH THE PORTS TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE
PARAMETERS OF THAT LAND WHAT
WOULD BE WHAT WOULD WORK. AND
THEN TO START TO SERVE A
DIFFERENT PARCELS AND I THINK
WE TRIED TO EXPAND THAT SEARCH
WE NOW HAVE A- A PRETTY LOW BUT
ROBUST LIST OF SEVERAL DOZEN.
THERE ARE COMMON COMPLICATIONS
FOR EACH OF THEM BUT WE'RE KIND
OF WORKING THROUGH THE
QUESTIONS AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND- WHICH IF ANY- WOULD
BE- WOULD ACTUALLY HELP ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM SO JIM PROCESS AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO. KEEP YOU POSTED
IF AS AS WE GO FORWARD BUT
AGAIN THE ETHOS OF A STATUS AS
A DEADLINE OF NO LATER THAN
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH. AT
APPRECIATE THE ECONOMY YOU'RE
GOING TO TRY AN EXPEDITED GET
IT DONE BEFORE DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH. AND THOSE PROPERTIES
WOULD SERVE BOTH PORTS. YEAH
ADDITION WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING.
THE WITHIN NOT WITHIN A RANGE
OF BOTH PARTS BUT I THINK
DEPENDING ON ON WHERE THEY ARE
AND WHAT WHAT PROP YOU KNOW
WHAT. ASSETS THEY OFFER. OTHER
COULD BE POTENTIALLY AVAILABLE
TO EITHER PORK OR BOTH PARTS.
GREAT THANK YOU. AND QUESTION
FOR SECRETARY KIM. THIS SOMEONE
IN INDIANA IS GETTING A CHEAP
TV. BUT CALIFORNIA IS PAYING
THE PRICE IN IN IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS CERTAIN
ENVIRONMENTALLY. BUT ALSO
FINANCIALLY WERE CARRYING SOME
OF THE BURDEN TO SUPPORT OUR
PORTS BECAUSE- WE'RE NOT
GETTING. OUR FAIR SHARE OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS SO WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA DOING. TO ENSURE
THAT THAT GOING FORWARD. WE DO
WORK TO GET OUR FAIR SHARE
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO SUPPORT. OUR
PORTS WHICH MOVE. MOST OF. THE
NATION'S GOODS AND WE SHOULD.
YOU KNOW. BE THE OVERWHELMING
RECIPIENT OF THOSE DOLLARS
ALREADY TO CLEARLY WERE NOT.
JERRELL DONNELL THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- I THINK IT'S BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED LIKE NEVER BEFORE
THAT THERE IS AN INVESTMENT IN
BALANCE BETWEEN. CO OF PORTS
ALONG THE EAST COAST AND GULF
COAST RELATIVE TO CLOSE UP POST
SORRY PORTS ON THE WEST COAST
HUGE AMOUNTS HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT BY VARIOUS FOLKS.
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO WORK
HAND IN HAND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION AND CALL AND THE
ENTIRE CONGRESS. AND THE WHITE
HOUSE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
SURE WE ADDRESS THAT AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY
THANKFULLY OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT'S NOW
PENDING INCLUDE SEVENTEEN
BILLION FOR PORTS. AND THEN IN
THE RECONCILIATION BILL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION FOR RESILIENCY
PROJECTS SO THERE IS A LOT OF
MONEY COMING DOWN THE PIKE. WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET AS
MUCH OF AS WE CAN MOST OF THIS
WILL BE DONE EITHER A
COMBINATION OF FORMULA. AND
DISCRETIONARY- REGARDLESS IF
IT'S DISCRETIONARY WE'RE GOING
TO COMPETE LIKE CRAZY FOR THAT
MONEY AND NOT TO GET TOO MUCH
INTO THE WEEDS BUT THE REASON
THERE'S NO BALANCE IN THE
HARBOR MAINTENANCE TRUST FUNDS
BECAUSE JUST THE UNUSUAL
NATURE. OF THE FORMAL OF THE
WAY IT'S SET UP. WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS IT AND WITH THE HELP OF
PEOPLE LIKE CONGRESSMAN
LOWENTHAL AND OTHERS- WE'RE
GONNA DO IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHER. QUESTIONS REALLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR FONG- I
THINK YOU MUCH- I'VE I GUESS
FIRST GOING TO. A DIRECTOR
MYERS- I APPRECIATE THE UPDATE
I YOU'D MENTIONED THAT THERE'S
AS TASK FORCE THAT'S IN PLACE
AND YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
RETAILER'S YOU'VE HEARD FROM-
INFORMATICA SERVER FROM A LOT
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS I'M SURE
YOU'RE TALKING TO ALL OF THE
DAILY- AND OF COURSE THIS
CONCERNED ABOUT RE EVALUATING.
THE SYSTEM IN THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS AND ORDINANCES AND
OF COURSE. MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S A HOLISTIC APPROACH IS
THE ADMINISTRATION LOOKING AT.
ALL THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS
AND WHAT'S BURDENING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AND- WILLING TO REMOVE
SOME OF THOSE- ANCHORS. YES I
THINK WE'RE WILLING TO LOOK AT-
AT AT A HOLISTIC APPROACH IT AS
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED AND TO FIND
WAYS TO TRY TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD I THINK. THAT THIS IS A
VERY COMPLICATED PROCESS OF
GREAT COMPLICATED SET OF
PROBLEMS- AND I CERTAINLY DON'T
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE WILLING
TO JUST WHOLESALE. INDEFINITELY
LIFT CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE TO DO
THIS IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE
ENVIRONMENT PROTECT WORKERS
PROTECTS THE COMMUNITIES IN
THOSE. QUARTERS OF COMMERCE
THAT WE AS WE HEARD FROM SOME
OF THE MEMBERS OF OUR EVEN BEEN
REALLY IMPACTED BUT I THINK
WE'VE ALREADY SHOWN. THAT WE'RE
WILLING TO LOOK AT- LIFTING
REGULATIONS YOU KNOW WHAT
WEIGHT LIMITS ON TRUCKS OFFER
CRITICAL SUPPLIES FINDING NEW
ROUTES TWENTY OTHER THINGS
WE'VE DONE IS- IN IN IN IN
YOUR- GROUP BUT DAVID IS- HELP
TO EXPEDITE. LICENSES FOR
PROPER THROUGH DMV ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS WHERE WE
CAN YOU KNOW ACCOMMODATE
CHANGES- TO FACILITATE THE
PROBLEM BUT NOT TO MAKE
WHOLESALE THROWING OUT. OF SOME
OF THE IMPORT PROTECTION AND
I'M AND I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR
THROWING THINGS OUT I THINK
OVER TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEFT AND THE RIGHT HAND RIGHT
NOW NOT COMMUNICATING. AND SO
IF YOU LOOK AT IT WE WILL TAKE
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS TO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND OUR OUR THEIR
ACCOMMODATIONS WE CAN MAKE TO
ATTEMPT TO MAKE PROGRESS
ENSURING SLOWER AND SAID THERE
IS A CONCERN AND IN
APPRECIATION WITH AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT. YOU HAVE
TO LOOK NOT ONLY.
RETROSPECTIVELY BUT
PROSPECTIVELY BECAUSE I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS- WITH
THAT AFFECT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
WHETHER IT'S OFFENSE- THE
REPAIR REGULATIONS OR OR
ORDINANCES THAT IMPACT. THE
PORTS RAIL TRUCKING
MANUFACTURING WAREHOUSES- THAT
ARE NOT HAVING GONE INTO EFFECT
YET. THAT TO COULD GO INTO
EFFECT IN THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO
THAT ACTUALLY COULD. EXACERBATE
THE PROBLEM THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THERE IS AN
APPRECIATION AMONGST
MINISTRATION ABOUT THAT. YEAH I
THINK AGAIN I THINK WE WANT
HAVE A CONTINUED CALM DIALOGUE
WITH ALL OF YOU AND WITH OUR
PARTNERS THE INDIAN AT. EVERY
NODE IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND WE
DO TALK REGULARLY TO AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE
IN. IN THIS. CHAIN THAT'S MORE.
FOR ALSO MEET OUR- LONG TERM
ECONOMIC GOALS WHICH IS
INCLUDING TRANSITIONING TO A-
TO A CLEANER COST SUPPLY CHAIN
BUT YES I THINK THE- SHORT
ANSWER IS YES. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE GO FORWARD AS
WE MAKE INVESTMENTS AND AS WE
TRY TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE TO
BUILD AGAIN A RESILIENT- SUPPLY
CHAIN. WE'RE NOT GOING BACK TO
WHAT IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO LET
ALONE TEN YEARS AGO WE'RE GOING
FORWARD AND HOW TO MEASURE.
CALIFORNIA TO STICK TO SUCCEED
AND THRIVE. IN THAT ENVIRONMENT
HOW DO WE WORK WITH ALL THE
PARTNERS REQUIRED TO DO THAT-
STRESSING THAT WE ARE
RECOGNIZED UNDERSTAND ALL THE
CHALLENGES WHICH AGAIN IS. IS
MIND BOGGLINGLY COMPLICATED
SURE WHAT LET ME JUST ASK
DIRECTLY THEN I MEAN IS THE
ADMINISTRATION WILLING TO LOOK
AT. THE WAREHOUSE ORDINANCES-
THE IMPACTS FROM FEES BOARDS
THAT THE CHAIR IS MENTIONED.
ARE THEY WILLING TO LOOK AT-
YOU KNOW THINGS ON TRUCKING
THAT GABY FIVE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTING OR THE IT'S A
DEMONSTRATION WILLING TO LOOK
AT THOSE- THOSE LAWS
REGULATIONS AND ORDINANCES.
IT'S IN GIVE IT A FRESH LOOK. I
THINK WE'RE WILLING TO LOOK
BROADLY I THINK THERE'S SOME
THINGS THAT WE WON'T BE WILLING
TO- TO CHANGE BUT I THINK WE
ARE JUST IN GENERAL WILLING TO
LOOK BROADLY INCLUDING
DIALOGUE. WITH ALL OF YOU WHO
HAD. YOU KNOW A ROLE IN
IMPLEMENTING A LOT OF THE OF
THE OF THE REGULATIONS AND THE
BOARDS THAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT SO I THINK A- YOU KNOW AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION BUT- SO
THERE I THINK THERE WILL BE
SOME THINGS THAT WILL BE
WILLING TO TAKE A LOOK AT AND
OTHER. THINGS MAKE MAY BE LESS
SO. WHAT HOPE THAT YOU WILL. I
MEAN HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET THIS
FROM. AND INFORMATION FROM FROM
FROM THIS- FROM SAID THAT
COALITION OF FROM THE REALTOR
TO RETAILERS ON SUPPLY CHAIN.
OF THE CATHOLIC COLLECTION
RESPONSIBLE GOODS MOVEMENT
MAYBE THAT WILL SPUR SOME
CONVERSATION I DO THINK THAT WE
NEED TO. HAVE A HEART TO HEART.
ABOUT THAT WHAT. WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS DOING TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN IN OF ITSELF- NOT
ONLY CURENTLY BUT- FIRST-
RETROSPECTIVELY AND THEN OF
COURSE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DONE AS WELL-
AND I WILL ALSO MENTIONED AS-
MORE OF A STATEMENT THAN
ANYTHING ELSE BUT- I DO THINK
THAT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN- BUT
HAVING THE PORTS GOES WAY FOR
SEVEN IS. AN IMPORTANT. BUT IT
HAS TO ALIGN WITH THE
WAREHOUSES OF THE- THE
WAREHOUSES ARE NOT. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN OR IF THE HOURS ARE NOT
ALIGNED. A TRUCKER TO PICK
SOMETHING UP AT NINE PM BUT IF
THE- IF THE WAREHOUSE IS AN
OPEN AT NINE PM. THAT'S A
PROBLEM TOO RIGHT- OF THE
SECTOR JIM WE SPENT SOMETIME
TOGETHER TALK ABOUT THIS- YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT THE HEAT THERE
WAS A DECISIONS CAN BE MADE ON
INCREASING THE WEIGHT LIMITS-
TEMPORARILY WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AS WELL. DO YOU HAVE
A TIME LINE OF WHEN THAT
DECISION WILL TAKE PLACE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN I THINK WE SAW
EACH OTHER ON THE DAY YOU GOT
EGO WATER CAME OUT ON TOP
RIGHT. SO THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
CALLS ON CALTRANS TO IDENTIFY.
AND PRIORITIZE POTENTIAL FREE
ROUTES THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED
FOR HEIGHT WEIGHT LIMITS. I
THOUGHT THAT'S A THIRTY DAY
EXERCISE SO WE HAVE UNTIL I
BELIEVE IT'S NOVEMBER NTIETH
GIVE OR TAKE- CALTRANS IS IN
THE PROCESS OF DOING THAT- THEY
WILL REACH OUT TO INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS- TO GET SOME
INPUT. AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME CALTRANS WILL BE PREPARED.
TO ISSUE THOSE PERMITS FOR
ROUTES THAT ARE THAT ARE.
ULTIMATELY DESIGNATED FOR A
HIGHER WEIGHT LIMIT. I WOULD I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I GUESS MY
COMMENTS ARE THE SAME- TO U. S.
IT'S A- A DIRECTOR MYERS THAT.
THAT RAIL AND TRUCKING ARE VERY
IMPORTANT PARTS THE MAIN THEIR
KEY ESSENTIALS THAT- TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. I WOULD
HOPEFULLY- HOPEFULLY WILL
ENCOURAGE YOU- AND HOPEFULLY
WILL. TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
REEVALUATING THE IMPACTS OF
REGULATIONS AND ORDINANCES ON
THE- ON THE RAIL TRUCKING- SIDE
OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND BEGIN
TO LOOSEN- SOME OF THOSE
ANCHORS I THINK THAT ARE.
CREATING CHECKPOINTS AND IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN- I WILL ASK. ONE
LAST QUESTION WHICH IS. HE
MENTIONED THE LOAN ASPECT- TO-
TO THESE IMPROVEMENTS AT THE
PORTS- AND IT MEANT AND I
THINK- I THINK PRESENT. A WINE
MENTION THIS EARLIER THAT-
OTHER STATES ARE MAKING
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE NOT LOANS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GRANTS AN
INDIRECT INVESTMENT TO THE
PORTS TO IT TO INCREASE THEIR-
THEIR CAPACITY. IS THERE A
DISCUSSION WITHIN THE
MINISTRATION AND SOMEONE WHO IS
THE VICE OR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I WOULD OF COURSE BE
SUPPORTIVE OF MAKING
SIGNIFICANT STATE INVESTMENT-
INTO- THE PORTS INTO HARD OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN. IS THERE
DISCUSSION- WHAT ABOUT STATE
INVESTMENT. BUT THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES AND PER THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER- WE
ARE TASKED WITH- PULLING
TOGETHER BUDGET CONCEPTS THAT
COULD ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. AND
TO ADDRESS SUPPLY CHAIN
RESILIENCY AND TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS TO OVERALL SO- MORE
TO COME. SURE I KNOW YOU SAY
THAT I DO ECHO AND SHARE THE
CHAIRS CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
AGENCIES THAT AND PROPERTIES
THAT ARE IMPACTING- THE SUPPLY
CHAIN THAT. SOMEHOW OUR IMMUNE
FROM FROM OUR ACTIONS AS THE
LEGISLATURE EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
THE ELECTED BODY- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANKS VERY MUCH.
GREAT DAY THANK YOU MR FONG I
JUST BE CARE WITH THAT TOO
BECAUSE I THINK IS. A SURE THAT
THIS NEW DONE ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. FOR EXAMPLE I'VE GOT
BRIDGES VERY LARGE BRIDGES MY
DISTRICT. AND WE MIGHT NOT WANT
TRUCKS TRAVELING OVER THOSE
BRIDGES MOVING CREASE WEIGHTS
SO AGAIN THIS IS ON A BROAD
STROKE THAT I'M CALLING FOR AS
MUCH AS THERE ARE INSTANCES.
WHERE WHERE WHERE WE DECIDED I
SHOULD BECAUSE I CERTAINLY I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU GRACIA
THANK YOU AND AGAIN JUST WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE RIGHT BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO LAUGH CURRENTLY
THE RATE UNANIMOUS ORDER-
BECAUSE I'M NOT HANNAH. SADDAM.
BUT I- BUT- I JUST. DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE POWER OF
EXTRA. THIS LICENSES THAT'S
ACTUALLY. A BIG DEAL. AND
THAT'S- SEEM. YOU KNOW.
SOMEBODY WHATEVER IT. BUT THAT
IS A BIG BIG BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING. I'VE BEEN HERE FROM
THE TRUCKING. THEY GET PEOPLE
TRAINED. YEAH WAIT. SO MANY
WEEKS TO GET THE LIGHTS. OF
COMMERCIAL. IS A PERSONAL TO MY
RIGHT. SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- AND I KNOW WHAT
WE ALL THERE'S ALWAYS YOU KNOW-
TEMPTING TO TRY TO GET RID OF
ALL REGULATIONS AND LAWS DURING
TIMES OF CRISIS- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
NOT GONNA WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND DO
THE WORK THAT THE LOT OF US-
HAVE WORKED ON. AND WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT WE WOULD EXPECT
SOME ACCOMMODATIONS DURING
TIMES OF CRISIS BUT I ALSO HAVE
SOME. THOROUGHFARES I DON'T
KNOW THAT I WE WANT THEM TO BE
HEARING ABOUT THE POTHOLES IN
THE AND THE OVERPASSES
COLLAPSING WITH THE EXTRA
WEIGHT SO CASE BY CASE I THINK
IS VERY IMPORTANT. I THINK I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THE
POINT MAYBE TO MS MYERS I THINK
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT LOOKING UP.
AND GOING FORWARD
PROSPECTIVELY- THAT WE DON'T
JUST KIND OF KEEP RECREATING
WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE WORKING
TWENTY FOUR HOURS PUTTING MORE
WEIGHT ON TRACK. VERSES LOOKING
BIGGER AND AGAIN. GOING TO THIS
SOME OF THE SMALLER INLAND
PORTS THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE SOME
OF THE SMALLER CONTAINERS THERE
ARE WERE ALREADY MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION SO HOW DO WE- HOW DO
WE WORK TO EXPEDITE. SOME OF
THOSE THINGS BECAUSE THEN WE
CAN ALSO HELP TREMENDOUSLY WITH
EXPORT ESPECIALLY AS IT AS IT
RELATES TO WIND TO ADD PRODUCTS
TO TIMBERED A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE COMING DOWN. FROM THE
NORTH PART OF THE STATE- SO
JUST AGAIN IT ENCOURAGING US IS
AND YOU'RE GOING FORWARD AND
LOOKING AT THE TASK FORCE. TO
LOOK UP TO LOOK BIGGER AND TO
LOOK AT HOW ON DOING THINGS IN
WAYS WE HAVEN'T TRADITIONALLY
DONE THEM WILL BE A GOOD PATH
FOR RESILIENCY. GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
FOR THE FOR THOSE CON SENATOR I
MEAN I THINK IT FALLS UNDER THE
HEADLINE OF FOR THE CATEGORY OF
NEVER LET A GOOD CRISIS GO TO
WASTE AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
MUCH. HOW WE'RE THINKING HOW
AND I THINK IT OPPORTUNITY IN
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO INVEST
AND TO DO IT IN A HOLISTIC WAY
RIGHT A PROGRAM OF PROJECTS SO
THAT THEY REINFORCE EACH OTHER
AND SUPPORT EACH OTHER GOING
FORWARD TO BE CREATIVE. YOU
KNOW MORE VIBRANT AND RESILIENT
SO PROPS TO PLACATE ACROSS THE
STATE AND YOU KNOW WE KNOW BOTH
INLAND WATER PORTS AS AS WE
DISCUSSED BUT ALSO THE INLAND.
LAN PORTS WOULD WOULD WOULD BE
IT WOULD BE AN INNOVATION THAT
YOU KNOW WOULD BE A POTENTIAL
PROJECT WE COULD INVEST IN AND
WOULD CERTAINLY. HELP
FACILITATE MOVEMENT IN A MORE.
HOLISTIC MANNER THAT COULD
REALLY SUPPORT LONG. TERM
ECONOMIC GROWTH LOS STATE AND-
UNION DOING ITS- WIDE WE- IS.
PART OF THE- OF THE OF. HERE IS
WE COME OUT OF THIS HOW DO
INVEST IN. OUR SUPPLY CHAIN A
WAY TO PUT. OPPORTUNITIES NOT
JUST IN THE COASTAL AREAS. BUT
THOSE AS WELL AS THE INLAND
AREAS OF NORTH AREAS OF THE
STATE. SO IT IS A WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. INVESTING IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WE'RE ALSO
INVESTING IN OUR OUR HUMAN
OFFICIAL STRUCTURE AND EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE RIGHT. AS WE
LOOK AT SOME AREAS THAT HAVE
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDER-
INVESTED IN THIS IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY. SPREAD
SPREAD THAT AROUND THE STATE SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE VERY
CREATIVE THINGS THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE COMING OUT OF A
CRISIS BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT. I
SHOULDN'T WASTE ONE MEMBERSHIP
COME OUT BETTER THAN BEFORE AND
NOT JUST. REINVENTING THE SAME
HOLE THAT WE DUG OURSELVES INTO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ANYONE
DOWN THERE NO SINGLE HANDS UP.
OVER HERE MISTER GIBSON. YEAH
YOU KNOW AS A TEACHER YOU KNOW
I ALWAYS RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK SO. GIVEN THE
PROGRAM GUYS. DELIVER AT LEAST
TWELVE YEARS SO. MAYBE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
REALLY APPRECIATE IT BUT- THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS IT SEEMS
LIKE WE HAVE EAST COAST PORTS
WEST COAST PORTS IS THERE ANY
SIMILARITY I KNOW THAT- ON THE
EAST COAST TO CONSIDER
OPERATING COSTS AND THE
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE CALLED LIMB
MORE PORTS- ARE THERE ANY
SIMILARITIES. DIFFERENCES OR
LESSONS LEARNED THAT WE CAN
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF- BECAUSE
PEOPLE- WORD ON THE STREET IS
THEY FEEL LIKE THE CONGESTION
ISSUES WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE TAKEN SOME
OF THE ASPECTS FROM ON THE
OPERATING CORDS- INSURE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CALIFORNIA
INTERVENE- TO HELP- MOVE THINGS
ALONG WORKING TOGETHER WITH
OTHER PARTS I AM AND I'D HATE
TO LOSE IN THE MARKET SHARE.
RT'S COAST PORTS AND SO DO YOU
HAVE ANY- INSIGHT ON THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION WHAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY. EVERY STATE HAS
HAS ITS OWN UNIQUE GOVERNING
STRUCTURE SO FOR EXAMPLE. IN
VIRGINIA WHERE I USED TO LIVE.
IN OTHER STATES LIKE FLORIDA.
IT'S THE STATE THAT OWNS AND
OPERATES- THE REPORTS IN THEIR
IN THEIR IN THEIR STATE. THOSE
ARE STATE ENTITIES THAT IS NOT
THE CASE HERE ARE NOT
SUGGESTING WE GO THAT
DIRECTION. BUT IT JUST POINTS
IT HIGHLIGHTS THE DIFFERENCES
IN THE WAY PORTS ARE MANAGED.
OWNED AND OPERATED- AND SO
THAT'S JUST ONE INTERESTING
DATA POINT- AND GETTING BACK TO
A PREVIOUS CONVERSATION- INLAND
PORT. WE DON'T HAVE AN INLAND
PORT. WE NEED ONE. AND SO-
THERE IS A CALIFORNIA INLAND
PORT PROPOSAL BEING DEVELOPED
BY FRESNO COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS- WE HELP THEM GET A
ONE MILLION DOLLARS- GRANT FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION- TO HELP FURTHER
DEVELOP THAT FEASIBILITY STUDY-
THIS HOLD GREAT PROMISE AND- IN
FACT THERE PROPOSAL. WAS
SUPPORTED BY THE SAN PEDRO BAY
PORTS BECAUSE AN INLAND PORT.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WOULD DO.
WONDERS IN TERMS OF RELIEVING
CHOKEPOINTS. AND FACILITATING
THE MOVEMENT OF CARGO FROM THE
SENATE PETER BAY PORTS UP TO
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
BY TRUCK. OR RAIL AND SO WOULD
YOU MIND JUST CLARIFYING I
UNDERSTAND WHAT INLAND PORTS
MEANS BUT I THINK MAYBE PEOPLE
WATCHING. HAVE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT THING YOU'RE IN
FRESNO YOU DON'T HAVE A POINT.
CAN YOU JUST CLARIFY THAT
PLEASE AND ALSO SEE THERE ARE
SOME INLAND PORTS. YEAH CORRECT
YEAH THANK YOU SO. HILLARY
INLAND FOR DOING SO STILL IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE WE DON'T HAVE. IS
AN INLAND PORT THAT SERVES. AS
A DESTINATION FOR CARGO COMING
FROM THE PORTS OF ST OF LA LONG
BEACH AND OTHER PORTS- THROUGH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. BY TRUCK OR
RAIL- THAT CAN THEN BE SENT- TO
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. WE DON'T
HAVE THAT MANY STATES HAVE AN
INLAND PORT- NOT WATER FOR BUT
INLAND PORT- AND WE NEED ONE.
AND SO THERE ARE PROPOSALS ON
THE TABLE TO DO TO DO THAT. IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THERE ARE
ALSO PROPOSALS TO DO THAT IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. SO ADDING
ADDITIONAL TOOLS ADDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPLY CHAIN
MECHANISMS WILL HELP. BUILD THE
NETWORK AND HELP ADD RESILIENCE
TO THE ENTIRE NETWORK. AND WE
SEE- SO IT'S IN THE CUT
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW WITH
FRESNO- I'D LOVE FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER SOMETHING IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA JUST SAYING. THANK
YOU I MISS BONTA DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS YES THANK YOU
SECRETARY KIM FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY- AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO A BUILD ON
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IN JUST THE
RECOGNITION THAT WE CONTINUE TO
UNDER INVEST IN OUR PORTS
STRUCTURE- AND A HOPE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO. INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE WEEK THOUGH
IT WE NEED TO I ALSO WANT TO
JUST APPRECIATE MISS MYERS
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT THAT THAT
THAT EVERY STAKEHOLDER IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN IS GOING TO NEED
TO STEP UP AND I'M GOING TO. I
CONTINUE WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
BE AN INCREDIBLY BROKEN RECORD
ABOUT THIS BUT- WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THT IN THE PORT
THE PORT OF OAKLAND STANDS
EMPTY RIGHT NOW I AND IS AN
UNUSED ASSET- TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT SHOULD BE SO REALLY
APPRECIATE. ADS WERE THINKING
ABOUT REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO
THIS THAT WE ALREADY USE THAT
THE ASSETS THAT E HAVE IN
BEING ABLE TO MOVE IT TO
IMPROVE THE SUPPLY CHAIN IN
THAT- AND ALSO JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE ARE. STRUGGLING IN THIS
MOMENT RIGHT NOW S BECAUSE OF
THE DEREGULATION OF THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY THAT HAS
HAPPENED- AND THE MISCLASSIFIED
MISS CLASSIFICATION OF OUR
TRUCKERS AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS IN CAUSING ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY. WE DON'T HAVE
THAT KIND OF WORKFORCE THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
THIS CRITICAL MOMENT. THANK YOU
RESPOND I JUST KNOW AB FIVE
SOME. LO BEFORE. THIS BEGAN. I
WITH THAT- FIRST SENATOR DAHLE.
THE USE CHAIR NOT SO. I THINK
IF THERE I HAVE A QUESTION A
QUESTION WOULD BE- IF THERE WAS
ONE THING THAT YOU IT WOULD
MAKE THE SUPPLY CHAIN. SPEED UP
IN AND OPERATE MORE WHAT WHAT
DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA WHAT THAT
ONE THING WOULD BE. I THINK
MOST OF THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM AGREED THAT
IT'S GETTING. CONTAINERS OFF
THE PORT SCRIPT FINDING EXCESS
SPACE EITHER IN THE PORT
COMPLEXES ARE OUTSIDE THE COURT
COMPLEXES. WHERE YOU COULD
TEMPORARILY STORE FOR
TRANSPLANTS FOR CONTAINERS SO
THAT SHE COULD. CREATE MORE
VELOCITY IN THE SYSTEM AT THE
PORTS. I THINK THAT THAT THAT
MEASURE MAJORITY STAKEHOLDER
POINT IN THAT DIRECTION. SO
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD A LOT THANK
YOU. WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THAT FACT THAT. YOU KNOW SOME
REGULATION AND SO I HAPPEN TO
BE IN THE TRUCKING BUSINESS
MYSELF. AND TO THEIR WORST A
TRUCKING SHORTAGE OF THE PEOPLE
I SAY I THINK OUR BIGGEST
INVESTMENT NEED TO BE IN PEOPLE
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW WE GET
THOSE PEOPLE. INTO THE JOBS
THAT ARE WIDELY AVAILABLE AND
SO FOR THOSE OF US IN THE
TRUCKING BUSINESS THIS BEFORE-
COBIT IN. AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CHANGES IN THE TRUCKING.
WORLD AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS IS A LACK OF TALENT TO
BE ABLE TO PUT PEOPLE IN AND
ACTUALLY OPERATE THESE. TRUCKS
ALONG WITHOUT A LOT OF
REGULATIONS CHANGED- AND WE'VE
HEARD AB FIVE IT WAS HUGE. IT
IMPACTED A LOT OF THE TRUCKING
BUSINESS. I DON'T SEE THAT
CHANGING I DON'T THINK THAT
THE- ADMINISTRATION OR- THEY'RE
GONNA BE ROLLING THAT BACK ANY
TIME SOON BUT THOSE WERE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE- BASICALLY.
THAT CHANGE THE WAY THE RULES
WERE OR ARE. BEING IMPLEMENTED
SO- SO THAT THAT BEEN AROUND
FOR SOE SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT- IMPLEMENTING YOU KNOW
CDL LICENSES EASIER QUICKER I
MEAN THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS
THAT WE HAVE THE LAWS THAT WE
HAPPEN YOU'RE GONNA ADD WEIGHT
TO A TRUCK. AND THEN YOU'RE
GONNA PUT IT IN OFFICE SOMEBODY
WHO'S NOT EXPERIENCED AS MUCH
AS SOME IN A TRUCK THIS NOW GOT
EVEN MORE WEIGHT ON IT I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S- A RECIPE FOR- IN
SOME DANGER ON THE ROADS. AND
ALSO TO THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SET UP
FOR. TYPICALLY AN EIGHTY
THOUSAND POUND. GVW UNLESS YOU
SPREAD IT OUT OVER LONGER
LINKED OF AXLES SO- I'M I'M IN
FAVOR OF THAT ANYTHING NEEDS TO
BE SOME OBVIOUSLY SOME THOUGHT
PUT INTO THAT PROCESS BUT THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE I THINK WE
FACE. AS THE LACK OF TALENT AND
OF AVAILABILITY AND QUITE
FRANKLY THAT'S DUE TO. I THINK
SOME OF THE LAWS AND THE
PETITIONS THAT WE'VE DONE HERE
AND WITH ALSO THE WITH THE
EXTENSION OF. UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
EVER I MEAN WE'RE LIKE I CANNOT
TELL YOU IN EVERY BUSINESS I GO
BY IS LOOKING FOR PEOPLE AND
WE'RE STILL CONTINUING TO LET
PEOPLE. DRAW UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS AND NOT HAVE TO GO
BACK TO WORK WHEN THERE'S JOBS
AVAILABLE. SO IS THERE ANY BEEN
ANY THOUGHT PUT INTO THE FACT
THAT WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE BACK
IN THE WORK FORCE- SINCE THE
PANDEMIC THERE'S BEEN BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS SPENT. ON ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO JUST STAY HOME. YEAH
WELL I MEAN WE HAD IS A LONGER
CONVERSATION I'D BE HAPPY TO
HAVE IT WITH YOU OFFLINE BUT I
THINK WE HAVE LOOKED
EXTENSIVELY AT THE CAUSES OF-
SOMETIMES IMBALANCE IS
IMBALANCES IN THE JOB MARKET
AND WHY WE CONTINUE HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT- I THINK THAT MOST
ECONOMISTS AGREE AND IF YOU
LOOK AROUND THE COUNTRY AT AT
AT AT AT STATE WITH A ROLL BACK
ON EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. UP
EARLIER THAN THAN WE DID THAT
THERE'S THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE CAUSE AND EFFECT- I THINK
THE REASONS PEOPLE BUT YOU KNOW
THAT UNEMPLOYMENT WE WE'VE HAD
KIND OF A OF A LITTLE BIT OF A
ON EVEN RETURN TO- JOB GROWTH
ALTHOUGH JOBS ARE GROWING
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
THE NATION IN JOB GROWTH RIGHT
IT IT'S WITH YOU KNOW SINCE
JANUARY IT'S BEEN MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS A MONTH-
BUT I THINK WE- WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THAT AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND IT WHILE INVESTING
IN JOB TRAINING AND OTHER
THINGS. TO TRY TO HELP PEOPLE
MAKE THAT TRANSITION BACK INTO
THE WORKFORCE AND TO GROW JOBS
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FIT
THAT WERE YOU KNOW MANAGING
ECONOMY WAY THAT ALLOWS JOBS TO
GROW ITSELF YEAH WE AGAIN THAT
RESULTS A LITTLE UNEVEN BUT THE
TRAJECTORIES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT I'M HEADED TO
DISCUSS AT LENGTH WITH YOU. AT
ANY TIME MY PLEASURE THAT THE
ONE THE ONE THING I THINK THAT
IS YOU WILL TALK ABOUT. AYE MY
FRUSTRATION WITH GOVERNMENT AS
WE JUST THROW MONEY AT IT THINK
IT'S GOING TO FIX IT THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS FIX THE PROBLEM-
OBVIOUSLY HELPS AND THE THINGS
THAT THAT ARE PROPOSED OR LONG
TERM RIGHT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A CRISIS RIGHT NOW. AND SEND
AND THE SHORT TERM I THINK HIS
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED MORE SPACE
RIGHT FOR THE- CONTAINERS AND
NUMBER TWO WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE THOSE CONTAINERS. THE
REAL SHORTAGES THIRTY THOUSAND
TRUCK DRIVERS AND IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE AND I THINK IT'S LIKE A
MILLIONS NATIONWIDE THAT WERE
SHORT AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO
GET FIXED EITHER OVERTIME OVER
A QUICK TIME RIGHT EVEN THOUGH
THE RATES ARE GOING UP THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR PAYING. TOP
DOLLAR FOR QUALIFIED DRIVERS
RIGHT AND I DID IT IS THAT IS
THAT IS ONE OF THE FOR SURE ONE
OF THE TRUMP POINTS IN THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS
FOR HOW TO VESTED OVER THE
LONGER TERM- IN THE MEANTIME
WHICH HAVE TRY TO GET THINGS
MOVING AGAIN AND HOPE THAT THAT
WORKFORCE AND. AND THEN MY LAST
POINT WOULD BE THIS IS JUST TO
STAY A MAN IS THAT. IN THE
REGULATORY. IS REAP THREE POWER
THOSE A QUICK. UPGRADING YOUR-
TO MEET THIS STANDARDS OF THE
PORTS- IS NOT JUST FOR SMALL
BUSINESS FOR LARGE BUSINESSES A
HUGE IMPACT AND SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES. ARE I MEAN WHEN
YOU I LOOKED AT THE- EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TALK ABOUT A THOUSAND
DRIVES TEXT BUT YOU CAN'T EVEN
BUY THOSE TODAY. THEY'RE NOT
EVEN AVAILABLE. IF YOU HAD HIM
SITTING THERE. THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT. YOU CAN GO TO THE
LOT AND PICK THOSE UP. SO THOSE
ARE THESE ARE LONG TERM RIGHT-
SOLUTIONS TO WE NEED A SHORT
TERM FIX FOR RIGHT NOW AND THAT
I AGREE WITH MOST OF WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD IS THAT. OBVIOUSLY
THE OTHER PORTS NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO- BEING ABLE TO NOT.
IT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT. CHANGE ALL THE
RULES BUT FOR THE SHORT TERM WE
NEED SOME RELIEF SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AND THEN DO. THE LONG TERM
EFFECTS THANK YOU. THANK IT IS
ONE HIGHLIGHT THE RESPONSE YOUR
FIRST QUESTION. WHICH IS THE
ONE THING WE CAN DO. AND THE
RESPONSE WAS GET THE EMPTIES
PAPA DOC- AND HOW THAT'S DONE
IT'S DONE A VARIETY WAS ONE OF
THEM ONE OF MAIN WAYS IS THE
SENT OVER SWEEPER SHIPS. RIGHT
RIGHT SO THEY TAKE HIM BACK. TO
THE IMPORTER RIGHT TO GO BACK
WE NEED TO GET THOSE OFF THE
DOCK THAT'S WHAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE.
BECAUSE WITH HIS SITTING THERE
TOO LONG- THAT THEY WANT TO
ATTACH THAT FEE SO THERE'S AN
INCENTIVE. FOR THOSE FOLKS TO
GET THOSE EMPLOYEES OFF THE
DOCK. WITH SO MEMBER GIPSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M I'M
GONNA TRY TO EXPEDITIOUS THAT
ALWAYS TO HAVE MORE- PANELIST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MYERS
AND ALSO SECRETARY CAMP- JUST
TO PIGGYBACK WITH SENATORS SAY
YOU MUST BE LOOKING AT MY
NOTES- WITH RESPECT TO- THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY A SHORTAGE THERE
WE ARE IN NEED MAKE WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO TRUCK DRIVERS
BECAUSE AS I LOOK FROM MY
LIENS- VISITING THE PORT
SEVERAL TIMES WHEN THE
PRESIDENT- DID EXECUTIVE ORDERS
WE HAVE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THOUSAND CONTAINERS- ON THE
DOCK- AND NOT ENOUGH TRUCK
DRIVERS TO MOVE THAT STUFF AND
THEN WE HAVE. FIFTY TO SEVENTY
TRUCK- SHIPS OUT AT SEA WAITING
TO GET IN AND SO IT'S AGAIN
IT'S THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS I THINK THAT
WE CAN FIX- BUT THIS LEADS TO
MY QUESTION AND MY QUESTION IS
WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE THAT
SCRATCH OUT THE WERE POSSIBLE
WE NEEDED TO HAPPEN WE
IDENTIFIED. A FREAK OR GOODS
MOVE MOVEMENT A KEY PERSON IN
THE HORSESHOE THAT CAN
COORDINATE THE AGENCIES GO
BEARS- CAL S. T. A. AND ALSO
CARBON OTHERS BECAUSE GOING
BACK TO SHERMAN- O'DONNELL- HAS
INDICATED WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
POLICYMAKERS WE ARE LEGISLATIVE
BODY THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
AUTHORITY AS WELL AS CARBON
OTHERS AND THERE'S NO
COORDINATION AND THEN WE WILL
THERE'S NO COORDINATION THERE'S
CHAOS AND WE HAVE CHAOS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE NO ONE IS TAKING
ALL OF THOSE AGENCIES CAN
COORDINATING THEM AND MAKING
SURE THERE IS A ABSOLUTE OF
DELIBERATE- MATTER FACT PLAN TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES AT
HAND RIGHT. WE ALSO TALKED
ABOUT LAND USE AND I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE OF THE DOZEN OR SO-
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE WE CAN GO
AND STACKS- BECAUSE I'M AFRAID
BECAUSE I RIPPED AT THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITY WHICH IS
WILMINGTON- CERTAINLY HOPE YOU
HEARD SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE- THE YOU KNOW. THE-
THE THIS TAX SO HIGH. AND IS
DANGEROUS AND I'M A- AN OBSCENE
A NUMBER. WITH RESPECT TO-
THERE WAS ON OF EACH BUT THERE-
I KNOW HORROR. WE ARE YOU DO IS
HAVE A WIND BLOWING IT'S GOING
TO TEETER TOTTER FALL OFF AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M AFRAID OF THAT.
YOU KNOW SAFETY IS NEEDS TO BE
AN ISSUE- AND SO THAT'S A
COMMENT BUT ALSO WHAT CAN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DO- TO HELP
ESTABLISH MORE DOMESTIC- MATTER
FACTORING OF CHASTITY'S. I'M
HERE- THAT WE CAN REALLY-
ENVISIONED AS A SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM SO THAT'S ONE
QUESTION. DO YOU DO I DON'T
HAVE A GOOD ANSWER ON THE
CHASSIS QUESTION. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IT DOES HAVE A
THROUGHOUT THE DISPLACING
TARGET TAKE A SHOT AT IT BUT I
ALSO THE DIRECTORS OF THE PORT.
I CAN SPEAK UP AND I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT ON STARTING OFF
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GOING. THE FEDERAL TOOL IS
CALLED THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT. CAN BE INVOKED IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY OR CRISIS AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID DURING
COVERT THE EARLY DAYS OF CULVER
TO. WRAP OF DOMESTIC SUPPLIES
OF PPP. TESTING AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS. THEORETICALLY IT
COULD BE INVOLVED HERE AS WELL
FOR TO- IN COURAGE GREATER
DOMESTIC PRODUCTIONOF
CHELSEA'S CONTAINERS- THAT IS
SOMETHING- WE HAVE RAISED I
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. AND SEE
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY FINAL LAST
QUESTION IS LOOKING TOWARDS THE
FUTURE AS WE DEVELOP A PLAN TO
ADDRESS WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US
RIGHT NOW- I'M REMINDED OF A
FOUR SIX SEVEN WIENER WHICH
WOULD HAVE HAD TO- INITIALLY
EXTRAPOLATES- ALL LOCAL OIL
PRODUCTION THE CALIFORNIA- TO
BASICALLY BE DEPENDED BY YOU
KNOW A 100% RIGHT- AND AS YOU
LOOK AT. HOW THAT IS DONE UNDER
THAT PARTICULAR BILL AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR HUNDREDS BECAUSE
WE'RE NO LONGER BE PRODUCING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA EXPRESSLY
WITH EXECUTIVE ORDER WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE THAT ABILITY TO
HAVE THAT THAT CREW HERE WHICH
MEANS TO ME. IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT IN FROM SHIPS
AND IF YOU BRING IT IN FROM
SIPS IN OUR PORT THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD BE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED COMING IN AT ONE GIVEN
TIME SO WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT HOW DOES THAT IMPACT OUR
PORTS. AND INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT
THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN OUR
PORTS- WITH THE POLICIES WE ARE
NOW- MOVING FORWARD IN THE
STATE DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
YEAH I THINK WE DID THAT BUT
THAT WOULD POTENTIAL CREATE
MORE DEMAND ON THE PORTS AND-
PERHAPS IT'S SOMETHING THAT
DIRECTORS CORDERO AND- AND THE
STRUGGLE CAN CAN SPEAK TO MORE.
OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT GOING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF YOU BEING
HERE TO CENTURY BEING HERE WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT AS A LONG
TERM PLAN ON HOW TO ADDRESS
THAT. IF IN FACT WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE DOWN THAT ROAD. YEAH THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WITH IS A
HIGHLIGHT YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT WITH
REGARD TO THE CHASSIS. THAT'S A
BIG DEAL. BECAUSE AS YOU BEAT
HIM AT LEAST A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE SHOULD BE MADE.
DOMESTICALLY WE HAVE RELATIVELY
MINIMAL. CAPACITY THE UNITED
STATES TO MAKE THOSE MOST OF
THOSE ARE MADE CHINA SOME OF
MEXICO. I GUESS  FEW IN
PENNSYLVANIA THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD ACT ON THAT-
MR FONG. I'M FIVE ONE LAST
QUESTION AND I THINK WAS
SPURRED BY- MY CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT
COORDINATION. WHO IS THE PERSON
RIGHT NOW IN CHARGE OF
DIRECTING- THOSE DECISIONS AND
IS THE- ADMINISTRATION WILL.
WILLING TO LOOK AT A SUPPLY.
CHAIN PERSON- THAT COULD
ADVOCATE. FROM THE BUT THE
PUBLIC'S- PUBLIC SIDE TO HELP
COORDINATE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SIDE WHEN WE- ARE IN. A IN A
CRISIS LIKE THIS AND- HELP MAKE
DECISIONS AS WELL AS STOP BAD
IDEAS AND BAD. LEGISLATION
FROM. FROM BEING PUT IN PLACE
UNDER IN IN AND IT THE BIG AT
THE BEGINNING CAN WE AVOID A
LOT OF THESE PROBLEMS I MEAN.
IS THERE A PERSON THAT THAT
SHOULD BE PUT IN CHARGE. WHO IS
THAT PERSON RIGHT NOW. AND IF
NOT WHO WOULD THAT PERSON BE.
RIGHT SO WHEN THE GOVERNOR
SHOULD THE EXECUTIVE ORDER HE
ALSO ASKED US TO STAND UP AN
INTERAGENCY TASK FORCE WHICH
WE'VE DONE- INCLUDES- CAL STEP
GO BIZ- I'M GONNA FORGET. ABOUT
THE LIST IN FRONT OF ME BUT ALL
THE REPRESENTATIVE AGENCIES
INCLUDING CARP- IT'S CO CHAIRED
BY ON A MONTH TO SANTOS AND
MYSELF- BUT BUT IT HAS MY
PROTESTS A PATIENT OF THE- OF
THE SECRETARY LEVEL-
REPRESENTATION. EACH OF THE
AGENCIES INCLUDING AG- AND SO
THAT IS RIGHT NOW THE BODY
THAT'S COORDINATING ACTIVITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME
INSIGHT INTO WHAT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS THE MINISTRATION EFFECT
AND WHAT. DIFFERENT
PUBLICATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ARE. I MEAN I THINK WE'RE
ALWAYS OPEN TO A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THAT WORK
BETTER. AND WHAT IS THE RIGHT
LONG TERM STRUCTURE- I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE A FINAL LONG TERM
DECISION ON THAT THIS POINT BUT
CERTAINLY- WORKING TOGETHER AT
THIS POINT WITH THIS
INTERAGENCY. GROUP TO ADDRESS
THESE PROBLEMS IN THE WAYS THE
STATE CAN- AND LOOKING TO WORK
WITH OUR FEDERAL AND OBVIOUSLY
RETAIL AND- TRUCKING AND-
IMPORT PARTNERS- EVERY STEP
ALONG THE WAY. AND I THINK THAT
WAS THE FIRST QUESTION OUT OF
THE GATE FROM. FROM PRISON ON
IS. IS ONE IS THAT WHAT IS THAT
PART BUT HOW DO. WE IMPROVE
COORDINATION THANK YOU MISTER.
OKAY THANK YOU. I'M JUST
LOOKING TO. YOUR CHAIRS SO LIKE
A ONE I'LL THANK YOU THAT THE
INCREDIBLE AND I JUST. GIVE YOU-
THANK YOU AS WELL AND GRATITUDE
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A-
HUGE FEAT- I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON COLLABORATING VERY
WELL WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND I JUST WANT TO
FIRST THANK YOU FOR. FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK A COLLABORATIVE LEE
AN INDIGENT INDIVIDUALLY. MY
QUESTION REALLY QUICKLY IS JUST
ON DIGITISATION HOW DO WE
CREATE THE SMART PORT THAT
EVERYONE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT.
AND HOW THE STATE CAN NOT JUST
INFUSE DOLLARS BUT ALSO LOOK AT
SOME. OF OUR OWN INGENUITY- TO
BE ABLE TO APPLY TO THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT FACTOR THAT WE NEED
TO GET DONE LIKE YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU. YEAH IT'S A QUESTION
I MEAN I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT SOME OF
THE REALLY EFFICIENT PORTS- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THEY SHARE
OUR- DIGITAL PLATFORMS RIGHT
THEIR DIGITIZED IN A WAY THAT.
THAT PRODUCES EFFICIENCY AND SO
WE WERE DEFINITELY INTERESTED
IN IN LOOKING AT THAT AND
WORKING WITH OUR- WITH OUR
PARTNERS ACROSS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO DO THAT IN ITS
PURPOSE. IS ONE OF THE-
CERTAINLY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
INVESTMENT BOTH THROUGH THE-
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP BUT ALSO TO
THE STATE AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
REEMPHASIZED. THE GOVERNOR WE
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED TO
COME UP WITH SOME. PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS BY
THE JANUARY TENTH BUDGET AND SO
IT'S ON EVERYBODY'S MINDS-
DAVID YOU MIGHT HAVE. SOMETHING
TO ADD. I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- AND I THINK YOUR NEXT
PANELISTS- GENE'S ROLE. IN
MARIN CORNER WILL BE VERY WELL
POSITIONED TO. ADDRESS THE
ISSUE FROM THE STANDPOINT OF.
EVERYDAY FOR OPERATIONS IN THE
DEGREE TO WHICH- TECHNOLOGY IS
BEING OPTIMIZED TO- TO REALLY
IMPROVE OPERATIONS. AND NOT
JUST LA LONG BEACH PORTS BUT
ALL THE OTHER PARTS WELL ONE
EVENING. STOCKTON WEST
SACRAMENTO YOU NAME IT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION TO YOUR
RESPONSES TO THE MANY QUESTIONS
AND- I'M THE FORTY MANY MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS TOPIC
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO SOLVE
IT. THANK YOU. SO MUCH THANK
YOU. WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO PANEL FOR- HOOPS PANEL THREE
ACTUALLY. MY PHONE. OUR PANEL
THREE- AND THE PORT'S ROLE IN
EASING CONGESTION THESE ARE
REALLY THE DOERS THESE OF TWO
DIRECTORS REPORT MARIO CORNER
AND GENE SOROKA- THESE GUYS
KNOW IT ALL- SO IF YOU HAD YOU
KNOW DIDN'T GET AN ANSWER TO A
QUESTION YOU PREVIOUSLY ASKED
SOME OF THEM HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THESE TWO GENTLEMAN ARE SURE TO
HAVE IT. THE WE DISCUSSING
REPORTS ROLE IN EASING
CONGESTION EACH PANELIST WILL
HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR WAITING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR PROBABLY YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
TALK ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF
AGO OVER THERE BEEN SO MANY
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN HELD
BACK SO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH MARIO CORDERO WAS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PORT
OF LONG BEACH MR CORDERO OFF
FROM WHAT ACTS THOSE ON. OKAY
OKAY YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ- SURE
SOME REMEMBER DONALD AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
BROTHER THE SUPPLY CHAIN
COMMUNITY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH AN UPDATE TO
SHARE OUR PROPOSED SOLUTIONS TO
RELIEVING CONGESTION AND
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS OF THIS
NATIONAL SUPPLY CHAIN. BEFORE
BEGINNING MY COMMENTS I WOULD
BE REMISS IN NOT THINKING
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. THANK YOU
GOVERNOR FOR EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND MANY TWENTY ONE TO HELP
TACKLE THIS TRIPLE A SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES. THE PARLIAMENT OF
THE SECOND LARGEST CONTAINER
PORT UNITED STATES TOGETHER
WITH THE PRO LOS ANGELES THE
SAN PEDRO BAY COMPLEX COUNCIL
40% OF THE KIDS MOVED IN THIS
COUNTRY. REPORT HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF SEEKING A
FRAMEWORK FOR EXTENDING HOURS
OF OPERATION IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. WHAT THE GOAL OF TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN. A FRAMEWORK I FIRST
REFERENCE BACK IN JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN GIVEN THE
CARPOOL FORECAST THAT WE- IN
THIS INDUSTRY. YESTERDAY BY IN
A DAY WE HAVE SEVENTY SEVEN
CONTAINER SHIPS OFF THE COAST
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THEY'RE
WAITING TO GET INTO EITHER THE
BIRTH OF BIRTH YOUR TO LONG
BEACH WELL OUR NEIGHBOR IN LOS
ANGELES. THE RECORD WAS REACH A
WEEK AGO WITH AITOR CONTAINER
CONTAINER SHIPS AT ANCHOR. OR
IN THE DIRECTOR RETURNS SO YOU
MASS IN NORMAL TIMES WHAT THE
NUMBER IT'S- IN NORMAL TIMES
THERE'S ZERO SHIPS AND- KEEP IN
MIND THANKS FOR SUPPLY CHAIN
WORKFORCE THE PRO LONG BEACH
HAS NOT SHUT DOWN. OR SINGLE
DATA INDEPENDENT. ARE I'LL W.
PARTNERS HAVE KEPT THE CARGO
MOVING. AS THE MARINE TERMINAL
OPERATORS AND TRUCK DRIVERS
REAL WORKERS SHIP CREWS TUGBOAT
CREWS AND THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN WORKFORCE NEEDLESS TO
SAY. THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL
OPERATION THAT HAS BEEN A
BALANCE AT ALL LEVELS. ANDERSON
CHAIN WORKERS SHOULD BE
COMMENDED AS A HELP THIS
MORNING. MORE CARGO IS MOVING
TO THE SPORTS. EVER BEFORE ONE
NINETEEN A POOR LONG BEACH
MOVED SEVEN POINT SIX THREE
MILLION TWO YEARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY REMOVED EIGHT POINT ONE
MILLION OUR BUSINESS YEAR EVER
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE'RE
EXPECTED TO SET ANOTHER RECORD
AND MOVE CLOSE TO NINE MILLION.
OR MAYBE A LITTLE MORE. PETER
BIG. IS FORECASTED TO MOVE
TWENTY MILLION TO YOUR
CONTAINERS IN THE COMING YEARS
THAT'S REQUIRED IN MY VIEW. IT
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE IN THE
REGIONAL SUPPLY CHAIN. AS YOU
HEARD FROM CAPITOL SPOKESPERSON
DADDY ONE MY GOOD COLLEAGUE ON
VOCAL. THERE ARE MANY REASONS
FOR THIS BATTLE. MY FOCUS TODAY
WILL BE TO SHARE WITH YOU WHAT
THE PORT IS DOING TO RESOLVE IT
AND DISCUSS WAYS THE STATE
COULD ALMOST RESOLVED THIS CAR
A CRISIS OR FIND SOME SOLUTIONS.
TERMINAL'S FREIGHT ARE RUNNING
OUT OF SPACE WE NEED TO MAKE
ROOM ON OUR TERMS WERE
PARTIALLY FIVE HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND CONTAINER UNITS
SITTING IN THOSE WAITING SHIPS.
WE NEED CARGO VELOCITY. SO WE
CAN STOP TALKING ABOUT CARNIVAL
VOLATILITY. LAST WEEK THE POOR
LONG BEACH LOS ANGELES THAT WE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING A
SURCHARGE FOR CONTAINERS LEFT
TOO LONG ON THE TERMS. IN THE
CASE OF CONTAINERS SCHEDULED TO
MOVE BY TRUCK. OCEAN CARRIERS
WILL BE CHARGED FOR EVERY
CONTAINER TOOLING NINE DAYS OR
MORE. CONTAINERS MOVING BY RAIL
OCEAN KITCHEN- CARRIERS WILL BE
CHARGED IF THE CONTAINER HAS
DEVELOPED FOR MORE THAN SIX
DAYS OR MORE. BEGINNING
NOVEMBER. THE POOREST WOULD
CHARGE WATER COMPANY WITH THE
CARGO IN KIND. HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER CONTAINER INCREASING IN A
HUNDRED DOLLAR INCREMENTS PER
CONTAINER PER DAY. ELECTION OF
THE CITY WELCOME ADDITIONAL
SOONER THAN NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WHAT THE
BACKING OF THE BUDGET
MINISTRATION WE ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH OUR REGIONAL
OPERATORS TO EXPAND HOURS OF
OPERATION. I NEED TO KNOW THIS
IS WHAT THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING
DEBATE EVEN PRIOR TO THIS
CRISIS. WHAT BIDEN AT THE WHITE
HOUSE I NEVER DID HE TO HELLO
IT DOESN'T PORTRAY FOUR SEVEN
SUPPLY CHAIN. I WAS VERY
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR HIS SUPPORT
WITH THIS BOLD JOHNSON. THE YOU
ARE TERRIBLE AT THE PROLONGED
BEACH IN SEPTEMBER AGREED TO A
PILOT PROJECT TO EXPLORE A
FRAMEWORK WHERE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN OPERATION. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH OTHER SUPPLY CHAIN
PARTNERS TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
USED TO USED AS NEW OURS AT TTI
TERMINAL. WE CALL THE LEAD SHIP
OR WILL WE CALL THIS NATURE THE
WHO CHEN. BUT FOR ABOUT THREE
AND THE SEVEN A TEACHER.
TRUCKERS IN CAR OWNERS NO THEY
CAN BEAT THE TRAFFIC. USING
THESE EARLY HOURS WHAT ARE
SLOWLY WARMING TO BE EXPANDED
ARMS. BARBARA THERE'S PLENTY
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE DELIVERIES
DURING THE SHIP. THERE ARE
CHALLENGES BUT I DO BELIEVE WE
DO EXPECT SOME PROGRESS. WHITE
HOUSE EMPLOYEE JOB CARTY HAS
BEEN VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN
BRINGING LARGE RETAIL COMPANIES
TO THE TABLE TO MOVE CONTAINERS
DURING THESE EXTENDED HOURS.
OTHER TERMINALS ARE FLASHING
GATES THIS MEANS THEY'RE
OPENING EARLIER AND STAYING
OPEN LATER. SUMMER READING
FRIDAY NIGHT AND WE CAN GETS.
MEANWHILE AT THE POOR LONG
BEACH ARE SHORT TERM OR FOR
RESEARCH PROJECT KNOWN S.
STORE. HAS BEEN A GREAT SUCCESS
FIRST IMPLEMENTED BACK IN
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR. NOW THE
SIXTY FOUR SUCH CITY FOR A
GROUP OF SELLING AT THE PORT IS
WORKING TO PROVIDE CONTAINER
TRANSPORT AND TEMPORARY STORAGE
DURING THIS CARD WILL SEARCH.
TODAY IT HAS. FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CONTAINERS AT THE SITE. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE OUR
PARTNERSHIP A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS WITH OPENS A NEW
LEADERSHIP OF DD BUYERS.
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH POOR
GERMANS TRUCKING COMPANIES TO
IDENTIFY PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
LAND BUT ALSO CAN BE USED FOR
TEMPORARY STORAGE DURING THE
SEARCH. OUR TERMINALS ARE
WRAPPING UP ON DR OPERATIONS A
PRIORITY COMPONENT. TO THROUGH
THE CAR WILL ALSO BE AND
DIMINISH TRANSACTION IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION I WHICH- REGROUP
FROM ABOUT 20% EARLIER THIS
YEAR. TO ABOUT 27% IN THE
SUMMER WITH REGARD TO OUR ON
DOCK OPERATIONS. ALONG THOSE
LINES THE PORT OF LONG BEACH.
THAT'S PARTNERED WITH THE UTAH
INLAND PORT AUTHORITY IN THE
TEMP TO INCREASE RAIL HAUL
CARGO THIS WILL BE DONE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF COST
EFFECTIVE AND INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES AIMED AT MOVING
GOODS QUICKLY SAFELY AND
EFFICIENTLY BETWEEN LONG BEACH
AND YOU TALK. WE ARE STILL
GETTING COLD ISOLATION FOR
INTERNATIONAL BURNERS SOME
SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
SAILORS HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
BY THE LONG BEACH HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ON BOARD MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED SHIPS BERTHED AT
BOTH PORTS. NOW BACK TO TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN. I BELIEVE THAT WHEN
WE HAVE THOSE FRAMEWORK IT WILL
MITIGATE THE CURRENT SURGE
YEAH. CHALLENGING BUT PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE. IT WAS ALSO
SERVED AS A PRIMER TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN THE FUTURE. AS I
HAVE INDICATED I BELIEVE THE
SUPPLY CHAIN NEEDS A
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE GIVEN
THE VOLUMES THAT WE HAVE AND
THE BOTTOM IS EXPECTED TO
COMPLETION HERE TO CALL.
REJECTION CHAU CARL WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE IN THE
COMING YEARS. INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AS WE ALL KNOW IS A MAJOR
FACTOR AS TO WHY CALIFORNIA IS
THE FIFTH. LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. FOR SOME CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED OVERNIGHT OVER THE
FLIP OF A SWITCH. IT TAKES A
SERIES OF SWITCHES HOWEVER WE
HAVE STARTED OUT AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR OTHER LEASES SUPPLY
CHAIN SUPPLY CHAIN TO JOIN. THE-PARLIAMENT HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
CAME ONLINE IN THE PAST YEAR
AND A HALF THE REPLACEMENT OF
JOE DOESN'T BRIDGING TWENTY
TWENTY IN THE- COMPLETION THE
THIRD BASE BEEN OCCUPIED
LUGGAGE CONTAINER TERMINAL IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WHICH
OMIT WHICH IMMEDIATELY ADDED.
ONE MILLION TO YOUR COMPETITORS
AT THE SPORT. PUSHES ME UP A
BIT TERM. WHAT ARE THESE
INVESTMENTS I ASSURE YOU WE
WOULD HAVE YOU WOULD HAVE HAD
MORE PRODUCTS. I WANT TO THANK
SURGERY Q. AND A STOP WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE US DEPARTMENT
CHARGER SECOND SECRETARY CHECK
FOR PRIORITIZING FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS AND
ADDRESS OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES. MOST NOTABLY TO PROLONG
WHICH- PLANS ON INVESTING ONE
BILLION DOLLARS ON ON DECK
BONDOC REAL PROJECTS. WE WILL
HOPE THAT THIS WILL INCREASE
NOW ON DECK OF UNCIA HONDA
ACCORD WILL BID. TO ABOUT 35%
JURBY OUR NEXT RENDON DEVER FOR
INCREASED UNDER LOCK RAILROAD.
REALLY AREN'T FIVE HUNDRED
SEVEN USE AND IT WOULD. THE
PROJECT WAS IN FASTER MOVEMENT.
AND WILL ELIMINATE
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND TRUCK
TRIPS RESULTING IN LESS
CONGESTION. AND TRUCKS IDLING
IN CALIFORNIA HIGHWAYS AND
BETTER AIR QUALITY. WELL WE
INSTITUTE SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE BIG
PICTURE. AND BUILD FOR THE
FUTURE. BUT WE CANNOT AND
SHOULD NOT DO THIS ALONE.
THERE'S TOO MUCH AT STAKE WHERE
YOU'RE CALLING ME NOT NOT ONLY
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY BUT OF
COURSE THE NATIONAL FUND. THE
PROBLEM IS RESPECTFULLY UPS
THAT THE STATE'S SUPPLY CHAIN
RELIEF INSTABILITY PACKAGE
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUDGET. ON
THAT NOTE INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
WORKFORCE TRAINING DEVELOPMENT
OF A CHANGE OF IT'S QUITE
CHANGES A DIGITAL SURPRISED.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INCREASE IN
CAPACITY THE LAWSUIT
EFFICIENCIES OF THE CALIFORNIA
PORTS. AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS THAT THE
STATE LOOK AT ONGOING CONTINUED
SUPPORT. FOR THE SPORTS. SO WE
CAN KEEP PACE FOR OTHER STATES
REMAIN COMPETITIVE AND AGAIN.
BIG PICTURE WE'RE CALIFORNIA
REMAINS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THIS WORLD. AND
AGAIN ON THE VALUE OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND OF
COURSE FOR THE PANEL MEMBERS
WHO EXPRESSED THE SAME AND TWO
OF. MANY HERE WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS AND
HOPEFULLY GOING FORWARD WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN EMPHASIS OF
WHAT IS SUCH A CENTRAL PARK
RATIO NOT ONLY FOR AGAINST YOUR
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THE NATIONAL
ECONOMY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU EXECUTIVES MARIO
CORDERO NEWS MOVED TO SOREL.
WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES MISTER
SOROKA WHEN READY.
MISTER
STROKE CAN YOU HEAR ME. ALL
AREAS I HEARD SOME. YEAH CAN
YOU FOR STEVEN READY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE A GREAT
THANKS A LOT MY NAME IS JEAN
SOROKA HUNG THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AND CITY OF LOS ANGELES
CHIEF LOGISTICS OFFICER IN
RESPONSE TO COBIT NINETEEN. I'D
LIKE TO TAKE JUST A COUPLE OF
MINUTES TO TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW WE GOT HERE. WHAT
WE'RE DOING NOW AND WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE IN THE FUTURE. MANY
FOLKS HAVE CALLED THIS A CRISIS
AND AN END OF DAYS WITH RESPECT
TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN. ACTUALLY
THE STORY HERE IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. BUT IT DOES DATE
BACK YEARS AND DECADES WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT WE NOW HAVE A
SPOTLIGHT SHINED ON. FOR AREAS
OF IMPROVEMENT. IN MOST RECENT
HISTORY THIS BEGAN ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF YEARS AGO. WITH THE
TRADE POLICIES OF THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON.
AND THE COUNTER TRADE POLICIES.
PUT BACK IN THE AREAS OF
RETALIATORY TARIFFS BY CHINA.
THAT BECAUSE A LOT OF IMPORTS
TO SPEED UP AND ORDERS ADVANCED
SO MUCH SO THAT AT THE END OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT MAY
NOT BE REMEMBERED THAT OUR
BUSINESS YEAR THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES FELL OFF A CLIFF. BY
ABOUT SIXTEEN PERCENT. BENKOVAC
NINETEEN HIT EARLY IN TWENTY
TWENTY. SHUTTING DOWN THE
FACTORY COMMUNITY AND MOST OF
CHINA AND SPREAD TO OTHER ASIAN
COUNTRIES. IN THE FIRST FIVE
MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
BUSINESS AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES DROPPED BY AN
ADDITIONAL NINETEEN PERCENT. SO
EFFECTIVELY WHEN YOU WERE NOT
IMPORTING. FINISHED PRODUCTS
PARTS AND COMPONENTS FOR
FACTORIES FOR A TOTAL OF ABOUT
EIGHT MONTHS OR MAYBE JUST
ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
NORMAL IMPORT LEVELS. THEN
SUDDENLY WE STARTED TO SEE MANY
TRENDS HAPPEN. EMPTY CONTAINERS
COME BACK TO OUR PORT COMPLEXES
THE NEED TO GET THOSE BACK TO
ASIA TO PRE POSITION THOSE
ASSETS FOR WHEN THE FACTORIES
OPEN. AND WE WATCH THIS VERY
CLOSELY WE WATCHED ENERGY USAGE
TRAFFIC PATTERNS AND EVEN
POLLUTION IN CHINA TO SEE WHAT
LEVEL OF ACTIVITY IN ADDITION
TO OUR LONG TERM RELATIONSHIPS.
AND THOSE PHONE CALLS YIELDED
ON A NIGHTLY BASIS. THEN THE
STRENGTH OF THE AMERICAN
CONSUMER BEGAN TO SHOW AS EARLY
AS JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY. MANY
OF US WERE WORKING FROM HOME.
WE DIDN'T GO TO BALL GAMES OR
MOVIES WHERE ARE GOING TO
RESTAURANTS ARE FLYING TO SEE
YOUR GRANDPARENTS. WE STARTED
TO BUY ONLINE AND IN FACT OVER
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS ONLINE
BUYING DOUBLED IN WHAT TOOK US
IS AN AMERICAN CONSUMER TEN
YEARS TO BUILT. RETAIL SALES
CONTINUE TO FLOURISH IS WE'RE
AT HOME WE BOUGHT SOFAS AND
REFRIGERATORS OUTDOOR PATIO
SETS IN MY CASE I BOUGHT A SET
OF GOLF CLUBS AND SHOES BECAUSE
MY GYM WAS CLOSED I NEED TO
EXERCISE. REALLY HASN'T HELPED
MY GAME BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE
CONTINUE TO BUY ALL THESE
GOODS. STILL TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH AMERICAN CONSUMER DEMAND
HAS NOW BEEN THE MESSAGE IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN FOR THE BETTER
PART OF THE LAST. YEAR IN A
QUARTER. AND ALL DURING THIS
TIME WE ALSO SAW THE AMERICAN
EXPORTSLIMIT. HERE IN LOS
ANGELES WE'RE NOW DOWN THIRTY
ONE OF THE LAST THIRTY FIVE
MONTHS ON EXPORTS. TRADE POLICY
MONETARY POLICY WHICH HELPS US
GREATLY IN SO MANY AREAS OF OUR
ECONOMY IS A CHALLENGE FOR
THOSE COMPANIES WERE TRYING TO
COMPETE WITH OTHER TRADING
NATIONS. ACROSS THE ASIA
PACIFIC REGION. AND IS MORE
RECENT PHENOMENON OF PUTTING AN
EMPHASIS ON REMOVING AND MOVING
OUT EMPTY CONTAINERS BACK TO
ASIA AS ALL PUT PRESSURE ON THE
AMERICAN FARMER. AND EXPORTER.
AND TO ILLUSTRATE OUR SPENDING
HABITS ARE DISCRETIONARY INCOME
ARE GOING TO GOOD IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THOSE SERVICES AND
WE CONTINUE AT A VERY HIGH CLIP
IN THAT SPENDING. I ANTICIPATED
SOME POINT WE WILL LEVEL OFF
AND WE WILL GO OUT MORE AND
MORE INTO THE SERVICE SECTOR IN
FACT THIS MORNING'S REPORT. BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOWS
SERVICE SECTOR NUMBERS ARE UP
AND ESPECIALLY THE HOSPITALITY
SECTOR OF OUR BUSINESS STARTED
TO SHOW SOME PROMISE WITH MORE
HIGHER DURING THE MONTH OF
OCTOBER. CAN I TRANSLATE INTO
MORE CARGO COMING THROUGH
AMERICA'S LARGEST TRADE GATEWAY
HERE IN LOS ANGELES WE'RE
ESTIMATING THAT WE MAY MOVE AS
MUCH AS ELEVEN MILLION
CONTAINER UNITS THIS YEAR THIS
WOULD BE AN ALL TIME RECORD.
AND I KNOW COMPARISONS ARE KIND
OF CLUNKY GIVEN THE RECENT
TRAVAILS OF TRADE COBIT
NINETEEN AND THIS IMPORT SURGE
BUT THIS WOULD BE FOURTEEN
PERCENT. OF ALL OF OUR ALL TIME
BEST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AND FOR A SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT WE LOOK LIKE TODAY HERE AT
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES WE'RE
ACTIVELY WORKING SIXTEEN
VESSELS IN THIS IS AN AREA THAT
HAS NOT BEEN TALKED ABOUT MUCH
YET. OUR PRODUCTIVITY FROM THE
VESSEL SIDE IS UP 50% YEAR ON
YEAR AND 80% COMPARED TO A
SIMILAR TIME LAST YEAR OVER THE
LAST SIX WEEKS. THE AVERAGE
LOADING AND UNLOADING OF A SHIP
HERE IN LOS ANGELES IS ELEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
CONTAINERS. AND THAT'S THE BEST
OTHER INTERNATIONAL PORTS THAT
MANY TALK ABOUT WORK YOUR
GATEWAY HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHEN A SHIP COMES IN
WE JUST CHARGE AND ITS ENTIRE
CONTENTS AND LOAD BACK THAT
ENTIRE SHIP AT ONE PORT CALL.
NOT MANY OTHER PORTS AROUND THE
WORLD DO THAT NOT EVEN HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES NOW HERE'S
WHAT'S GOT EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION. TODAY WE HAVE NINETY
SIX SHIPS AT ANCHOR SEVENTY OF
THOSE ARE OF THE CONTAINER
VARIETY. THIRTY FIVE OF THOSE
CONTAINERSHIPS ARE DESTINED FOR
LOS ANGELES THE OTHER HALF
EXACTLY DESTINED FOR LONG BEACH
BUT HERE'S THE INTERESTING
THING WE'VE HAD TEN NEW
ENTRANTS TO THE TRADE JUST THIS
YEAR SEEING A BOOMING
TRANSPACIFIC MARKET. NEED FOR
CAPACITY ON THE VESSEL SIDE
MORE FOLKS ARE COMING IN THOSE
THAT PREDOMINANTLY WORKING
INTER ASIA OR MIDDLE EAST LONG
HAUL TRADES HAVE SHIFTED THEIR
VESSELS HERE TO THE
TRANSPACIFIC. NOW THE AMOUNT OF
CARGO SITTING OUT ON THE SHIP
ALSO GET A LOT OF ATTENTION FOR
MEDIA. IT IS THE EQUIVALENT
RIGHT NOW. ALTHOUGH ABOUT
FIFTEEN TO SIXTEEN SHIPS THAT
OUR RECORD. AGAIN EVERY
CONTAINER SHIP WE BRING IN
AVERAGE IS A LITTLE MORE THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
CONTAINERS EXCHANGED YOU'VE GOT
A LOT OF SMALL SHIPS SITTING AT
ANCHOR TODAY. FIFTEEN HUNDRED
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CONTAINERSHIPS THAT ALL
GOING TO THAT BIG COUNT OF
SEVENTY. AGAIN FOR LOS ANGELES
IN LONG BEACH COMBINED WE WOULD
LOOK LIKE WE HAVE THIRTY TWO
SHIPS AT ANCHOR WHICH IS
NOWHERE NEAR THE RECORD THAT
WAS SET OF NINETY SEVEN. BACK
IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND TO A
VERY DIFFERENT TIME AND FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS LOOKING
FURTHER AT THIS CHART. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
DWELL TIME OF CONTAINERS
CONTINUES TO INCREASE FOLKS
THAT IMPORT ARE SITTING ON
THEIR CARGO LONGER FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS. IN FACT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED OUT OF THE
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND IMPORT
CONTAINERS THAT ARE SITTING IN
LOS ANGELES. THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND HAVE BEEN SITTING FOR
MORE THAN NINE DAYS AND SINCE
WE MADE OUR ANNOUNCEMENT ON
THIS PENALTY FEE WE'VE GOT
REQUEST TO MOVE NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED CONTAINERS OFF PORT
PROPERTY FOR LONG TERM STORAGE.
THERE'S A MISMATCH HERE WE'VE
GOT PATIO FURNITURE ON THE
DOCKS WE'VE GOT CHRISTMAS TREES
OUT AT ANCHOR FOLKS ORDERED A
LOT OF PRODUCT OF THE- A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT SECTIONS. ALL
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THE FACTORY'S
CAPACITY WOULD FILL UP. IF WE
REMOVE THOSE THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND CONTAINERS
FROM LOS ANGELES THE FLUIDITY
RISES A MEDIA LIKE. MUCH IS
ALSO BEEN SAID ABOUT THESE
EMPTY CONTAINER ABILITY ON
AVERAGE WERE MOVING THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
EMPTY CONTAINER UNITS EVERY
MONTH OUT OF THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES. 30% MORE THAN WE DID A
YEAR AGO OUR VESSELS ARE 75%
EMPTY 25% EXPORT I'LL TALK MORE
ABOUT EXPORT IN A MOMENT. BUT
THESE DWELL TIMES ARE REALLY
WHAT'S DRIVING A LOT OF THE
LACK OF FLUIDITY AGAIN WE'RE
BREAKING RECORDS EVERY MONTH
PRODUCTIVITY NOT JUST PR
RECORDS. PRODUCTIVITY BY THE
LONG SURE MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
LOADING AND UNLOADING THE SHIPS
IT'S LIKE TAKING TEN LANES OF
FREEWAY TRAFFIC AND MOVING IN
IN THE FIVE WE'RE STILL GOING
PRETTY FAST WHAT IT'S ABOUT
ABSORBING ARE DIGESTING ALL
THIS CARGO INTO THE DOMESTIC
SUPPLY CHAIN. AS HAS BEEN
COVERED THERE'S A PAUCITY OF
TRUCK DRIVERS WERE SHORT EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN TRUCKING ASSOCIATIONS
NATIONWIDE. AND IS RACHEL SAID
EARLIER WE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND WAREHOUSE JOBS OPEN
AND OUR WAREHOUSES TWO BILLION
SQUARE FEET FROM THE SHORES OF
THE PACIFIC OUT TO THE DESERT
REGION OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ARE OVERFLOWING WITH CARGO.
WE'VE CO MINGLED FULFILLMENT-
ONLINE BUYING WITHTRADITIONAL
WAREHOUSING AND CROSS DOCKING
CAPABILITIES THESE WAREHOUSES
NO LONGER. ARE ENOUGH TO CATER
TO ALL THE CARGO THAT'S COMING
YET SO WE'VE GOT TO WATCH OUT
ON THOSE TWELVE TIMES AND THEY
CREATE AN ARTIFICIAL SHORTAGE
OF CHASSIS. CONTAINERS ARE NOW
BEING USED FOR STORAGE WHETHER
THEY BE ON OUR DOCKS ARE OUT ON
THE STREET MORE PRECIOUS
CHASSIS IS UNDERNEATH THOSE
CONTAINERS WE'VE GOT A SPEED
THE LAWSUIT IN A HEALTHY AND
SAFE WAY OF GETTING THOSE
CONTAINERS BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM. THIS IDEA OF LAND USE
IS A GREAT ONE WHICH WE'LL TALK
ABOUT IN A MOMENT BUT NOW WE
HAVE HUNDREDS OF PARCELS OF
LAND. STRING THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ITS MY
ESTIMATE WILL BE BACK IN FRONT
OF YOU IN ANOTHER MONTH AND A
HALF TALKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
SCOOP UP ALL THOSE CONTAINERS
AND. GET HIM BACK FOR AN EARLY
LUNAR NEW YEAR. OUR NATION
FIRST AND STILL ONLY PORT
COMMUNITY SYSTEM RESIDES HERE
IN LOS ANGELES THE PORT
OPTIMIZER. ONE OF ITS KEY
DISTRIBUTORS OF INFORMATION IS
THE SIGNAL. THESE ARE ACTUAL
LOADINGS OF VESSELS SUPPLIED BY
U. S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION TWENTY FOUR HOURS
BEFORE SAILING. AND CALL A
COMBINED WITH VESSEL MANIFESTS
FROM ALL OF OUR TRADING
PARTNERS ON THE LINER SHIPPING
SIDE. THOSE NUMBERS KEEP ON
COMING OUT WE HAVE TWENTY ONE
SHIPS COMING IN OVER THE NEXT
THREE DAYS WHICH IS A BIG
NUMBER. SO WE BEGAN WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BIKE
THAT MINISTRATION TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR OWN
MUNICIPALITY MONTHS AGO. ON A
SHORT TERM FOCUS TO GET AFTER
THE IMMEDIACY IS OF WHAT WE SAW
WE BEGAN IMPLEMENTING FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO REDUCE TRUCK TURN
TIMES INCREASE THE ROUND TRIPS
ARE TRUCKERS AND LINER SHIPPING
IMPROVEMENTS ON EFFICIENCIES.
WE ROLLED OUT FOR NEW MODULES
OF OUR INFORMATION SHARING
SYSTEM DURING COPA NINETEEN
DESIGNED BY INDUSTRY DEVELOPED
AND DELIVERED FOR INDUSTRY.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON A TRUCK
GATE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND A
DEMURRAGE AND DETENTION OR
STORAGE PILOT MUCH AS BEEN MADE
ABOUT POLITICIZING AND
WEAPONIZING THE STORAGE CHARGES
WERE GOING TO GET DOWN TO THE
BOTTOM F IT. AND WE'RE ALSO
WORKING BOTH INTERNATIONALLY
AND DOMESTICALLY ON FREE DATA
ARCHITECTURE AND STANDARDS
REGARDLESS OF WHO THE
UNDERLYING TECH SERVICE
PROVIDER IS SHARING INFORMATION
THROUGH THE PORT OPTIMIZER IS
MADE POSSIBLE TODAY. AND TO GET
AFTER THE IMMEDIACY IS
OVERSATURATION USING OUR
EXISTING CAPACITY. 30% OF ALL
TRUCK APPOINTMENTS EVERY DAY GO
ON USED HERE AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS 50% GO UNUSED DURING
THE WEEKENDS WE OF LATENT
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW LONG SHORE
MANY WOMEN ON THE DOCKS IN THE
TERMINALS READY TO MOVE AS MUCH
CARGO AS POSSIBLE LEADING BACK
TO MY ORIGINAL THEORY SOME
FOLKS DON'T NEED CERTAIN
CONTAINERS RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT
A SEGMENT THOSE TO THE SIDE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE CREATED
ACCELERATE CARDINAL LA TURNING
WHAT IS TRADITIONALLY A PULL
SYSTEM WE OPEN UP ON OUR HOURS
OF OPERATION. PUT UP A
SPREADSHEET FOR IMPORT
APPOINTMENTS TO BE MADE BY OUR
TRUCKERS AND WAIT FOR THEM TO
SHOW UP WE TURN THE TABLES IT'S
NOW A PUSH SYSTEM WE KNOW WHOSE
CARGO IS HERE WHERE IT'S
LOCATED AND HOW LONG IT'S BEEN
THERE. A SYSTEM THAT WAS A
HEAVY LIFT MANUALLY BUT NOW
BEING DIGITIZED UNFORTUNATELY.
OF THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IMPORTERS THE CALL LOS
ANGELES HOME EVERY YEAR ONLY
TWENTY COMPANIES TOOK US UP ON
THIS PREMIUM SERVICE AGAIN. DO
WE REALLY NEED THE CARGO IN ITS
NOTS LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET THE PRODUCT TO MARKET THAT
EASY AND NEAT. AND THAT'S WHY.
AFTER MANY MONTHS OF
COLLABORATION ORDER SHIPPING
MEETINGS ON OPERATIONS WE CAME
TO THIS FINAL AND LAST RESORT.
AND THAT WAS CHARGING A PENALTY
ON CONTAINERS THAT SAT NINETIES
OR GREATR TO MOVE OUT OF THE
TRUCK SIX DAYS OR GREATER ON
RAIL AND AS I MENTIONED SINCE
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT CAME OUT WITH
A- REQUEST IN FOR MORE THAT
NEARLY TEN THOUSAND CONTAINERS
TO BE MOVED OFF DOCK AND STORED
IN LONG TERM STORAGE FACILITIES.
LONGER TERM WE MUST CONTINUE
THIS DIALOGUE ACROSS THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTOR AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO BE VERY ACTIVE. WE
NEED TO PRODUCE A NATIONAL PORT
COMMUNITY SYSTEM WE'RE THIRTY
YEARS BEHIND OTHER TRADING
NATIONS I WORKED OVERSEAS FOR
ELEVEN YEARS IN ASIA AND THE
MIDDLE EAST. WE NEED TO IMPROVE
OUR NATION'S COMPETITIVENESS
THROUGH DIGITIZATION AND WE
MUST CREATE A NATIONAL EXPORT
POLICY I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
REGULATION OR LEGISLATION THIS
IS AN AREA TO GET THE AMERICAN
FARMER AND MANUFACTURE BACK IN
THE GAME. GET THE CALIFORNIA
FARMER RECONNECTED WITH THEIR
TRADING PARTNERS ANDCUSTOMERS
OVERSEAS WE'VE BEEN TALKING AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS THE FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENT AND I
THINK WE'VE GOT SOME VERY
INTERESTED PEOPLE. AND IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED BUT WE'RE READY
TO TURN. ON THE NATION'S FIRST
AND ONLY WORKFORCE TRAINING
CENTER. THAT WILL B RIGHT HERE
AT THE NATION'S LARGEST PORT
COMPLEX IT'LL BE ABLE TO CREATE
A PIPELINE OF SKILLED LABOR AND
IT'S WELCOME TO ALL ALTHOUGH
ARE A LONG SHORT MEN AND WOMEN
MARINE CLERKS FOR MEN ARE RIGHT
HERE IN TOWN TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS WILL BE ABLE TO TRAIN
TRUCK DRIVERS AND WELDERS.
LOGISTICIANS AND FOLKS WHO WORK
ON COMPUTERS THERE WILL BE A
DAY PRETTY SOON THEN A MECHANIC
NO LONGER WORKS WITH THE RANCH
WITH A COMPUTER TO IMPROVE AND
DIAGNOSTICALLY TEST EQUIPMENT.
AND LASTLY IT'S BEEN SAID
BEFORE BY DANNY ONE BUT WE NEED
TO GET OUR FAIR SHARE THE
INVESTMENT. AND WHEN THE CARGO
TO TRAVERSE IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST PORK REACHES EACH AND
EVERYONE OF OUR COUNTRY FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS THE
BEST RETURN ON INVESTMENT FOR
THE AMERICAN CITIZEN. ALL ROADS
LEAD HERE TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND I MENTIONED
WE'VE ROLLED OUT FOR NEW
MODULES OF OUR NATION'S FIRST
PORT COMMUNITY SYSTEM. IS
INTEROPERABLE WE WELCOME
EVERYONE. AND WITH THAT. I
WOULD SAY THAT IT IS A CALL TO
ACTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT LAND USE WE NEED TWO OR
THREE STRATEGIC LOCATIONS THAT
WE CAN MONITOR SECURE WHEN IT'S
HAVE COMES TIME FOR BRING THOSE
EXPORTS AND DECENT CHASSIS IS
BACK WE HAVE A REAL BEAT ARE
WHERE ALL THESE CAPITAL ASSETS
LIE. AND WE'RE GOING TO NEED
HELP IN THE TRUCK SECTOR TO
MOVE ALL THESE CONTAINERS OUT
THAT ARE NOT NEEDED TODAY.
HALSALL THESE RETAIL GOODS
PARTS AND COMPONENTS FOR
FACTORIES AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
IT'S LOS SOMETIMES BUT 20% OF
OUR IMPORTS ARE REFERRALS PARTS
AND COMPONENTS FOR UNITED
STATES MANUFACTURING IT WITH A
WEAKER MANUFACTURING NUMBER
TODAY. PART OF THAT LIES ON OUR
SHOULDERS. WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
BE LOOKING QUICKLY AT
ACTIVATING EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL ACRES ON TERMINAL
ISLAND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN FAST. WE CAN SEE
THIS IS A RETURN FACILITY FOR
AT LEAST HAVE LONG SURE FLIP
THOSE EMPTY CONTAINERS OFF GET
A ROAD ABILITY CHECK ON THE
CHASSIS. PICK UP THAT IMPORT
AND MOVE OUT WILL MOVE THOSE
INTO CONTAINERS OVERNIGHT WHEN
THERE'S LESS TRUCK ACTIVITY TO
LOAD RIGHT AGAINST THE VESSEL.
AND WE NEED WE NEED A LITTLE
BIT OF ASSISTANCE WITH THE NEAR
TERM ZERO EMISSIONS DRAYAGE
TRUCK DEPLOYMENT WE CALL IT THE
Z. TWENTY FIVE PROGRAM. WERE
ACTIVELY SEEKING THE INPUT OF
ORIGINAL EQUIPMENT
MANUFACTURERS AND CHEERED
SUPPLIERS TO PUT THESE TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD WITHIN THE NEXT
THREE MONTHS. AND I MENTION
THAT SUPPLY CHAIN DATA
INTERCONNECTED BODY AGAIN WORK
WITH OR WHATEVER PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPANY YOU WANT BUT MAKE YOUR
DATA PUBLIC AND WILL BRING IT
ALL TOGETHER. WITH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS HERE THE
SMART. CARE GREAT THANK YOU TO
THE TO OUR DIRECTORS- AND WHAT
WE WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS VOTERS
COULD HAVE SOME SHORT QUESTIONS
SHORT ANSWER. IS WE HAVE TO BE
OUT OF THIS ROOM AND A BIT AND
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER PANEL. MISTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ON MY QUESTION WAS- FOR-
CHEERS TO REGRET OR OR- DORAL
COULD COULD GENERAL IN CHARGE-
AND YOU KINDA ANSWERED IT ON IN
YOUR PRESENTATION OF- THE
CONTAINERACCESS TWELVE FEES
AND HOW DID YOU SEE THAT ALL.
REDUCING WAIT TIME FOR THESE
CONTAINERS AT YOUR PORT BUT I
GUESS MY REAL QUESTION IS WHAT
INSURANCE DO YOU HAVE THAT
THESE FEES JUST WON'T SIMPLY
ARE COSTS TO THE CONSUMER AT
THE END OF THE DAY. THANK
CENTER. HE THE WASHINGTON YEAH
I'M SURE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
THE WANT TO SPEAK THAT ORDER
WAS. PASSED ON TO AMERICAN
SHIPPING THIS WAS INTENDED TO
CARE CITY TABLE TO ASSIST US
AND COLLABORATE DOING.
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
MISSIONERS FOR COMP SO THAT
WASN'T TOO OF DEFEAT LAST ALSO
THAT I COULD BOTTOM LINE OKAY.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME VERY GOOD
COLLABORATIVE COME WE'VE HAD
WITH THE- UP THERE TO ALL THEY
CAN TO ENJOY THIS ISSUE SO
HOPEFULLY YEAH. A LOT THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
BE A- MASON FOREVER BUT I MEAN
SHORT TERM WE'RE TO PUSH ALL
THE BUTTONS TO TAKE ALL ACTIONS
ARE WE NEED TO GIVE PEOPLE TO
AGAIN INSTEAD. OF TO THIS ISSUE
THAT WERE IN WE GET THAT'S BEEN
ROCKED WORDED. LET'S LOOK. AT
GLOBAL CRISIS BUT HERE THE
NATION ARE PORK. THESE MEASURES
NEED TO BE TAKEN AGAIN TO THE
CAR OF. SENATOR I CAN'T YOU
ANYTHING AT THIS IN TIME I WILL
TELL YOU THAT THE NAY. RATE
FOR. RECENT PUT OUT AN
ANNOUNCED SAYING THIS WILL BE
THE- RETAIL SALES YEAR EVER IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
LINER SHIPPING COMPANIES ARE
MAKING RECORD PROFITS THIS YEAR
RECORD MULTIPLE TIMES BEYOND
THEIR BEST EVER YEARS IN THE
EARLY PARTS OF THE TWO
THOUSAND. SIX AND OTHERS ALONG
THE SUPPLY CHAIN OR L. ALSO
PROFITING FROM THESE RECORD
VOLUMES FUELED BY THESE GREAT
AMERICAN CONSUMER DEMAND AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. TO
BRING IN A VERY FAMOUS PAIR OF
BASKETBALL SHOES IN MORE NORMAL
TIMES. COST TWELVE CENTS TO GET
THEM TO THE STORE THAT YOU WHEN
I BUY FROM. TWELVE CENTS PER
PAIR ON A HUNDRED DOLLAR PAIR
OF BASKETBALL SHOES LET'S GO
ALONG WITH THE MEDIA FOR A
SECOND AND SAY THAT NUMBER HAS
DOUBLED TRIPLED EVEN CALL IT A
DOLLAR. PER PAIR OF THOSE
BASKETBALL SHOES IF THAT MONEY
OF THIS HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE GETS
PASSED ON TO THE AMERICAN
CONSUMER. OTHERS SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY THIS BODY.
SEOUL'S FEES WILL BE ASSESSED
ON YOUR MEMBERS COMPANIES AS
WALLER. THOSE FEES ARE GOING TO
BE DIRECTLY ASSESSED AGAINST
THE LINER SHIPPING COMPANIES
THEY HAVE SKIN IN THIS GAME TOO
THEY WORK DIRECTLY WITH OUR
MUTUAL CUSTOMERS AND AGAIN I
TAKEN THIS DRASTIC STEP ON THE
LOS ANGELES SIDE IS I HAVEN'T
ALWAYS GOTTEN THE STRAIGHT
STORY FROM SOME OF THESE
IMPORTERS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER IN THESE
COLLABORATIVE ZOOM MEETINGS AND
MAKING COMMITMENTS AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS IN THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND CARGO IS NOT
NEEDED WE'RE SUDDENLY
UNDERSTANDING THE CARGO IS
GOING TO BE MOVED TO THE SITE
VERY QUICKLY AS THESE FEES
APPROACHING THE NEXT ELEVEN
DAYS SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
CONVERSATION MUST BE TRUTHFUL
AND THERE IS NO SHAME HERE IF
YOU DON'T NEED YOUR CARGO NOW
WE SIMPLY ASKED IT BE MOVED
ASIDE BECAUSE THINK OF THAT.
SMALL THIRD GENERATION FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESS THAT IMPORTS TEN
CONTAINERS OF TOYS A YEAR THEIR
ENTIRE PAYROLL DEPENDS ON THE
NEXT FOUR WEEKS WE HAVE TO
DELIVER TO THAT COMPANY. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
WRONG. I'LL JUST BROKE ALL MY
QUESTIONS IN A WAY INTO INTO-
INTO ONE I THINK I'VE THREE
QUESTIONS YOU CAN ALL- YOU CAN
CHOOSE BUT WHICH WAS ONE ANSWER
BINDING GENE YOU MADE IT A VERY
GOOD POINT ABOUT THE IMPACT. OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN ON
MANUFACTURING THAT WE FOCUS ON
THE IMPORTS WE FOCUS ON
AGRICULTURE BUT THE INVENTORY
DELAYS CAUSED BY- THESE
INTERRUPTIONS OR ARE
SIGNIFICANT- ARE MAIN FACTORS
IN IN THE UNITED STATES IN
CALIFORNIA RELY ON JUST IN TIME
DELIVERY AND MANUFACTURING. SO
THESE SUPPLY CHAIN IMPACTS HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
MANUFACTURING BASE AS WELL SO
MY FIRST QUESTION IS HOW DO
OTHER STATES INVEST IN THEIR
PORTS AND SUPPLY CHAIN AND IS
THERE A CONCERN THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL LOSE MARKET SHARE BECAUSE
OF THIS MY SECOND QUESTION IS
ON THE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN- MOVE
FOR THE PORTS HOW IS THAT
ALIGNED WITH THE HOURS AND THE
WAREHOUSES AND HOW DO WE ALIGN.
HOW DO WE MAKE THAT WORK AND
THIRD ON THE LAND USE ISSUE- IF
YOU HAD YOUR- ANALYSIS WHERE
WOULD YOU PLACE- THOSE. TWO OR
THREE INLAND PORTS AND WHAT
WOULD BE THE HURDLES TO MAKE.
THAT HAPPEN AND WHO WOULD RUN.
DOESN'T MAGICALLY. THANK LET ME
TELL MY PERSONAL FIRST EVENT
THIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. SOME IT ME LET ME SEE
TO THIS COME. LET'S LET'S HAVE
A HISTORIC CON TO WHAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING TO. LET ME TELL YOU
THAT STOCKTON YOU'RE TWENTY
TEN. JUDY TO CERTAIN TWENTY.
DISSOCIATION AMERICAN STORY. AT
A CONFERENCE AND A VERY
RESPECTED ECONOMIST JOHN
RECOMMEND. ADVISERS THAT BY
TWENTY TWENTY THIS WAS THIS
PREDICTIONS MADE ELEVEN YEARS
AGO AND BY TWENTY TWENTY. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PORTS IF WE IF WE
DID NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUES AND
HAVE. NO TO ADDRESS WHAT HE
PREDICTED WOULD BE NINETEEN
MILLION PIZZA CONTAINERS IN THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY. WELL MISTER
RECOMMEND WAS ALMOST RIGHT ON
POINT. AND I HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH A CRISIS BUT HAVE
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. OKAY
DOLLARS. CHELSEA'S IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT SO TO
YOUR QUESTION. I THINK IN MY
SIX YEARS OF THE FEDERAL
MARITIME COMMISSION BEING
CHAIRMAN ARE IN WASHINGTON DC.
I HAD A UNIQUE VIEW OF HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF
THEM FOR EXECUTIVES AND THE
BOARD OF THIRTIES AND ALL THE
CEOS OF THE MAJOR INTERNATIONAL
CARRIERS. AND IT IS FAIR TO
SAY. THAT THE INVESTMENT IN
SOME OF OUR COMPETITIVE PARTS.
OF OUR EXCEEDED WHAT I SAW IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE GOOD NEWS I
THINK THAT WE'RE HAVING A VERY
PROPER CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
THINK MOVING FORWARD I THINK
IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS GOVERNOR
AND THIS COMMITTEE. AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS MARIJUANA AS HAS
BEEN REPRESENTATIVE. WHAT ARE
WE DOING THIS CRISIS OTHER
LESSONS LEARNED OVER THIS
CRISIS. PRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY
AND UP THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
IS BACK IN TWENTY TEN LET'S
JUST TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
WE WERE UNPREPARED TO ADDRESS
TODAY. SIMPLY BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T WILLING TO HAVE A
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. AND THE REQUIRED
INVESTMENT THAT'S NEEDED IN THE
NATION'S LARGEST PORT COMPLEX.
AND LESS I WILL SAY THIS.
DURING DISAPPOINTED WAS
DISRUPTED. FIRST OF ALL. DUE TO
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION AT THE
U. S. IN WASHINGTON WITH THE
TRADE WAR. THAT COMMENCED AND
ALREADY DISRUPTION IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. AND MANY OF US
SAID AT THAT POINT THAT NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO ON THIS TURF
ISSUE THAT WAS NOT. RECOMMENDED
POLICY IT WASN'T- THE NEEDLE
WITH REGARD TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE TRANS PACIFIC TRADE
ROUTE THAT IS THE WEST COAST
UNITED STATES TO ASIAN. I WANT
TO REMOVE HERE I DON'T SEE IS
GOING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
ANYTIME SOON. SO WHAT. I JUST
WANT EARNERS OF ALL THE
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY. WE KNEW YESTERDAY.
SO MY ONLY SENSE OF URGENCY IS
LOST NOT LOSE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAKE. ROADS WHAT WE NEED TO
DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T
GREAT PLAINS TO REMAIN AND
CONSISTENTLY BE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WE GET TO EVEN GREATER THINGS
TODAY WITH THE COMMENTARY HAS
BEEN MADE TODAY SPECIFICALLY
WITH SOME OF OUR STATE LEADERS
LIKE DUCEY MYERS. AND SECRETARY
DAVID CHIU. THANK YOU I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR CLARIFICATION ON
THE DOCKS IS SO CONTAINERS
SITTING ON THE DOCKS SOME OF
THOSE CONTAINERS ARE FULL OF
GOODS. AND THEY'RE USING THE
DOCK- THE VCOS OTHER WAREHOUSES
ARE USING THE DOC'S ESSENTIALLY
AS A WAREHOUSE. SO THOSE THOSE
CONTAINERS ARE SITTING THERE
FOR AN EXCESSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME
BUT THERE'S ALSO EMPTIES ON THE
DOCKS TO IS THAT ACCURATE. OUR
EMPTIES TYING UP THE DOCKS.
THERE'S A THERE'S THE THERE'S
BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
SWEEPER SHIPS COULD YOU JUST
WALK US THROUGH THAT QUICKLY.
SURE ALL ALL TAKE THAT LONG.
I'M SORRY MARIO YOU FIRST PLACE.
GOOD CUT YEAH THERE'S A LOT
RECENTLY CHAIR OF- OF DANTE'S
CLOGGING UP THE- CLOGGING UP
THE SYSTEM WERE LOADING OUT
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND EMPTIES PER MONTH
WHICH IS NOT ONLY THE HIGHEST
ON RECORD BUT IT BEAT THE HIGH
SET JUST LAST YEAR ON AVERAGE
BY 30% WERE OVERSUBSCRIBED ON
ANDY'S GOING BACK TO ASIA.
WE'RE ALSO COLLECTING EMPTY
CONTAINERS FROM NONTRADITIONAL
GEOGRAPHIES AT THE PRESENT TIME
THINK OF SOUTHEAST ATLANTIC
PORTS AS WELL AS GULF COAST
PORTS TO SEND THOSE BACK AS
FAST AS WE CAN TO WE GOT INTO A
LITTLE BIT OF A DISCUSSION OVER
THE WEEKEND WITH SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE TRUCKING
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS
REPRESENTING THAT. THEIR EIGHTY
THOUSAND CONTAINERS ON THE
STREETS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW THAT NEED TO BE
RETURNED BY THE TRUCKING
COMMUNITY THAT IS MANAGEABLE
BUT WE HAVE TO DO IS MAKE THE
LINER SHIPPING NUMBERS ON HOW
MANY MPS THEY'LL RECEIVE EVERY
DAY PUBLIC INFORMATION THEN USE
SOMETHING LIKE THE PORT
OPTIMIZER TO DO JUST THAT.
SOLVE THEY'RE NOT CLOGGING UP
THE SYSTEM IN FACT IN LOS
ANGELES TODAY WE HAVE SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND IMPORTS ON THE
DOCKS. ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND EXPORTS AND FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND CONTAINER UNITS OF
EMPTIES. FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
REPRESENTS ABOUT FOUR DAYS OR
FOUR DAYS WORTH OF WORK THE
LONGSHOREMEN HAVE TO LOAD THOSE
EMPTIES BACK UP ON TO THE SHIP
AGAIN A VERY MANAGEABLE. NUMBER
BUT AT THE SAME TIME PORT ENVOY
GIAMPA COREY HAS BEEN IMPLORING
THE LINER SHIPPING COMPANIES TO
BRING IN SOME EXTRA MUSCLES AND
EVEN MOVE THOSE AT THE SOUTH
FASTER TO LOOSEN UP THE
SITUATION. SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
WHAT YOU CORRECTLY SET SOME
IMPORTERS. HOLDING ONTO
CONTAINERS LONGER ON THE PORK
THAT'S AN ADDED SEGMENTS ON THE
STAR MAX THAT MAKES THE
SITUATION A LITTLE BIT TOUGHER
TO HAVE MANEUVERABILITY. AND IF
I MAY GO BACK TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG'S- THREE QUESTIONS-
AS YOU SAW LAST WEEK WHEN YOU
VISITED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THE- THE-
ACTIVITY OF THE DOCKS IS REALLY
FAST. THINGS ARE MOVING QUICKLY
IT'S GETTING THAT PRODUCT OUT
THE GATE AND IF IT DOESN'T NEED
TO GO NOW JUST MOVE IT TO THE
SIDE FOR THE TIME BEING.
INVESTED BY OTHER STATES THIS
STARTED BACK IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS WHEN MANY OF OUR
IMPORT EXPORT COMPANIES BEGAN
TO LOOK AT WHAT THEY CALLED A
FOUR CORNER STRATEGY. OR POOR
DIVERSIFICATION STRATEGY TO DE
RISK HAVING ALL THEIR CARGO
GOING THROUGH ONE GATEWAY THE
END RESULT. WE LOST 20% OF OUR
MARKET SHARE SENSE THAT. AND ON
THEIR BEHALF THEY HIRED REALLY
SWITCHED ON PEOPLE THEY ALIGN
THEIR EFFORTS AT THE PORTS WITH
POLICY MAKERS AND LEGISLATORS.
AND EVEN FORMED REGIONAL
COALITIONS. IN ORDER TO GO TO
WASHINGTON. OUTLINED
LEGISLATION AND THEN
APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR THEIR
INVESTMENTS AND THEY'VE DONE A
TERRIFIC JOB I THINK WE COULD
PROBABLY TAKE A FEW CUES FROM
THOSE FOLKS. AGAIN IN
CALIFORNIA ALL OF US WHO WORK
EVERY DAY 30% OR IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND WE
ACCOUNT FOR. ABOUT A MILLION
JOBS HERE ALONE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OF THE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN ENVIRONMENTS THAT IT WAS
A TELEGRAPH THE PRESS WHEN.
MARIO AND I OUT THERE IN
WASHINGTON ON THE THIRTEENTH OF
OCTOBER TO MEET WITH HIM
CABINET MEMBERS AND OTHERS.
OTHER FOLKS IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
WORKING ON THE SAME SCHEDULE
WAREHOUSES TRADITIONALLY SAVE
THE REALLY BIG COMPANIES WORK
ON THE DAYSIDE. TRUCKERS ARE
MANDATED FEDERALLY TO WORK
ELEVEN HOURS A DAY IF THEY WERE
CONSECUTIVELY THEY MUST TAKE A
REST WE'VE GOT A TURN JUST
THOSE TWO JOBS INTO PROFESSIONS
AGAIN. MY GRANDPA WAS A TRUCK
DRIVER HE'S A PROUD TEAMSTER
WORKING FOR AMERICAN CAN
COMPANY IN NEW YORK CITY. WORK
FOR THEM FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED IN THIS
INDUSTRY YOU COULD START OFF AS
A BOX MOVERS WE CALL THEM IN A
WAREHOUSE WORK YOUR WAY UP TO
SUPERVISOR AND THEN ONE DAY YOU
COULD MANAGE THAT WAREHOUSE
WE'RE GONNA TURN THESE AROUND A
LITTLE BIT. AND IS RACHEL SAID
EARLIER THESE JOBS ARE PRETTY
GOOD PAYING THEY CAN CREATE
GOOD MIDDLE CLASS INCOMES BUT
WE GOT TO ATTRACT RECRUIT. AND
RETAIN FOLKS TO SEE WHAT THEY
COULD DO IN OUR INDUSTRY AND
LASTLY ON YOUR LAND LOCATIONS I
WOULD SAY TO STRATEGIC SITES
ONE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
BECAUSE A THIRD OF ALL OF OUR
CARGO ON THE IMPORT SIDE GOES
OUT TO THE I. E. FOR RE
HANDLING AND- DISTRIBUTION. THE
SECOND WOULD BE SOMEWHERE NEAR
THE PORTS OF LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH EVEN IF IT IS. IN
THE HIGHER LOW DESERT SO WE CAN
GET OUT THERE WILL HAVE A
SECURE ENVIRONMENT WOULD DATE
AROUND WHERE ALL THOSE CAPITAL
ASSETS ARE. AND WE COULD
RETRIEVE THEM QUICKLY. IF THERE
IS A THIRD DUE TO VOLUME NEEDS
IT ALSO SHOULD BE A DECENT
PROXIMITY LIKE A LOS ALAMEDA
US. TRAINING CO TRAINING
CENTER- JUST SOUTH OF THIS YEAR
THE PORT COMPLEX- BUT WHAT WE
HAVE NOW. ARE A NUMBER OF
HUNDREDS OF PARCELS STREWN
THROUGHOUT THE REGION AND IT'S
GONNA BE TOUGH TO COLLECT ALL
THOSE CONTAINERS AND CHASSIS IS
BRINGING A BACK. BUT ALSO AS
WELL AS WAS SAID BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON EARLIER. I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
SKILL SETS ON THOSE FACILITIES
ARE THEY HAVE THE PROPER
EQUIPMENT TO MOVE AROUND ALL
THOSE CONTAINERS WITH THEIR M.
TIER LADEN. AND THAT MAKES ME A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY. I THANK YOU
JEAN AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND MARIO FOR THE HOSPITALITY
YOU SHOWED ME WHEN I WAS THAT
WHEN I WAS VISITING IN TERMS OF
THE- 20% OF THE ALIGNMENT OF
THE HOURS AND YOU. MENTIONED
THAT THAT. THE STRUCTURAL
pTHE DAYSIDE AND THE REST
PERIODS ON ON THE ON THE- ON
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY- WHAT ARE
YOUR SUGGESTIONS IF YOU. HAVE
ANY TO TRY TO RE TO TRY TO
REALIGN THOSE. IF IT IF YOU
HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS. WHAT I
THINK THIS FORUM PROVIDES OF.
VENUE FOCAL POINT TO CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT THAT FRAMEWORK
BECAUSE AGAINST THE BODY THAT
WE HAVE TODAY- IS NOT TO GET
ANY LESS EVEN AFTER THIS CRISIS
I COULD REPRESENT YEAR THE-
VESSELS AT ANCHOR THAT'S GOOD
THAT'S GOING TO BE TRANSITORY
NATURE IN OTHER WORDS WE'LL GET
BACK TO SOME NORMALCY WILL
RETURN WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE ANY
THIS IS AN ANCHOR. LPO FIFTY
ONE FOR EVERYBODY- SHIPPING THE
STATE NO MATTER. WHERE YOU ARE
ON THE QUESTION OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE BUT WAS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY IS THAT TWENTY
MILLION NUMBER IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE FOR THE REASONS I HAVE
BEEN STATED HERE AT THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING SO SUFFICE TO
SAY THAT I THINK AGAIN. GOING
FORWARD IT IS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY CRITICAL- TO CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THE GATE OUR
OPERATIONS THE REASON WHY. AND
WHY I MADE THAT STATEMENT BACK
IN JERRY. TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF
THE LAST. PERSON TPM PUMP I WAS
HERE IN LONG BEACH IT'S- GOOD
ONE OF THE LAW. IN THE US. PORT
INDUSTRY. ACCOMPLICES HELD
ANNUALLY. BUT THE LOSS IN.
MEETING WAS IN. TWENTY
NINETEEN. ABOUT WE HAD A
DENTIST OF SOME OF THESE ISSUE
WERE JUST WHAT. AND REYES THIS
YEAR THE C. E. O. ONE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL. JEREMY NEXT. WAS
OUR AT THE BROUGH. OF CON OF
THE CARE THIS YEAR. WHY BOTTOM.
THERE'S A THERE'S A CALL TO SEE
IF AS TO WHY WE HIS SISTER. ONE
OF MY OLDER BAY IN TERMS WHAT
OCCURRED AFTER THE SPRING OF
TWO TWENTY BUT HIS ANSWER. OUR
LOOK PART OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR-
ABOUT FIRST. I COMPORTED. IT IS.
SO I THINK AGAIN- IT'S NOT
REINVENTING THE WHEEL WITH JUST
ONE FOUR SEVEN FRAMEWORK- GIVES
A STATE AS DOES REQUIRED TO
SUPPLY CHAIN TO MOVEMENT
DIRECTION SO I THINK AGAIN THE
FACT THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS A
ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT LOVE.
WHAT'S ARE KIND ACTION ASSISTED
OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS WHAT.
THAT WATER MAYBE CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF. A NEAR TERM METRICS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IN MY
VIEW. IT HER MORTARBOARD
ENGINEERS AND- SO WE WON'T GET
A SITUATION IT WILL BE A UNDER.
EVENT IN THE YEARS TO COME. I
DON'T KNOW HISTORY YOU THAT IN
SUCH. WE GET IN SCITUATE A LOT
OF. WE DO IS WE KNOW THE ANSWER
ARE AND WE NEED INSIST. BETTER
WHATEVER MAKE IN A FEW. WITH
REGARD TO. BOND I THINK MUCH
AND I AS A WANT TO THAT LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH MARIO AND
EUGENE- AND THE TO ME THOSE
INVESTMENTS- INSTANT OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN SO WE BEGIN TO MORE THIS
MARKET SHARE BY. THANK THANK
YOU US IS NO FURTHER. THANK YOU
TO- FOR YOUR PAGE FIRST- AND
YOU AND YOUR INFORMATION.
INSURING WITH US TODAY AND I
KNOW YOU'RE VERY BUSY. FOR MORE
BUSY THAN EVER. SO AGAIN- ON
BEHALF OF THIS COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU. WITH THAT WE NEED TO
OUR THANK YOU. JAMES ROGAN MARC
MARIO CORDERO GOOD GUYS- NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO ON TO- GOODS ARE
GOOD GOOD MOVEMENT INDUSTRY
LEADERS AND HOW THEY ARE
RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS. OUR
LAST PANEL DISCUSS HOW GOODS
MOVEMENT AND OTHER GOODS MOVING
INDUSTRY IT LEADERS ARE
RESPONDING TO CRISIS AND WHAT
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED FROM US
THAT ARE STRICTLY THEIR STATE
LEADERS. EACH PANELIST WELL
FIVE MINUTES IF YOU CAN CUT IT
DOWN A BIT THAT MIGHT BE GOOD
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ADDED AS
ANOTHER HEARING COMING IN THEY
HAVE TO CLEAN THE ROOM BUT I WE
DO WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU SO
PLEASE PROCEED ALREADY WILL
START WITH MIKE JACOB. VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL COUNSEL
OF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I DON'T SHARE
MEMBERS- I CHECK WITH CANNOT
SAY WE REPRESENT OCEAN CARRIERS
MY TERMINAL OPERATORS. CAN AND
WILL REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
INCLUDING. US IN THIS- BUT
HEARING TODAY AND- JUST GIVEN
THE TIME OF PURCHASE WORTH
THOUSAND WORDS I HAVE A COUPLE
SLIDES TO SHARE- AND I THINK-
WHAT WE WE'LL DO IS WE CAN OF
GOING THROUGH THE- ALL- THE
STAFF TO HAVE THOSE SENT AROUND
TO GO NUMBER. AND- IT JUST JUST.
CONSIDERING OF YOUR TIME- AND I
THINK THE BEST THING SAY IS
THAT- WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK AND THE PRESENTATION- BY
BURKE THE PORT COMMISSION. I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT THE FORTY
SECOND DIRECTORS- FROM LA LONG
BEACH AND OAKLAND. THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY FROM THE COMMENTS
TODAY ON A- THIS MICHELIN IN
THE STRIKING THE- ENTIRE SYSTEM
WORKS FOR THE BENEFIT OF CARGO
OWNERS- THEY ARE OUR ULTIMATE
CUSTOMERS EVERYONE HERE FROM
TODAY THAT'S A KERRIER NOTION
HERE REAL CARAMEL- CARRIER.
THERE ARE BRAND BUT FOR THEIR.
CUSTOMERS- WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE MOVING GOODS TO
THAT'S WHAT WE OBSERVE TO DO-
AND- TWO SIX THAT WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO DO THAT OPTIMALLY- IN
EVERY CASE- CERTAINLY THAT IS
THAT IS NOT OUR- INTENTION OF
NOT WHAT WE WANT TO BE DOING.
BUT OVERALL THE ENTIRETY OF THE
SYSTEM IF YOU LOOK AT LEAST
THAT THE LATEST NUMBERS WE
PUBLISH OUR WEST COAST TRIP
LAST MONTH BUT OUR OVERALL
TOTAL THROUGHPUT YOUR TO DATE
AT SAN PEDRO BAY- IS UP NEARLY
30% YEAR OVER YEAR. AND UP OVER
20% WHEN COMPARED TO PRE COATED
LEVELS IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THAT
IS SIGNIFICANT- AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT REALLY MEANS THAT
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO IS
FACILITATE THOSE CHANGES IN THE
MARKET PLACE THAT- EXACT
DIRECTOR SOROKA WAS TALKING
ABOUT. GIVING GLOBAL DYNAMICS
AND IN DEMAND FOR GOODS- AND
THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE REST
OF THE- THE IMAGES THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH- ARE WAITING
AMY IN OAKLAND. ALSO REALLY
TREMENDOUS AND SO BUT- WHY NAME
HIM. WHEN YOU COMPARE BACK TO
NINETEEN- WAS MOVE- OVER 50%
MORE GOODS WHEN YOU COMPARE TO
TWENTY NINETEEN CLOSE TO A 100%
MORE IN TERMS OF TOTAL WORK.
LOADS TURNED THEIR THEIR
SYSTEMS ARE JUST TREMENDOUS
NUMBERS- BUT WHERE WE SEE THE
STRAIN. AND WHERE ARE THE
PLACES WHERE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE FOCUSED OUR-
ATTENTION AFTER THIS HEARING
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS. IS
ON PRODUCING TWELVE TIMES- AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE
LOTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO SKIN
THIS CAT LOTS OF APPROACHES
THERE MIGHT BE SOME CONTROVERSY
OVER SOME OF THOSE INCLUDING
THOSE EXCESSIVE DWELL TIME
FEES- BUT OUR TOTAL DWELL TIME
ON TERMINAL. RECODED ARE WE'RE
AVERAING ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN
DAYS- AND NOW WE'RE UP BY CLOSE
TO SIX DAYS- AND SO WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT DOUBLING AND THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF ACTUAL SPACE
AND TIME THAT IS USING THE
CAPACITY SO. NOT ONLY REMOVING
30% MORE CARGO. BUT THE CARGO
THAT WERE MOVING ON AVERAGE
SITS LONGER BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS COMPOUND THEY TAKE MORE
TIME AWAY FROM OUR ABILITY TO
MOVE THE CLOCK THE SYSTEM AS WE
HEARD. I WITH RESPECT TO- THOSE
CONTAINERS MULLIN WAS
SIGNIFICANT WHILE TIME. OR IN
FIVE DAYS YOUR AVERAGE OF THOSE
CONTAINERS PRETTY COVE IT WAS
ABOUT 6% OF THE CONTAINER
SOPHOMORE IN FIVE DAYS. NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MORE THAN
30% OF OUR OUR PARTY ON
TERMINAL. ARE TAKING OVER FIVE
DAYS TO MOVE AND THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT AND THEN LASTLY
BEFORE I TURN IT BACK OVER AND
WE HEAR FROM. OUR PARTNERS IN
LABOR MISTER POSITIVELY ON
TALKING ABOUT THE EFFORTS ARE
W. IS MAKING TO MOVE THAT
POSITIONAL CARGO THAT
ADDITIONAL THIRTY PERCENT. I DO
WANT TO ADDRESS THE- EXPORTING
JEEZ QUESTION- AND OBVIOUSLY
THE- IMPORTANCE OF EMPTIES
BEING LOADED VERSUS- BUT-
EXPERTS. BEING LOADED HER ZACKS
WAS BEING- EMPTY ARE DIFFERENT
FOR NORTHERN CAL. SOME CAL.
DRAMATICALLY AND WE NEED- WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH OUR PART IN
THAT IN THIS TO MAKE THAT WE
ARE FACILITATING A MUCH MORE.
BACKS CARGO POSS. BUT WE ALL
HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE SHOW TERM.
WITH RESPECT TO- AND IN TWO.
OUT OF SUFFOLK. BECAUSE THEIR
CALL ARE SAID. AND I JUST
APPOINT THAT IN SAN PEDRO BAY-
OUR RECORDS FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS HAVE BEEN MOVING UP
AND UP AND UP BUT EXPORTED DISS
PERCENTAGE. BUT SO FAR YEAR TO
DATE- THROUGH SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ARE EXPORTED TESE
WERE ALREADY HIGHER THAN
THEY'VE BEEN AT ANY OTHER POINT
IN TIME- AND IF WE- PROJECT
THOSE FURTHER THROUGH THE END
OF THE YEAR WILL BE OVER SEVEN
MILLION- T. ISN'T EMPTY SO.
WE'RE MOVING MORE SHIPS THAN
EVER WE HAVE MORE MINOR
SERVICING NUMBER SHIP SIZES
GOING DOWN BUT WE ARE WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY TO. ROUTE
EVERYTHING SHIP LOADED- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME- AND I
APPRECIATE THE- COMMENTS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER JACOB WILL
MOVE ON TO. REMOTE PONCE DALY.
HE IS A PRESS I'LL THIRD-
MISSED POSITIVELY ON YOU MAY
FOR ON RIGHT. YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE ON THE PHONE. YOU HEAR ME.
ALWAYS SHE LIVES. RIGHT THANK-
THANK YOU- JOE DONNELLY AND
COACH OF GETS YEAH- IT'S
HORRIBLE THING YOU FOR US TO BE
UP OF THE SO. ALL ON STATE SEPT
ON UP AT PORTS IN MOVED- BEFORE
I GO ANY. ONE OF THE THINGS A
RED FOR WE HAVE TO CARE OF IN
JUST THAT'S SOME I MEAN THEY
GOT TO BE IN FOEMOST- THAT'S
IMPORTANT NEED TO HAVE SOME
SHIPS TO CALL OAKLAND AND TO
HELP THEM WITH THE EXPORTS. BOB
ALL I COULD THINK THE OUTDOOR.
THEY AYE ALTHOUGH USED THAT
WOULD THE PARTS OF ALONG BEACH
THE CASF WORK FOR. AND THE POOR
TRUCK UP WHO ARE COLLECTED
BLOKE RECORDS A STATE BEFORE.
TRY TO GO TO THIS BRIEF. YEAH
WE WORK TO CALL WE HAVE. SIX
PRO WORK AMIDST TWENTY DEATHS
WE'VE HAD. A STUDENTS CALLED-
AND- NEVER THE HISTORY HAVE
HAVE WE- RECORDS IN HAS LAID
OUT WELL SIMPLE. UP WHAT IS. SB
UNDER. IS HAVE OVER HALF A
CENTURY MAYBE LONGER OF A- THAT
ALLOWS FOR THREE D. SHIP BY
CHEF SECONDS AND THIRD SHIFT SO
WHEN THEY US WE WERE PURCHASE
STATE SOME CONTRACT- YEAH TO
HAVE THE ORDER IT. OKAY AND
WHAT'S THE EMPLOYERS ARE FOR A
OUT OF. I WE DO HAVE TO
DIFFERENT STARTS ON THE FIRST
STARTED OUT SO- DIFFERENT TIMES
STARTS THE SECOND SHIFT START
AT. FOUR AND IN THE- THIRD
SHIFT IS UP TO IBM INTO. SO WE
REALLY HAVEN'T MAYBE A DOWNTURN
UP FOR HOURS. SO IN THE THIRD
SHIFT WE COULD PROBABLY SOME
KIND. SOME RARE WORK IT'S
DELIVER. AND THAT WOULD BE
CALLED- CHECK. NOW I WANT TO
GET INTO ISSUE AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS. THAT THAT WE NEED
TO BE PATIENT OUT THERE AND WE
DO. FEEL THAT THE TRUCK
OPERATOR HAVING TO SIT THE LINE
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHEN WE TAKE OUT CARGO FROM THE
BAY. AND DELIVERED TO A TRUCK-
WE MIGHT HAVE TO GET TO THE
SIX. ROLLBACK BOB CAN HAVE TO
DIG CANS OUT GET TO THE
CONTAINER DELIVER IT BUT THE
CANS BACK. AND THEN THIS
PROCESS CONTINUES AND AS IT
EMPTIES OUT IT'S QUICKER. BUT
WHAT HAPPENS BECAUSE OF THESE
CONGESTION THE SHIP COMES
BEHIND US. AND THAT UNIT PUTS
THE COMPUTERS BACK TO FULL
CAPACITY SO WERE CRACKED. OKAY
SO. KNOWING THAT- THAT HAS TO
BE UNDERSTOOD THROUGHOUT THE
INDUSTRY. NOW THERE'S THREE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE HAD AND MOST
OF ITS READY TALK TALK ABOUT.
THE SHORT TERM SOLUTION IS
BEING WORKED ON WITH THAT. WHAT
THE CURRENT WITH UP. ON VIæT.
UP ENVOY AT JUMBLE CARI AND- IS.
TASK FORCE. JEFF AND UP TO PORT.
YOUR ALONG WITH OUR- ACOSTA
INTERFACE PASSED ALONG TO ME
WITH THEM TO NEED TO DAYS A- SO
THERE. ON CONTINUAL- THEY DID
TALK ABOUT. THE SOLUTION ABOUT
HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE SO I WILL
GET INTO THAT. AND I WANT TO
THANK BOTH PORT COMMISSIONERS.
A MARIO CORDERO AND ANGIE
SOROKA FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
AND TAKING ON THE TASK AND- AND
PUTTING THAT THE CARRIERS TO
TASK A LITTLE BIT SINCE THEY'VE
GONE. AND RECORDED PUBLICLY
POINT FIVE BILLION IN PROFITS.
THAT DOESN'T COME BACK INTO OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE NOR INTO OUR
ECONOMY. SO THAT WAS A PLUS.
AND THAT IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
STINK THEIR AMERICAN. SUMER AND
THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT WHY SAID THE
AGRICULTURE. WE NEED TO HAVE-
THAT SOULS- TO EXPORT OUR- AT
UP THERE IN THEN SAVE OUR OUR
FORMER INDUSTRY. AND THE MID
TERMSOLUTION- JUST. SB
COSCO'S- WAREHOUSE SLASH RETAIL
STORE. THE CONTAINER IS
WAREHOUSE. SO WE ARE. TOLD
MAKES WITH NEW CAR. ON THE
FIRST. REPORTS THIS TERM IS TO
GET SOME GLASS. AND TO MOVE
THIS CAR WILL HOW THAT HAPPENS
IS THE- US. WE CONTAINABLE.
WE'VE ALREADY PRO WE CAN THAT
FAST AND IF. AND YOU KEEP THE
STAFF. AS A GROUP FACILITY THAN
AS THIS. OR IN. OF MOVING CAR.
OKAY NOW IF YOU TALK ABOUT IT.
AUTONOMY THAT IS WE GET BECAUSE
THAT IS. ON TRY DELIVER WE
AFFORD A TRY. ARE WE NEED TO
MOVE TO RAILS. SO WE CAN GET
THE- FIVE MILLION KEYS- MILLION
TEENS. THAT HELLO BE THE
GATEWAY. WE CAN GO FORTY. TO
PER. ON DOT RAIL LAW TERM IS
THIS A LOW. WE CAN LOAD UP ON
DOCK RAIL THREE HUNDRED MOVES
WITH TWO UNITS FIVE. IT'S ON
THE RAIL WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS
THAT A RAIL. BUT IT TO A
DISTRIBUTION CENTER CLOSE TO
WHETHER FULFILLMENT AND
DISTRIBUTION AREAS ARE
OFFLOADED THERE BUT THE CAR WAS
THERE. WE NEED TO BE TRUE BUT-
IF YOU GO TO AUTOMATION IS
ACTUALLY FOR DENSITY DENSITIES
EIGHT NINE NINE IMAGINE TAKING.
NINE I FOR THEM THE DAILY TO
ALTER. ALONG WITH LINES BE. WE
WILL THE CAR GO FASTER WE THE
POST IN THE- DIALED. AS SECOND
TO NONE WE WILL CAR THAT'S WHY
IT'S HERE IT'S ON THE BALLOT.
WE ARE GATEWAY. CONTINUE TO
MAKE WHAT NEED WE NEED TO DO.
IN OUR CONTRACT DR THE LAST I
WANT TO SAY CHAD. THEY AND I AT
THE WORKING TOGETHER. CLOSELY
WITH EXTRA. FREIGHT OPERATORS
FROM DELIVERY PURPOSE ONLY TO
HER FIFTH WITHIN A NINETY DAYS
WE'VE ALREADY HAPPENED TO A
SYSTEM AND NOW WORKED WITH
CONTINUED. WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT MORE IDEAS TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS CARGO.
MAKE ANY PATIENT WE ARE THE
LABOR FORCE AND IF YOU DO NOT
AS WELL MAKING. IT JUST AS WE
NEED TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ON RAMON PASEO- FOR YOUR
PASSION FIRST OF ALL YES- YOUR
EDUCATION ALSO I YOU
HIGHLIGHTED ANOTHER RICOTTA.
BUT YOU'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
MANAGEMENT HERE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM TO AND TAKE CARE OF THE
OVERALL HEALTH OF THE PORT. SO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT WE'RE
NEXT GOING TO GO ON TO A ONE
ACOSTA. REGIONAL VICE REGIONAL
ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT FROM
BEING US UP THAT'S THE REAL
WAY- ONE ACOSTA. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND-
CHAIRMAN GONZALEZ APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
OTHER COMMITTEE TODAY. ABOUT
BNSF'S PERFORMANCE- DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIME I'VE BEEN
WITH THE ROAD NOW TWENTY ONE
YEARS SO THIS IS THE- UNUSUAL
OF TO SAY THE LEAST- WHAT IS
BEEN SAID ABOUT. HOW WE GOT
HERE- THERE ARE SOME FOLKS WHO
HAVE SUGGESTED THAT THE
PANDEMIC EXPOSED A WEAKNESS IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN OR THE SUPPLY
CHAIN WAS ALREADY SHOWING THAT
WEAKNESS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC-
BUT I THINK THE LOW DWELL TIME
TWO DAYS AND RAILYARDS STUFF
VERY FEW SHIPS AT ANCHOR. AT
THE PORTS OF LA AND LONG BEACH
SUGGESTS THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
WASN'T BROKEN WHAT WE'VE DONE
THOUGH- THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
AND POST PENDENTIVES YOU KNOW
AFTER SHUTTING OFF. THE GLOBAL
COMMERCE ENGINE WE ARE WE BOTH
AT THE MANUFACTURING COMPONENT
OF SUPPLY CHAIN AS WELL AS THE
DELIVERY COMPONENT I WE'VE
REPLACED THAT OLD MACHINE WHICH
HAS BEEN SIXTY YEARS IN THE
MAKING IT STARTED BACK IN THE
MID FIFTIES WITH MALCOLM
MACLEAN'S INNOVATION. OF THE
SEABORNE CONTAINER AND IT'S
GROWN SINCE THEN BUT WE ARE WE
ARE WE ARE NOW RETOOLING OR
REBUILDING THAT MACHINE ON THE
FLY AND IS DRIVEN BY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN CONSUMER
EXPENDITURES YOU KNOW MORE
GOODS AND SERVICES MORE ONLINE
THAN IN STORE- AND WE ALSO SAW
IN THE EARLY PORTION THE
PANDEMIC. INVENTORIES DROP
SIGNIFICANTLY BY THE SPRING AND
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INVENTORIES NATIONALLY AMONG
RETAILERS READ ON ONE MONTH
LEFT. SO VERY LOW INVENTORIES
AND THEN THERE WAS THE BIG PUSH
THE BIG PUSH TO RESTOCK AND TO
PURCHASE AHEAD OF- THE
CHRISTMAS SEASON AND TO
ANTICIPATE A MANUFACTURING-
SHORTFALL SO- WE WENT FROM A
JUST IN TIME DELIVERY SYSTEM.
TO ADJUSTING CASE DELIVERY
SYSTEM SO A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN IN VOLUMES THAT YOU SEE AT
THE PORT SENATE THE RAILYARDS-
THROUGH AUGUST OF TWENTY ONE
BNSF MOVED MORE CONTAINERS-
THROUGH OUR- INTERMODAL YARDS
AT THE SAME POINT. IN THAT THE
SAME POINT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH WAS THE PREVIOUS RECORD
YEAR. BOB SO WHEN YOU WON'T
LET'S TALK ABOUT RAIL
INTERMODAL. THEY THEY ARE ALL A
THROUGH- VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
MR CONSTANTLY ON SAID ABOUT THE
PORTS WE ARE ALL ABOUT
THROUGHPUT WE ARE NOT DESIGNED
OR BUILT. FOR LONG ERM
STORAGE- SO IF THE ENGAGED
EXCEEDS ADVOCATING OF
CONTAINERS. OF THE RESULT IS
CONGESTION AND THE MORE
CONGESTION YOU HAVE- THE MORE
THAT CONGESTION AND BACKS UP IN
THE MAIN LINES OF CURRENTLY AT
ANY GIVEN POINT- DURING THIS
WEEK WE WILL HAVE THIRTY
TRAINS. WAITING TO ENTER
WAITING TO UNLOAD AT DIFFERENT
INTERMODAL YARDS- AROUND THE
COUNTRY- SO IT'S ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED CONTAINERS ON ON
ANY GIVEN DAY- AND THAT.
OBVIOUSLY IS GOING TO WORSEN
THE SITUATION THEY WERE FACED
WITH CONTAINERS AND CHASSIS. SO
WHILE WE'RE ON PACE FOR A
RECORD VOLUMES- INTERNATIONAL
CONTAINERS DWELT IN OUR YARDS
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN UNLOADED 30%
MORE THAN THEY DID IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- SO.
THE MORPH WE HAVE COMING IN-
THE LESS AND IT'S PICKED UP YOU
KNOW YOU YOU'VE GOT THAT THAT'S
THAT'S NOT A SUSTAINABLE
FORMULA- NOW GENERALLY SPEAKING
FROM END TO END THERE IS ENOUGH
CAPACITY. IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN-
BUT ONLY IF. THERE'S TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN OPERATIONS AND ONLY
IF EACH COMPONENT OF THE
PIPELINE WORKS NOW I SAY THIS
WITH ONE NOTABLE EXCEPTION AND
THAT IS THE ONLY BASE. THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT CAPACITY AND
YOU'VE HEARD PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
WAREHOUSING SAME IS TRUE OF
RAIL CAPACITY WE WE'D LOVE TO
MOVE MORE ON DOCK RAIL ON THE
RAILROAD BUT YOU HAVE TO LAND
THAT FREIGHT SOMEPLACE. IN
CALIFORNIA EITHER IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THANK- ALL. UP IN UP IN
THE HIGH DESERT- YOU YOU YOU
HAVE TO HAVE FACILITIES THAT
CAN HANDLE ON DOCK RAIL SO
YOU'VE GOT BLOCKS WHAT
FACILITIES PERHAPS IN PLACES
LIKE BARSTOW HIGH DESERT. ON
THE ON THE BE IN A SENTENCE- I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION'S A
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATIONS
PARTNERSHIP WITH- THE U. S. D.
O. T. ON BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT LAST WEEK BOB HAS
A LOT OF POTENTIAL BUT I BUT
MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE OF. OF
THE POSTER CHILD FOR THE
INABILITY TO BUILD ANYTHING OF
SIGNIFICANCE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S A STATE
PROJECT THAT WE WERE GOING TO.
BUILD WITH THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AS A PARTNERI STARTED
WORKING ON A PROJECT WHEN MY
DAUGHTER WAS IN DIAPERS SHE IS
A TWENTY YEAR OLD SOPHOMORE
THIS YEAR IN COLLEGE. WE STILL
HAVEN'T BUILT IT WE IT TOOK US
UP ALMOST- TEN YEARS TO GET A
PERMIT WE GOT A PERMIT FROM THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE WERE
SUED AND- WE ULTIMATELY.
PREVAILED ON APPEAL BUT WE'RE
BACK TO. BOXES ACTUALLY
AVAILABLE TO THE CUSTOMER FOR
PICK UP AND THE CUSTOMER IS
NOTIFIED SO- TYPICALLY
DEPENDING ON THE FACILITY HAVE
ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY FOUR TO
FORTY EIGHT HOURS OF FREE TIME-
BEFORE AY STORAGE FEES ACCRUE.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY ADD ANOTHER
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND TO THAT
DEPENDING ON WHEN THE CUSTOMERS
NOTIFIED BECAUSE WE TYPICALLY
DON'T START THE CLOCK UNTIL.
ONE DAY AFTER THE CUSTOMER'S
BEEN NOTIFIED SO DO YOU YOU
COULD HAVE ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO
REALLY THREE DAYS OF STORAGE OF
FREE TIME STORAGE. WE ON THE ON
THE FLIP SIDE OF THE STORAGE
FEE WE PROVIDE CREDITS WE ALLOW
OR- AWARD- CUSTOMERS CREDIT
SICKENING CREDITS FOR BOXES
THAT ARE OUTDATED. ON ON A
HOLIDAY OR ON THE WEEKEND WE
DONE THAT NOT ONLY AT THE PORTS
OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH
WE'VE DONE IT. EITHER ANOTHER
FACILITIES IN THEM LIKE THE-
THE MAJOR FACILITY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN CHICAGO L. P. C. O. I
THINK GOD'S BEAUTY MYERS
MENTION THAT WE OFFER A FIFTY
DOLLAR BOX. CREDIT FOR
CUSTOMERS AS WELL WHO DELIVER
BOXES OR PICK UP BOXES ON THE
WEEKEND- A MAJOR COMPONENT OF
WHAT WE DO WITH OUR CUSTOMERS
IS- VISIBILITY INTO THEIR
FREIGHT VISIBILITY INTO OUR
OPERATIONS SO PROVIDING
CUSTOMERS WITH THAT INFORMATION
IS. IS CRITICAL WHEN WHAT'S KEY
HERE IS REAL TIME COMMUNICATION
REAL TIME INFORMATION SO WE
HAVE DEVELOPED TECHNOLOGY
CALLED THE APPLICATION
PROGRAMMING INTERFACES IT'S
SIMPLY AN APPLICATION IT BUT
IT'S AN APPLICATION THAT ALLOWS
OUR CUSTOMERS TO OBTAIN EITHER
PUSH NOTIFICATIONS OR TO PULL
INFORMATION FROM OUR SYSTEM. AS
THEY WISH AS THEY WAT
CONCERNING OF THE TRAIN
ARRIVALS DEPARTURES ON A REAL
TIME BASIS THE STATUS OF THEIR
FREIGHT- PRICING- WAYBILL
INFORMATION- THIS THIS ALLOWS
THEM TO DO ANALYTICS ALLOWS
THEM TO MANAGE THEIR SERVICE
THEIR THEIR OPERATIONS THEIR
PICKUPS- IN IN A WAY THAT- I
THINK WILL HELP- NOT ONLY IN
THIS. SITUATION BUT IN THE
FUTURE AS WELL AND THAT'S
SOMETHING A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT TODAY'S
INFORMATION SHARING ARM WOULD
DO A LOT OF INNOVATION NOW
WE'VE WE'VE HAD TO BE VERY
RESOURCEFUL SO FOR EXAMPLE AT
OUR BIG CHICAGO FACILITY THE
LPC- WE'VE WE'VE CREATED MORE
STORAGE CAPACITY. WE TOOK. TO
EIGHT THOUSAND FOOT- TRACKS.
TOOK THEM OUT OF OUT OF SERVICE
IN THE YARD AND WE LAID THE
HOUND SPECIALLY MANUFACTURED
MATS OVER THE TRACKS TO ALLOW
FOR STACKING AND D. RAMPING
CUSTOMER BOXES NOW. THAT'S
INCREASED THE STORAGE CAPACITY
THAT YOU ARE BY ROUGHLY THE
EQUIVALENT OF TEN TRAINS TEN
INTERMODAL TRAINS BUT THAT
COMES AT A COST AND ONLY THE
EXPENSE OF. MANUFACTURING AND
INSTALLING THOSE SPECIALIZED
MATS BUT IT REDUCES YOUR
PRODUCTION SO YOU KNOW WHICH IT
IS A SHORT TERM BANDAID
SOLUTION- TO CREATE MORE
STORAGE CAPACITY- BNSF HAS
ESTABLISHED SEVERAL IN SEVERAL
LOCATIONS OFFSITE TRADES
PROGRAMS. IN TEXAS KANSAS CITY
MEMPHIS- THE BACKEND OF THESE
CONTAINER MOVES OUT OF
CALIFORNIA- WE ACTUALLY PAY OUR
OWN IN OUR OWN POCKET. THIS IS
AT OUR EXPENSE WE DRAPED ALONG
THE WELLING CONTAINERS TO OFF
SITE LOTS- WE'VE OPENED A NEW
INTERMODAL TERMINAL IN MEMPHIS
JUST IN RESPONSE TO THE
PRESSURES AND RELIEF PRESSURES-
IN PLACES LIKE CHICAGO AND THE-
THE DALLAS FORT WORTH ALLIANCE-
INTERMODAL FACILITIES. SO ALL
THESE BACK IN CHALLENGES THAT
THE WILL ROADS- HAVE TO FACE
AN- ARC ARE DRIVEN BY FRONT AND
DECISIONS AND NEVER REALLY
INCLUDES. THE CONTINUING ORDER
OF FREIGHT SHIPMENTS WITHOUT
THE RESOURCES TO MOVE THE
CONTAINERS BEYOND THE RAILYARDS
THAT'S GETTING BACK TO THE TO
THE PHRASE I USED BEFORE WE
MOVE FROM JUST IN TIME DELIVERY
TOO JUST. IN CASE A LIVERY- SO
WE WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF OTHER
SUGGEST HERE I THINK A
PRACTICAL ONE- BUT WHY NOT A
JOINT OPERATIONS CENTER WITH
YOU KNOW THE SUMMIT APPROACHES
IS USEFUL TO ERRING OUT LARGE.
HAVING LARGE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
BIG ISSUES BUT BUT ON A DAY TO
DAY BLOCKING AND TACKLING-
ASPECT OF THIS OF SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM A JOINT OPERATIONS
CENTER- MAKES AN AWFUL LOT OF
SENSE WITH SOMETHING THAT THE
RAILROAD USE IN CHICAGO. WHEN
WE HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THE
POLAR VORTEX WE'VE GOT YOU
KNOW- CRIPPLING WEATHER AND-
GET EACH OF THE STAKEHOLDERS OR
THE RAILROADS IN THAT CASE IN
CHICAGO BUT EACH OF THE MAJOR
STAKEHOLDERS. IN THE SAME
OPERATIONS CENTER SO THEY CAN
HAVE GREATER VISIBILITY. EASIER
COMMUNICATION FACILITATE
RESPONSES TO PROBLEMS AS AS
THEY COME UP AND THAT OUGHT TO
BE SOMETHING WE DO ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND THEN. HERE IN FORT
WORTH WE HAVEN'T- NETWORK
OPERATIONS CENTER WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE UNION
PACIFIC WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM AMTRAK- WE
HAVE THE MARKETING FOLKS IN THE
SAME PLACE AS THE DISPATCHING.
OF PERSONNEL AND IN THAT IT
DOES HELP COMMUNICATIONS THAT
DOES HELP WITH PROBLEM SOLVING
ON A ON A REAL TIME BASIS- I
WOULD NOTE THAT THERE ARE TWO.
THINGS IN THE MARKETPLACE THAT
ARE HAPPENING THAT WILL HAVE
SOME EFFECT HERE ONE IS OF THE
DOMESTIC CONTAINERS IN THE
GREATER UTILIZATION OF DOMESTIC
CONTAINERS- WELL. THESE THE
INTERNATIONAL CONTAINERS CAN BE
TRADE TO- A LOCAL FACILITY
WHERE THERE OTHERS TRANSLOAD
INTO DOMESTIC CONTAINERS LARGER
CONTAINERS FORTY EIGHT FIFTY
THREE FOOT MORE SAYING. THE USE
OF DOMESTIC CONTAINERS
INCREASE- THAT FREES UP
INTERNATIONAL CONTAINERS
QUICKLY AND ALLOWS THEM TO GET
BACK TO ASIA- BUT BUT- BUT
LASTLY I WOULD SUGGEST THAT-
WE'RE GONNA SEE ANALYZE. TO SEE
IS- CONSUMERS. DRIVING THE
SOLUTION IN A SENSE- RECENT
SURVEYS SAY THAT 80% OF
CONSUMERS FOR GIFT CARDS OVER
PHYSICAL GIFTS THIS YEAR. 25%
OF THOSE FOLKS- SITE PROBLEMS
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN. WE'RE
WE'RE FOR THAT PREFERENCE.
DAHLE LEAVE YOU WITH THAT.
THANK YOU SIR I WILL THAT WILL
GO TO CHRISTIAN MOTOR SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION MR SHIMON. THANK
YOU CHAIRED ON ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
CHRISTIAN MOTOR WITH CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY AND I DO HAVE
SOME SLIDES. WE NEED FOR THOSE
THE GO UP. RIGHT SECOND SLIDE
PLEASE. K. TO GET AT THE ROOT
CAUSES OF CONGESTION AT THE
PORTS OF LA AND LONG BEACH IT'S
HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND THE LIFE
CYCLE OF HOW THINGS WORK UNDER
NORMAL NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES THE
CONTAINERS JEFF DISCHARGE FROM
THE STEAM SHIP ONTO A MARINE
TERMINAL THE CARGO OWNERS
NOTIFIED THAT THE CONTAINERS
AVAILABLE THE CARD OWNER ONLY
HAS SO MANY DAYS TO RETRIEVE OR
BE READY TO RECEIVE A CONTAINER
BEFORE A LATE FEE CALLED THE
MERGE IS ASSESSED. A TRUCKER
EITHER CONTRACTED WITH THE
STEAMSHIP LINE OR BY THE CARGO
OWNER ENTERS THE MARINE
TERMINAL TO PICK UP THE
CONTAINER WE SEE ON THAT
PICTURE RIGHT THERE IS A-
CONTAINER BEING DROPPED ONTO A
CRITICAL PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
CALLED THE CHASSIS THESE ARE
REQUIRED TO MOVE THE CONTAINER
BECAUSE SHIPPING CONTAINERS DO
NOT HAVE WHEELS THEMSELVES FOR
LAND TRANSPORT. THE TRUCKER
TRANSPORTS THE CONTAINER ON THE
CHASSIS TO THE CARGO OWNER
FACILITY CONTAINERS UNLOADED
AND RETURNED TO EITHER THE
MARINE TERMINAL OR AN OFF DOCK
CONTAINER CONTAINER TERMINATION
POINT AS DIRECTED BY THE
CONTAINER PROVIDER THE EMPTY
CONTAINER MUST BE RETURNED IN A
SET NUMBER OF DAYS OR A LATE
FEE CALLED THE TENSION OR PER
DIEM IS ASSESSED TO THE CARGO
OWNER. IN ORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS PROCESS
INCLUDING THE FEES ARE DESIGNED
TO ENCOURAGE FLUIDITY OF
CONTAINER MOVEMENT WITHIN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN- NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SO WHAT INTERRUPTED THIS
FLUIDITY- AS DIRECTOR SOROKIN
MISTER JACOBS DID POINT OUT THE
PORTS ARE MOVING MORE EMPLOYEES
THAN EVER THAT IS TRUE BUT ALSO
TAKING IN MORE IMPORTS THAN
EVER. DATA FROM THE PORTS
INDICATE FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE THOUSAND MORE NET IMPORTS
ARRIVED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THIS YEAR VERSUS LAST YEAR.
THIS HIGHER THAN TYPICAL DEMAND
FOR IMPORTS HAS RESULTED IN AN
ACCESS OF EMPTY CONTAINERS IN
AND AROUND THE PORTS. AS
IMPORTS ARE BROUGHT IN AT A
FASTER RATE THAN EMPTY
CONTAINERS OR OR LOADED EXPORTS
FOR THAT MATTER EVACUATED. I
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THIS CRUSH
OF EMPTY CONTAINERS DECIDED BY
OUR MEMBERSHIP AS THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE PREVENTING FLUIDITY
OF CONTAINER MOVEMENTS IN THE
PORT COMPLEX. MARINE TERMINALS
ARE CONGESTED TO THE POINT THAT
MANY CANNOT ACCEPT EMPTY
CONTAINERS FROM TRUCKERS. THESE
CONTAINERS ARE BACKING UP A
TRUCKER- TRUCKING FACILITIES
AND TYING UP CRITICAL CHASSIS
IS. WITHOUT CHASSIS IS NEITHER
IMPORT OR EXPORT CONTAINERS CAN
MOVE BY LAND. A SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND HARBOR
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION OF JUST
FIFTY TRUCKING COMPANIES.
SERVICING THE PORTS FOUND THAT
THESE COMPANIES ARE HOLDING AN
ESTIMATED NINE THOUSAND EMPTY
CONTAINERS. 79% OF WHICH ARE
SITTING ON CHASTITY'S. WHILE
THE SURVEY COVERED LESS THAN 6%
OF THE TRUCKING COMPANIES
AUTHORIZED TO OPERATE AT THE
PORTS. CHASSIS IS EQUIVALENT TO
ABOUT 13% OF THE PORT'S LARGEST
CHASSIS POOLS. ARE SITTING
UNDER EMPTY CONTAINERS AT THEIR
YARDS. THERE ARE LIKELY
THOUSANDS OF OTHER CHASSIS
STOCK OTHER AND UNDER EMPTIES.
THESE EMPTY CONTAINER STILL
ACCRUE LATE CHARGES WHICH AS MR
ISOM NOTED HENCE PRESENTATION
CAN BE EXORBITANT. DESPITE
BEING STRANDED OUTSIDE THE
MARINE TERMINALS UNABLE TO BE
RETURNED FURTHER INFLATING
COSTS TO CONSUMERS NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. THIS ALSO HAS A DIRECT
IMPACT ON TERMINAL PRODUCTIVITY
THIS IS A SCREEN GRAB FROM THE
WEBSITE OF THE MARINE TERMINAL
OPERATOR. AS YOU CAN SEE THEY
ARE NOT ACCEPTING EMPTY
CONTAINERS FROM NAME MAJORITY
OF EQUIPMENT PROVIDERS BECAUSE
THE TERMINAL IS ALREADY
CONGESTED AND THEY NEED SPACE
TO UNLOAD SHIPS. THERE ARE ALSO
CRITICALLY LOW ON CHASSIS IS
WHICH MEANS THE TERMINAL CANNOT
BE CLEARED OF IMPORTS. THE MORE
CHANCES CANNOT BE FREED UP
UNTIL EMPTY CONTAINERS ARE
ACCEPTED BY TERMINALS- OFF DOCK
TERMINATION POINTS. THIS
DYNAMIC HAS CREATED A NEGATIVE
FEEDBACK LOOP THAT IS WORSENING
CONGESTION. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
IN THE NEAR TERM THE FASTEST
SOLUTION TO FIXING THE
SITUATION IS FOR EMPTY
CONTAINERS TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE PORTS BY WHAT'S CALLED
SWEEPER VESSELS AND THERE ARE
SOME EXAMPLES- THERE OF TIMES
WHERE THIS IS BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST TO CLEAR. AYE CONGESTED
MARINE GATEWAYS THIS IS TYPICAL
PRACTICE ONE MARINE TERMINALS
EXPERIENCE GRIDLOCK- I'M ALSO
HEARING FROM MEMBERS TYPICAL-
AFTER PEAK SEASON. WE ENCOURAGE
POLICY MAKERS AT ALL LEVELS TO
CALL ON STEAMSHIP LINES TO
BRING SWEEPER VESSELS TO CLEAR
INTO CONTAINERS. I'M IN THE MID
TERM ALSO FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
SUPPLY CHAIN EXECUTIVE ORDER
STATE AND LOCAL LAND IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO THE PORT SHOULD BE
USED FOR EMPTY CONTAINER
TERMINATION POINTS. WERE
CONTAINERS CAN BE REMOVED FROM
CHASTITY'S AND THE CLOCK ON
LATE FEES CAN STOP. THIS WILL
REDUCE COSTS IMPACTS FROM PORT
GRIDLOCK AND RESTORE FLUIDITY
TO INLAND CONTAINER MOVEMENT BY
FREEING UP CRITICAL CHASTITY'S.
ONCE EMPTY CONTAINERS ARE
EVACUATED IN CHASSIS
AVAILABILITY IS RESTORED THE
STATE SHOULD CONSIDER WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
A REASONABLE FEDERAL HOURS OF
SERVICE FLEXIBILITY. TO ENSURE
THAT AVAILABLE GATE HOURS CAN
BE UTILIZED- NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
AND TO CLOSE I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THE EMPTY
CONTAINER ISSUE MUST BE
ADDRESSED TO RESTORE THE FLOW
OF GOODS AT THE PORT. AND THIS
IS ALSO CRITICAL FOR OUR OUR
FOLKS WHO CARE ABOUT EXPORTS
WITHOUT THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GATEWAYS BEING CLEARED THE
NORMAL VESSEL CALLS ARE NOT
GOING TO RESUME- BUT WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THE
LARGER ISSUE THAT I THINK IT'S
BEEN SAID. A COUPLE TIMES- BY
WITNESSES THAT- THIS IS REALLY
YOU KNOW THE POOR CONGESTION A
SYMPTOM OF A LARGER GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS. NEARLY
EVERY MENU FOR IN NEARLY EVERY
MANUFACTURED PRODUCT IS
EXPERIENCING COST INCREASES
PART SHORTAGES AND DELAYS. FOR
INSTANCE DUE TO A GLOBAL
SHORTAGE OF MICROPROCESSORS
TRUCK MANUFACTURERS HAVE
STOPPED TAKING ORDERS FOR THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HAVE
GIVEN LITTLE INDICATION AS TO
WHEN PRODUCTION WILL RETURN TO
NORMAL. THIS WILL MAKE MEETING
NEAR TERM REGULATORY DEADLINES
FULLY INTEND TO COMPLY. AND ALL
INDICATIONS ARE THAT THESE
ISSUES WILL PERSIST OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS A SUPPLY
CHAIN STRUGGLED TO RIGHT
THEMSELVES. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE GOODS MOVEMENT
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE MINIMAL
DISRUPTION TO THE SECTOR THAT
SUPPORTS A THIRD OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AND JOBS. AND MAKE LONG
TERM INVESTMENTS IN CRITICAL
FREIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SCHROEDER
VERY VERY WELL DONE- AND
BROUGHT IT DOWN TO KIND OF A
LEVEL WHERE WE CAN UNDERSTAND
IT TOO SO THANK YOU- WITHOUT
WILL NEXT TURN TO RUN HER
DIRECTOR OF THE TEAMSTERS PORT.
DIVISION I BELIEVE MR HER AS ON
THE PHONE TODAY. YES I AM A
SENTIMENT. YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU- START OUT BY
THANKING SENATOR GONZALEZ IN
YOURSELF A SENTIMENTAL DONALD
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING. AND TO ALL
THE LEGISLATORS SCALING
ATTENDANCE AND WATCHING MY NAME
IS RON OR ERIN. AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE PORTS DIVISION
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF TEAMSTERS. THE
CURRENT BACKLOG OF CARGO AT THE
PORTS IS COMPLICATED AND MADE
WORSE BY MANY COMPLEX DYNAMICS
AND SYSTEM FAILURES HOWEVER THE
CHANGES FEEL THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THE CURRENT CRISIS HAS BEEN
DECADES IN THE MAKING. THE
SYSTEMIC MISCLASSIFIED CASE IN
COURT DRIVERS HAS CREATED A
RENEWED A CHAOTIC UNCOORDINATED
AND GOVERNABLE WILD WEST OF THE
PORT'S. BUSINESS CLASSIFICATION
FOR TERRORISTS IS NOT JUST A
LABOR ISSUE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE EXPLOITATION OF IMMIGRANT
DRIVERS. BY MAJOR CORPORATIONS-
SHIFT THE ENTIRE CROSSING
DURING BUSINESS CONTENT DOWN
WHILE PAYING THEM MINIMUM SUB
MINIMUM WAGES AND THE LABOUR
LEADER. SITE EVERY DAY AGAINST
THIS KIND OF EXPLOITATION OF
ASCENTIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
INTEGRAL TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN. A
NEGATIVE CONCEPT CONSEQUENCES
OF MIS CLASSIFICATION EXTEND
BEYOND THE DRIVERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO STRUGGLE TO MAKE
ENDS MEET MISS CLASSIFICATION
IS AT THE CORE OF OUR CURRENT
QUESTIONS. CURRENTLY THERE ARE
OVER TWELVE HUNDRED TRUCKING
COMPANIES REGISTERED TO MOVE
GOOD AT THE PORTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH IN OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND TRUCKS IN
SERVICE AT OUR PORTS THE
OVERWHELMING. MAJORITY OF MEN
AND WOMEN WHO DRIVE THOSE
TRUCKS ARE MISCLASSIFIED BY
THEIR EMPLOYERS DESPITE THE
FACT THAT COMPANIES EXERT
OVERWHELMING CONTROL OVER
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS THERE
AREN'T ABLE TO MAINTAIN A
STABLE WORKFORCE OR KEEP KEEP A
GLOBAL. RUNNING SMOOTHLY. ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
ADDRESS CONGESTION AT THE PORTS
IS TO ADOPT A SYSTEM OF DIRECT
EMPLOYEE DRIVERS INSTEAD OF
SHIFTING CROSSING THE PAD WHICH
TRACKING COMPANIES CAN OPERATE
FLEETS IN GENERAL ADMISSION
VEHICLES. THAT THEY COULD
AFFORD TO BUY I. AND MAINTAIN.
MEETING AND STANDARDS AFTER
IRISH WOULD BE WILD. FAIRLY
COMMON. AND HAVE PAID OFF. SO
THEY COULD HAVE- THE WORK EIGHT
BIG WORK IN NOT BEING SO.
TRUCKING COMPANY COULD USE. TO
EFFICIENTLY SCHEDULE AND DEPLOY
COOLEY OF TRUCKS TWENTY SEN. IF
NECESSARY TO ENJOY THE BACK.
MAKE MONEY WHAT WE'RE THEIR
VITAL. ARE AND SEND DRIVERS TO
BE A OF THE COMPANIES WOULD BE
HE TO SO IN DEMAND. CORDED MINI
SPENDING IS GOING COORDINATE
TRUCKING CAR IN THE IN ENSURE
TRACKING COMP- ABLE TO THE- TO
AND DRIVERS NEEDED TO GUARANTEE.
APPOINTMENT ARE NOT THE SYSTEM
WHAT DID PRETTY CHAU OF TRUCK
DRIVERS BECAUSE DRIVERS WILL BE
THEIR LIVES WAGE AND BENEFITS
AND IT WOULD MEAN THE HUGE. OF
ENTRY WHICH THE CAR OF BUYING
IN MAINE. OUR. THANKS A LOT.
AMERICAN THIS FOR IN ACTION
JOHN SO BEEN FOUND TO BE IN
BECAUSE HE'S- EVERY SEVEN POINT
FIVE SIX THE CREATION OF AMONG
AGENCY STRIVE FORCE IN CORDIAL.
WE GOT THIS I'M- TO ENSURE CAN
SCHEMES DRIVERS CHANGE THE
SPONSOR TO BE THIS YEAR TO
CHANGE THE BUSINESS MY IN THIS
WHICH AT THE- BOTH S. B. EIGHT
AND A BEATLES. NINETY FOUR. WE
TO JOSH. DR SHORTAGE LIKELY
GOOD JOBS THAT OFFER A OUT OF.
DID THOSE NEIGHBORING COME OR
SUFFERED THE MOST PORT POLICE.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD FIND
MORE HIGH ROAD TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR PORT TRUCK DRIVERS THAT
ENSURES. RESPONSIBLE COMPANIES
HELLO SUPPLY OF TRAIN DRIVERS
WITH INCENTIVES FOR LOCAL
HIGHER ONCE WE OF THE JESENICE
CLASSIFICATION REPORTS AND
IMPLEMENT THE LATEST MOST
EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGIES TO
ENSURE EFFICIENCY YOU PS
ALREADY USE IT IT USES ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY COURSE CENTRALIZED
ELECTRONIC DISPATCH WHICH IS
MADE THEM A LEADER IN LOGISTICS
THE ONLY OBSTACLE FOR THE PORTS
IN ADOPTING A SIMILAR SYSTEM IS
A FAILURE OF TRUCKING COMPANIES
TO FOLLOW THE LAW. AND HIGHER
EMPLOYEE DRIVERS ONCE WE WERE
MEETING BOB WE SHOULD ADOPT A
SIMILAR DISPATCHES THEM TO
RELIEVE CONGESTION THANK YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER RAY AND
I KNOW THERE BE A FEW WHICH
PROBABLY READ PRETTY. EXPERT OF
RECORD THANK YOU TO THAT PANEL
FOR FIRMING PAY AND WAIT WE
DIDN'T KNOW THIS HEARING- SO
LONG COUPLE HOURS LATER THAN I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BUT AGAIN
THAT'S AN INDICATION OF THE
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. FOR THIS
LAST PANEL- MISTER BRADFORD.
YES THANK YOU SECURE I HAD A
QUESTION FOR MR JACOB- IT'S NO.
SECRET THAT MANY OF YOUR
MEMBERS HAVE MADE OFF ALL TIME
PROFITS OVER THE LAST YEAR. AND
DURING THE SAME PERIOD- ARE
INDIVIDUAL CONTAINER COSTS HAVE
RISEN. AND THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO AGREE ON AVERAGE. THESE
INCREASES HAVE BEEN DRAMATIC. I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS. YOUR
MEMBERS ARE CHARGING MORE TO
SHIP- CONTAINERS AND MAKING
GREATER PROFITS. WHAT ADDED
VALUE OUR- THE- POINT GETTING
OR OR JUST LITERALLY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF A BAD SITUATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR- CERTAINLY
NOT THE LATTER THE- MARKET
PLACE OBVIOUSLY DRIVES. WHAT
FOLKS WERE CHARGING IT ALSO
DRIVES THE SUPPLY AND DEMAND WE
SEND THE SYSTEM THE SYSTEM IS
OVERWHELMED WITH DEMAND- AND
THE FACT THAT WE'RE SEEING
SHIPS OFF SHORE HERE. IT WAS
REFERENCED EARLIER IS NOT
UNIQUE WE HAVE A HUNDRED FIFTY
SHIPS WAITING BETWEEN THE PORTS
OF SHANGHAI AND NINGBO AS WELL
TRYING TO GET IN THAT LINE- SO
WE HAVE A CAPACITY SHORTAGE.
AND WE ARE MOVING WARSHIPS AND
I'LL BRING MORE SHIPS IN THE
SERVICE- SO YES THERE IS THE
RESULT HIGHER PROFITABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH DOING MORE
BUSINESS TO BE SURE. RATES ARE
HIGHER THAN THEY'VE BEEN
BEFORE- FOR SURE- BUT WE'RE
MOVING MORE CARGO THAN EVER AS
WELL SO. I THINK THE SHORT
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION IS WHAT
CAN BE THE MARKET PLACE RIGHT
NOW IS SUSTAINABLE FROM ALWAYS
SAYING- THERE ARE CERTAIN
PROFITABILITY SWINGS THAT THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO DISCUSS- BACK
AND CERTAINLY YEAH DISCUSSION
WE HAVE. BUT NO ONE BELIEVES
THAT THIS MARKET PLACES
SUSTAINABLE IN THE LONG TIME
LONG TERM- AND- BUT I MIGHT
ALSO POINT OUT THAT. THERE ARE
BETTER MANY MANY YEARS WHERE
ARE INDUSTRY WAS LOSING MONEY-
WE'RE CHARGING NON COMPENSATORY
RATES. FOR A LOT OF. THE
CARRIAGE- BUT CARRIERS A THE
BOARD CERTAIN THE CHARGE MORE
DEMAND IS IT'S HIDING SUPPLIES
SCARCE- AND THAT IS A FUNCTION
OF. PLACE SO. WE CAN WE CAN
JUST A LOT OF DIFFERENT ISSUES
ABOUT THE BUT DON'T THINK.
NECESSARILY PROFITABILITY IN
OUR SECTOR IS A BAD THING- AND
CERTAINLY IT ALLOWS US TO
REINVEST. IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WE NEED TO GROW WE DON'T WANT
TO NOT BE PROFITABLE FOR
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE REINVEST
IN THE TECHNOLOGY WE NEED. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
NEXT GENERATION OF ZERO
EMISSIONS AND ZERO EMISSIONS
EQUIPMENT WE NEED- AND THAT
THAT'S IT THAT'S A CONVERSATION
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE- WITH THE STATE AND-
WITH EVERYONE MOVING FORWARD.
AGAIN I AGREE NO ONCE AGAIN TO
MAKING A PROFIT IT JUST SEEMS
EXTREME AT THIS POINT I THINK
AT ALL TIME HIGH MY LAST
QUESTION IS- WILL THE PORT OF
LA'S CONTAINER- TWELVE FEES.
SHORTEN WITH THE TIME THAT YOUR
MEMBER. COMPANIES LEAVE
CONTAINERS AT THE PORT. BUT
THINK THAT'S THAT'S A FAN
QUESTION- BECAUSE- THE
IMPOSITION OF THOSE FEES. ARE
REALLY UNCLEAR WITH RESPECT TO
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
FILTER INTO THE MARKETPLACE-
BUT A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE
CARGO THAT IS THERE- MOSPORT
DESTINATION CARGO WHICH MEANS
ONCE IT'S DELIVERED. IT'S
ACTUALLY THE RESPONSIBILITY
CONSONANTAL CARGO OWNER TO COME
IN A RANGE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION TO PICK UP THAT
CARGO- SO WHETHER OR NOT YO
IMPOSE A FEE ON. ON A OCEAN
CARRIER REALLY DOESN'T IMPACT
THAT CARGO THAT NEEDS TO BE
ARRANGED- AND- BUT IN GENERAL.
I THINK AS AN INDUSTRY- SAID I
THINK OTHER CARRIERS WOULD
AGREE. THAT AS OU LOOK AT THE
TENSIONS EMERGE POLICIES
THEY'RE THEY'RE CRITICAL TO
KEEPING FLUID IN THE SYSTEM- SO
IN THE LONG TERM HAVING
ADDITIONAL FEES ON ON EXCESSIVE
DWELL SHOULD ACCELERATE. THE
MOVEMENT OF CARGO I REGARDLESS
OF WHO THEY ARE IMPOSED ON SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S MAYES BE SEEN
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS WITH RESPECT
INDIVIDUAL CONTRACTS INDIVIDUAL
CARRIERS AT THE SPORTS-
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF DIFFERENT- PERMUTATIONS IN
THE MARKET PLACE ABOUT HOW.
THESE CHARGES IN MAY OR MAY NOT
RELATE TO CONTRACTS. AND BILLS
OF LADING AND THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS BUT- MORE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WELL.
SHOULD REDUCED. WALK OF THE
LONG TERM. THANK YOU THANK MR
J. WITH A SENATOR GONZALEZ A
QUESTION. YEAH MORE JUST A
COMMON I DO WANT TO THANK- ALL
OF PANELISTS IS ALSO A REALLY
GOOD- DISCUSSION JAKE.
PRESIDENT ONCE ON THIS ACOSTA
MR SHIMODA AND DIRECTOR AND
DATA- I LIKE THE IDEA THAT-
MISTER COSTS AND BROUGHT UP OF
THE JOINT OP CENTER AND I'D
LOVE TO SEE WHAT THAT YU KNOW
LOOKS LIKE AROUND THE- THE
NATION AND HOW WE CAN IMPLEMENT
THAT POTENTIALLY HERE TO. SORT
AGGREGATE ARE ARE OPERATIONAL-
THAT. OUR OPERATIONS OVERALL-
BUT I ALSO WOULD- JUST TOUCH ON
WHAT DIRECTOR HEAD OF ASSET AND
I AND I OF COURSE AND SOME OF
THE HUGE BELIEVER IN THAT WE
NEED TO ENSURE AN ADDRESS
DIRECTLY THAT MISS
CLASSIFICATION ISSUE- AND THE
COMPLIANCE ISSUE AS WELL AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE EMBEDDED IN
THIS DISCUSSION I MEAN AS MUCH
AS WE JUST TALKED ABOUT. LOTS
OF- PROFITS BEING MADE AT THIS
PORT PORT OF LA AND LONG BEACH
OF COURSE UP AND DOWN OUR OUR
CALIFORNIA PORTS BUT THE WORK
FORCE- THAT OUR MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS WELL THAT GET
LEFT BEHIND THEY NEED TO BE
PART OF THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
THE WORK FORCE PROGRAMS- BEING
DELIVERED BY THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS AND I WOULD
JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER AND THAT AND
THAT SPACE TO ENSURETHAT WE
GET TO A PLACE WHERE EVERYBODY
BENEFITS SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
AGAIN AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL. THANK YOU
SENATORS ALSO MR FONG- A ABOUT
MY SON WENT THIS PAN. BY JUST
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- MAYBE
FOR CHRIS AND FOR RIDE. I'M
JUST TRYING TO WRAP MY HANDS.
AROUND WRAP MY HEAD AROUND I
THINK WHAT. THE EXTENT OF THE
TRUCKER SHORTAGE AND HOW MANY.
HOW HOW MUCH SHORT ARE WE AS A
STATE HOW MANY TRUCK DRIVERS DO
WE NEED. AND WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THE LARGEST CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS TO THE SHORTAGE. ALL
UP. ALL THE ALL STARS THE
DRIVER SHORTAGE IS A NATIONAL
ISSUE IF YOU TALK TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS WERE ALL LOOKING FOR
DRIVERS- WHAT WANT TO MAKE VERY
CLEAR THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE DRIVER SHORTAGE. IS A
ROOT CAUSE OF WHAT IS OCCURRING
WITH FOR CONGESTION- HOWEVER-
YOU KNOW I THINK A CENTER DAHLE
ALLUDED TO IT PREVIOUSLY THAT.
DRIVER WAGES ARE OP- MATT
ALMOST UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING
TO ATTRACT MORE DRIVERS INTO
THE WORK FORCE- IN THAT HAS
BEEN CONSISTENT FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS- AND I BELIEVE
THE NUMBER FOUR OWNER OPERATOR
SPECIFICALLY. THEY ARE MAKING
RECORD PROFITS RIGHT NOW THERE
WAS A- ARTICLE IN OVERDRIVE
MAGAZINE WHICH IS SORT OF THE
TRADE MAGAZINE FOR. OWNER
OPERATORS INDICATING THAT SIXTY
THOUSAND ISSUE- OWNER OPERATORS
ENTER THE MARKET THIS YEAR
BECAUSE- WHAT'S CALLED SPOT
RATES WHICH IS THEY GO THEY GO
OUT AND WORK- YOU KNOW FOR NON
CONTRACTED RATES ARE ARE HIGH
BECAUSE OF SIMILAR DYNAMICS-
DUE TO HIGHER DEMAND AND SO-
WITH REGARDS TO TRYING TO
ATTRACT MORE DRIVERS INTO THE
INDUSTRY OUR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION IS TRYING TO GET. A
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSE
AGES LOWERED FROM AGE TWENTY
ONE TO EIGHTEEN. FOR THE REASON
THAT- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WHEN
YOU GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL YOU'RE
LOOKING TO START A TRADE. IF
YOU CANNOT START TRACKING UNTIL
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE RUSINE-
POTENTIAL WORKERS TO OTHER-
TRADES FOR THREE YEARS- WE DO
HAVE THAT ABILITY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU CAN
DRIVE IN TRUST STATE AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN BUT CANNOT CROSS.
STATE LINES ARE HAN HANDLE
INTERNATIONAL CARGO SO- THAT IS
ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS AND AGAIN
JUST WE ARE TRYING TO ATTRACT-
WORKERS WITH HIGHER PAY. I
HAPPEN TO PROVIDE ANY
STATISTICS TO THE S. LIKE
COMMITTEE ABOUT AND I THINK
IT'S ALSO- AND SUPPORT THEIR
VACATION I THINK THAT LOOKING
FORWARD- OUT INTO THE FUTURE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT. WITH THAT THE TRUCK-
TRUCKER SHORTAGE IT'S NOT THE
REASON WHY THERE'S THAT-
CHOKEPOINT AT. THE PORTS BUT TO
IT TO GET TO GET THE TO HEART
AND SUPPLY CHAIN- MOVING
FORWARD WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE SO THANK
YOU. I DON'T KNOW RON HAD AN
ADDITIONAL FROM. YEAH I MEAN
INSTRUCTORS. AT THE PORT IS
BASICALLY INDEPENDENT- DIARIES
THAT. YOU KNOW THEY'VE BEEN-
CHARACTERIZED INDENTURED
SERVITUDE I THINKING. THAT EVEN
THOUGH SOME COMPANIES THAT-
SCENE THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF
RAISING SALARIES NOT ALL CATS.
I THINK THAT THAT IT'S VERY
VERY CRITICAL THAT. YOU KNOW MY
ARGUMENT ABOUT AN EMPLOYEE
STATUS IT IS. TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW- MISTER ZERO. IS BASED ON
TECHNOLOGY AND- TRUCKS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE THEIR OWN
MONITORS. IF WE GET YOU KNOW
THE PORTS EVER GO TO AN
ELECTRONIC DISPATCHING. SO- I
THINK THAT. IT'S ABOUT JOB
QUALITY. THAT WE HAVE THEY
RECRUIT- YOU INTO OUR- OUR- IN
THIS TRADE THE TRADE THAT I
CAME OUT OF. AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT LIKE MR PEROT PAID
BILLION MUCH SPANIEN I THINK
THAT. NEEDS TO. BUT THERE'S
DEFINITELY RECRUITMENT AND
RECRUITMENT BUT I HAVE TO BE
DONE THE- TRAINING AND
UNFORTUNATELY. BENEFITS AND
WAGES. GREAT THANK YOU- WITHOUT
EVER CALMEST. I JUST- LIKELY
DRAW TOWARD ADMIN JAKE OF ONE
TO UNDER THAT IF THERE'S AN
THAT CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT THE
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE AVAILABILITY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THE PORT OF
OAKLAND AS A AS A SOURCE IT'S
BEEN UNDER UTILIZED RIGHT NOW
AND- IN IN ITS DECISIONS. THANK
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- YES
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US
AND OBVIOUSLY I KNOW MY OFFICE
OBJECT ON THE SQUARE IN OAKLAND
NOW AREN'T WE HAVE AN INTEREST
IN MAKING THIS WORK FULLY
UTILIZED. WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE- DEDICATED DIRECT
SERVICE CALLS- INCLUDING TWO
NUMBERS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
SERVICE WITH DIRECT CALLS TO
OAKLAND ANOTHER COMING ONLINE
IN JANUARY- AND UNFORTUNATELY
ONE OF THE- THAT THE THAT. THE
FALLOUTS OF THE DELAYS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS THAT IT
PRECLUDES SERVICE POST IN
OAKLAND AND IN THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST THE PARTS OF TO
COMMON SEATTLE PEOPLE SKIPPING
THOSE STOPS SO IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE HELP FACILITATE. CARGO
MOVEMENTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP GET STRINGS
REESTABLISH THE WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE MOVING SO WE WANT TO
DO BOTH WE WANT TO. INCREASE
DIRECT SERVICE OAKLAND BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO GET SHIPS MILLION
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BACK ON
SCHEDULE- SO THEY'RE CALLING IN
OAKLAND TO. BUT IT IS A- THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. THANK YOU
CAN TO SEE YOU. YEAH THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS MUST AYE
YOU SAID QUITE IS REALLY TO
RECRUITMENT NO DOUBT A WORK
WORKER SHORTAGE SHOWING CAREY
SONG WHAT ARE I. B. I MEAN I O.
W. AND THE TEAM SHE WAS DOING
TO RECRUIT WERE YOU RECRUITING
**** YOU RECRUITING AND WHY
SUCH A LACK OF DIVERSITY- BOTH
IN- GENDER AND- ETHNICITY. I
KNOW FIRST SENATOR- BUT I CAN
ONLY SPEAK IN IN MY ARENA- AND
THAT THE UNIONIZED TRUCK
DRIVING COURSE WHERE- I PREACH
THAT IF YOU WANNA AND SYSTEMIC
RACISM IF YOU WANT EQUALITY IF
YOU WANT WAIT. DO YOU WANT
INDUSTRY STANDARD THEN JOINED
THE TEAMSTERS AND ALLOW US TO.
BARGAIN A CONTRACT FOR YOU-
OVER ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT THAT
WAY. SO I'M NOT GONNA SPEAK FOR
MY BROTHER NOT MINE BUT
DEFINITELY ON OUR SIDE SIR.
WE'RE DOING IN OUR OUR OUR- DO
DEAL. THAT YOU KNOW MAKES THAT.
COLOR AND- GENDER IS THE
PRIORITY HERE BUT OUR
CONTRACTS- HE DID THAT ON THEIR
OWN. MISTER BARCELONA STILL ON.
YEAH YES AND- I SUPPORT A BUT
HERNANDEZ INVENTURE TO CONTINUE.
TO- YOU SEE WAGES BENEFITS TO
OPERATORS ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREA- AS FAR AS THE OUT OF THE
U. IN THE PACIFIC MARITIME WE
HAVE AN ONLINE. MOVEMENT OF
CLASSIFICATIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
WE ALREADY HVE A LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE PMA AND
THE- UNION HAVE ALL. ATTAINTED
THAT LESS IS WON'T WORK ENOUGH
NOW WE CONTINUE TO MOVE THE
SYSTEM WE DON'T HAVE A LABOR
SHORTAGE WE HAVE THE REASON WHY
JUST NOT SEEN WORK REFORMS
BECAUSE INCOMES ARE TO CLOG TO
OPERATE A VESSEL. I JUST THE
OTHER DAY EVERGREEN HAD TO SHUT
DOWN WHICH IS RIGHT ACROSS THE
BAY HERE- THEY HAD TO SHUT DOWN
THEIR SHIP OPERATION BECAUSE
THERE'S NO MORE WE ARE. SO THIS
AS THEY'VE SHOT WE DON'T AT
HAVE A LABOR SHORTAGE HERE IN.
SEVENTY- AND WE'RE CONTINUE TO
MOVE PEOPLE THROUGH OUR SYSTEM-
INTO HIGHER RANKS OF OUR SYSTEM
AND- MOVED MORE PEOPLE OFF THE
LIST THAT- TO BRING HIM INTO
THE SYSTEM TO- WORK DOWN OR
JUST A CASUAL. THANK YOU- THAT
SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT SUBMIT
YOUR QUESTIONS MANY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE PRESENTERS ON PANEL
NUMBER FOUR ACTUALLY ALL PANELS
PROPELLER FOR BEEN VERY PATIENT
SO- I AND THE COMMITTEE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATES IT. WITH THAT-
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE TO BE OUT
pHERE THIRTY FIVE MINUTES AGO.
THIS IS THE LONGEST
INFORMATIONAL HEARING I'VE EVER
BEEN IN- BUT PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT QUITE
FRANKLY SO I WANT TO THANK THE
PRESENTERS THE PARTICIPANTS IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS. PLEASE
GET THEM TO MY OFFICE- OR
CENTER CONSULT OFFICE AS. AT
THIS MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.